Metal Gear is one of the greatest series
of all time but it's one I've never
played until now I've always wanted to
see what these games were about and
after playing them I can truly say that
they are one of a kind as always the
plan is to not only go through the Metal
Gear series and discuss their stories
you know exactly what's going on in
these games but I'll also be critiquing
them along the way there are so many
great themes and messages that the
series has but there's also a ton of
unresolved plots retcons and changes to
fit the current narrative and much more
this is going to be a long one so feel
free to take this at your own pace as I
don't expect you to watch the whole
video or even one game in one sitting
regardless like the video if you enjoy
and subscribe if you're new check out my
other story critiques on games like that
stranding Dark Souls Bioshock and many
more and as always let's get started
the first game we'll be discussing is
1998's Metal Gear Solid one probably the
first question many of you will have is
the order of the video as you can see
from the chapters in the timeline we're
going in release order for a first time
playthrough I always recommend the
release order as more often than not
there is a reason for this order this is
especially true for Metal Gear Solid
given the small number of tweaks in
retcons the series has which is
something we'll discuss later you'll
notice though that I left a few titles
from this video mainly Metal Gear 1 and
2 Metal Gear acid 1 and 2 and portable
Ops I didn't play Acid as I heard it
wasn't Canon but I did play the others I
didn't give them their own sections in
this video though as there wasn't a
whole lot to say about them while I do
want this video to be informative I also
want a nice balance of analysis in it as
well and I couldn't really do that with
these games that's not to say the games
are bad by any means I actually found
them quite fun but it doesn't make sense
for me to dedicate time in the video for
them that being said they will be
helpful in patching up some holes in the
story so while I won't be talking about
them in depth we will occasionally
reference their events throughout this
video either way I just wanted to clear
up the order of games in case anyone was
curious getting on with the video though
metagrosala 1 takes place in 2005 on a
base in Alaska called Shadow Moses just
like the games of old sitting on the
main menu long enough will play a
cutscene that gives us a bit more
background as to what's going on here it
states that not too long ago a group of
terrorists had taken over the base and
are threatening to launch a nuke at the
United States if their demands aren't
met they also have the president of arms
Tech a prominent arms Manufacturing
Company in the world of metal gear named
Kenneth Baker and the DARPA chief of the
United States Donald Anderson held here
as insurance we also learned that the
terrorists are group called foxhound
which apparently snake's old unit they
have a variety of important individuals
within their ranks but we'll meet them
throughout the game so there's no point
in front loading all that information
now that being said I do at least want
to mention the main antagonist and
leader of the group liquid snake clearly
he and Solid Snake have some history but
it's unclear what that is right now what
their demands are is also unknown but as
Solid Snake we're tasked with completing
two objectives first is to rescue the
two aforementioned hostages and then
determine if the terrorists can actually
launch a nuke as they could be bluffing
joining us on this Mission via intercom
is variety of people the three that are
the most important are Colonel Campbell
our main mission advisor Dr Naomi Hunter
a geneticist and master Miller snakes
old Mentor now there are a couple of
others like Mei Ling and Nastasia who
Provide support as well but I want to
focus on the first three so is to not
confuse you this is the main gist of the
game so far and already we're off to a
great start we have our mission and our
objective laid out for us in clear
detail if you wanted to know more though
you could take a look at the briefing
menu which plays a videotape of Naomi
Campbell and snake in a dark room
together Dr Naomi injected snake with
some kind of fluid that contained Nano
machines these are for a lack of a
better word combat steroids that help
his awareness and combat abilities you
get the sense of that snake was coerced
into this Mission by these two prior to
this he said that he had become a dog
musher and was living out here in Alaska
with his 50 Huskies it sounds like he'd
retired from his previous life which we
can assume is related to killing an
Espionage but here he is again going
back to that life this is because
Colonel Campbell has enough dirt on
snake to put him away for good if he
doesn't comply snake sees it as
blackmail Campbell thinks of it as just
helping snake make a decision once we
make it to the base though the game will
officially begin for some odd reason
even though the world is about to be on
the brink of War based on the actions of
one man they didn't opt to give snake a
gun and said force him to scavenge one
himself it's definitely strange but it
does make sense when in the context of
the Gameplay at least Metal Gear Solid 1
is a stealth game but not the typical
kind of stealth where we do sneaky
takedowns from behind cover but more
along the lines of pacifism you
shouldn't kill anyone if you can help it
and by removing any means of attacking
minus your fists includes the player in
as to how they should play the game
overall I felt the gameplay was solid
for the most part with my only gripe
being the map in the top right is a map
that shows the locations of enemies and
cameras as well as their cones of vision
due to how vital the map is you'll often
find yourself staring at the corner of
your screen for the whole game which
really takes away from the beauty right
in front of you outside of that though
and minus a few mechanical hiccups the
gameplay is quite impressive and very
enjoyable snake then makes it to the
cells where the DARPA Chief is located
and he not only tells him that the
terrorists can indeed launch a nuke if
they wanted to but that they also have
the possession of a nuclear battle tank
called Metal Gear Metal Gear looks like
a Mech and is the most advanced piece of
military equipment in the world this
specific Metal Gear is called Rex and is
the most sophisticated one of its kind
as it can launch nukes via its railgun
attachment and due to it not requiring
any specific chemical propellants to
launch it it's practically untraceable
meaning Rex can launch a nuke anywhere
in the world and no one would know until
it hit the ground I don't think I need
to explain how destructive that will be
if it falls into the hands of foxhound
so clearly we gotta do something about
it thankfully the chief has a way for us
to deactivate the mech there are two
passwords that are needed to actually
activate Rex and those passwords belong
to the Chief and Baker the president of
arms Tech who if you remember is also
being held here sadly the chief already
gave up his code since they beat it out
of him but the chief states that in case
the passwords are discovered there are
also three keys that can be used to
override its activation but baby steps
we gotta check on Kenneth before we do
anything because if he didn't talk then
we're good in the cell beside him is a
woman named Meryl silverberg she's later
revealed to be Colonel Campbell's
daughter she was here because she was a
part of Foxon before they were vaulted
see Foxon wasn't originally a group of
terrorists who only became that way once
liquid snake took command of the unit
seems like Merrell didn't agree to the
Betrayal though so they captured her and
threw her in the cell once the info from
Chief Anderson is given to us though he
mysteriously dies it seems to be a heart
attack of some kind but given how
healthy he sounded just a moment ago
it's good that something is going on
here After exiting the cell he meets
with Meryl who points a gun at him
she'll eventually take a brief
opportunity to run away from snake as
the two don't know each other's identity
just yet snake attempts to run after her
but is blocked by psychomantis a member
of foxhound he's only here for a brief
moment but we can see that he has some
magical abilities but a girl solid is a
grounded and realistic series for now at
least but there is a discussion to be
had about whether certain sci-fi
elements are just going too far and
making the game not as realistic as it
used to be psychomantis uses his mind to
read people's thoughts clearly that's
not something normal and definitely
seems more magical but given how he
operates is a boss fight I found his
weird magical abilities to fit as a
character who sort of commits to the bit
this discussion about whether or not
Metal Gear Solid Strays too far from the
shore regarding its realism is something
we'll have to bring up periodically
throughout the video so we'll Circle
back to this later I will say though I
do at least appreciate that the game has
established this now so whenever more
magical abilities start to appear we can
pass it off as something that's a part
of the world since it was shown to us
from the very beginning that Metal Gear
Solid isn't an exact copy of our world
after snake's brief Runa with
psychomantis he finds the armstech
president and Revolver Ocelot another
member of foxhound this is our first
boss fight of Metal Gear Solid 1 and
it's passable boss fights serve as
intense climactic moments that ramp up
the story and while some of them are fun
others aren't ocelots isn't bad it's
just a bit tedious to have to play a
ring around the rosie with him while
Baker is strapped to the wall which is
why I deemed it passable snake manages
to defeat him before ocelot almost gains
the upper hand if not for gray fox
appearing and cutting his hand off he
doesn't say much sadly and both end up
leaving the area while we get a chance
to talk to Baker Baker tells us that he
also gave up the password which means
foxhound can launch the nuke and now our
only way to stop it is with those three
keys the chief talked about he also
gives us an optical disc that has test
data from Metal Gear Rex this was
supposed to go to the Pentagon before
the Takeover happened so Baker wants
Nate to take it with him one thing that
surprised me about this though was right
after this when Baker talks about
nuclear war he monologues about the
state of the world and how nuclear test
sites are not only unmanned but also
left with the rockets and uranium still
inside but on screen is real footage
from actual test sites I've never seen
this done before in a game with maybe
Black Ops 1 being the only other game to
my knowledge but it's genuinely really
fascinating as Metal Gear Solid is tying
a lot of its ideas to real world events
there's also a weird sense of eeriness
that comes from these clips as they're
portrayed in this mysterious and creepy
way like we're seeing classified footage
that meant for the public eye Kojima
wanted to bridge the gap between games
and movies as at the time those things
were pretty much mutually exclusive
while it may not have been the first
Metal Gear Solid one was a driving force
for this movement oddly enough one of
the complaints levied at the game was
that it felt more like a piece of art
rather than a game funny how times have
changed 20 years later it's just one of
the many things within the game that
truly showcases how far out of the curve
metal gearsala was when compared to its
competition this attempt at making video
games into movies though does end up
coming with the caveat and that's lots
of dialogue there are many moments
throughout the game where the gameplay
stops to either show a cutscene or to
have snake talk on the codec with his
team and some of these conversations can
last upwards of 10 minutes this isn't a
metal gear solid one issue but rather a
whole series issue as many of the future
games continue to perpetuate this idea
in fact some of them are arguably worse
as Kodak calls last upwards of 20
minutes at a time Kojima has a real tell
Dawn show style of Storytelling which is
never something I've been a fan of metal
Garcia loves to take time out of the
script to ramble about pointless details
or over explain something for some
reason it almost always puts these calls
back to back as well so you'll find
yourself listening to people talk for 10
minutes walk four feet and then hear
another 10 minute conversation I think
most of my disdain for them though
revolves around them stopping times you
can listen to them some of the future
games replace these calls with cutscenes
or just have regular radio chatter play
while you walk around allowing you to
actually get stuffed on while listening
to them but for the first few entries
Kodak calls her with a bulk of our
information will come from which plays
into that telbone show style that Kojima
seems to love but as I said though this
isn't an mgs1 problem rather a series
wide issue regardless after we talked to
Baker he too dies of a mysterious heart
attack clearly something is going on
here and one of mgs1's strengths is its
ability to interweave its active plot
with its overarching plot before Baker
dies he mentions the Pentagon and how he
didn't actually think they would use it
we don't know what it is but it could be
related to what is killing him this
coupled with the numerous hidden details
that Colonel Campbell will reluctantly
tell us throughout the game points of
this being more than just a simple
Mission and that snake has not been told
the full extent of the mission this
makes the player want to know more they
want to know what's going on and they
can't do that unless they keep playing
so story wise mgs1's ability to keep the
player hooked while also simultaneously
setting up an overarching plot alongside
its active plot is downright impressive
and hooked me immediately with both the
hostages dead though things are not
looking good thankfully all hope is not
lost not only is Meryl still here but
according to Baker Hal Emerick the lead
researcher on Metal Gear Rex is also
here and could help us with our
objective talking with Merrell gives us
a bit more information about foxhound
which we've already discussed as well as
the very important detail that for some
odd reason sounds snake looks exactly
like liquid snake hell Emerick though is
held up in a lab nearby and might be the
progenitor of kojima's mind going off
the rails I mentioned in my last video
on death straining that Kojima likes to
mix the series with the stupid sometimes
like how we go from a climactic boss
fight with Higgs to walking along the
beach with Amelie at the time I had no
idea why Kojima did this and thought it
was just more reason to believe that he
became unhinged after leaving Konami but
it seems like it's always been like this
for a while as Emrick oozes that exact
feeling take a listen as to why emrick's
nickname is Otakon and why he's
fascinated with metal gears
what's with these guys it's like one of
my Japanese animes forget it talk to her
it stands for otaku convention and otaku
is a guy like me who likes Japan
animation I became a scientist because I
wanted to make robots like the ones in
the Japanese animes really it's true
it's just absurd that the majority of
emberg's personality is based on how
obsessed he is with anime what's even
better is that oticon is not a one-off
character but honestly one of the more
important ones in the series to sound
like Kojima just stuck this on a random
nobody he wanted this to be one of the
defining characteristics of one of the
series main characters and I don't know
if I should shake my head in disbelief
or clap and approval all the characters
in this game have very deep personal
backstories like snake who's a grizzled
war veteran who's done some terrible
things and has to deal with the traumas
of war or Nastasia who grew up in
Ukraine and was exposed to radiation
when Chernobyl exploded causing her
family and many others to die and then
we have oticon who's so much of a weave
that he became obsessed with military
mechs as I said I truly believe this is
the origin point of kojima's unstable
mind is only he would have been crazy
enough to make this and be dead serious
about it that being said otakhan is very
likable and he plays the traditional
role of the geeky nerd and he plays it
extremely well he's scared of conflict
he wets his pants when gray fox Corners
him and he cowers in fear when he and
snake start fighting it's a classic
archetype but it works well and that
goes for a lot of characters in this
game Snake plays the standard military
protagonist who's the only man for the
job Campbell is the deep voice officer
who relays orders and we're all sort of
a damsel in distress and love interest
although it's not as basic as other
media handle it this won't be the last
time I bring this up but okay solid one
plays like a very generic action movie
which further reinforces kojima's whole
plan of Bridging the Gap between movies
and games
just a second ago I said that gray fox
and snake would fight and that is
happening right now the fight changes up
the mechanics a bit as you're supposed
to fight him with your fists rather than
your guns Owen speak on Gray Fox too
much for now but it's revealed after a
fight with him that he's an old war
buddy of snakes and he was killed years
ago but clearly he's alive now so he
must have been revived this is also a
good time to bring up those retcons and
inconsistencies I talked about earlier
as games go on stories change and
evolves it's only natural a few mistakes
look at the cracks this is especially
true for metal gear solid as kojima's
been quoted as saying that mgs3 was the
last game but due to fans demanding
answers for what happened in mgs2 he had
to create mgs4 at the time Kojima likely
had plot threats he wanted to leave
unanswered or up to interpretation but
now that he had to make a new game he
needed answers to questions he likely
didn't have answers to this is how a lot
of retcons and additions occur and it's
because of this I've developed a method
to the madness basically my role for the
series has been whatever the most recent
game says is Canon is Canon these are
the most recent works at The Times They
reflect kojima's current mindset clearly
he has a much better idea of where he
wants to take the series in something
like Metal Gear Solid 3 as opposed to
Metal Gear 1. as it's hard to plan that
far ahead especially if you don't plan
on making that many games in the first
place the reason I bring this up is
because of this conversation with Naomi
regarding gray fox she says that gray
fox Will Survive using gene therapy
thanks the way Dr Clark she refers to Dr
Clark as a he but we see Dr Clark and
Metal Gear Solid 3 and she's very
clearly a woman it's clear that the team
either didn't remember this detail and
made a mistake or decided to change this
rather inconsequential detail to fit the
current narrative regardless going back
to the method if we follow it that means
that Dr Clark is and always has been a
woman even though Naomi calls Dr Clark
he mgs3 shows them as female so she's a
woman I'm definitely making this way
more complicated than it needs to be and
don't worry I won't be intentionally
adding details on a retcon than myself
later just to spare you the headache but
I felt like I should mention in case
anyone has been or becomes confused
regarding some of the events of the game
is there's a good chance that it was
just retconned or change in a future
entry obviously I'm not a huge fan of
this in and do with some of the series
details were less flimsy but sometimes
that's the difficulty of game design you
can't always plan ahead and sometimes
you're forced to make fewer or more
games than you intend which really
throws a wrench in your story if you had
a specific goal in mind getting back on
track one snake defeats gray fox he
freaks out and disappears the suit seems
to be causing him to be mentally
unstable which is why he screams out in
pain before cloaking and running away
snake then talks to oticon who vows to
help snake as he doesn't want his
research to be used by terrorists he
also understands he has to take personal
responsibility for this as he helped
create Rex so for the rest of the game
oticon is going to be our helpful guy
that will tell us how to get to certain
parts of the base
snake and Maryland meet face to face
again but it's more friendly this time
the two also have quite a serious talk
about war
snake is known as a hero to many people
in the world of metal gear but snake
doesn't see himself as one he believes
that he's just someone who's good at
killing he further states he only fights
for himself he doesn't care about the
people he helps in these missions as he
has no goal no life and no purpose
Solid Snake depicts the perfect Soldier
someone who's good at what they do and
doesn't do anything but what they're
told he really should be called a hollow
snake because he's really just a shell
of a man and luckily the main reason he
joined this Mission because he only
feels alive on the battlefield his
current life of dog mushing was an
attempt to keep himself busy so as to
not be afflicted by his PTSD in his want
to kill but clearly that didn't work
since he's here trying to save the world
it's a very important part of snake's
character and is something that will
have more weight once we get to the end
snake and Marilyn opt to work together
to defeat liquid snake which lasts a
grand total of two minutes as they
encounter psychomantis again he
temporarily takes control of Merrell
forcing snake to knock her down so that
he can deal with him after psychomantis
is probably the worst fight in this game
and it's entirely my fault psychomantis
is famously known for breaking the
fourth wall during battle in your
conversation with him he'll demonstrate
his psychic abilities by vibrating your
controller he'll also comment on your
current playthrough stats like calling
you Reckless if you haven't saved much
he'll also comment on your game saved on
your memory card like Castlevania
another Konami title unfortunately all
of this is removed in the PC version
which is the version I played the one
thing that kills all the games the
fastest is accessibility finding an
original game and respective Hardware
can be expensive at times which is why I
was thankful that Gog had the PC version
for just ten dollars what I had only
learned after beating the game that this
version removes one of the best parts of
psychomantis's boss fight with any
consolation though the game does at
least keep the controller poor gimmick
it's just your keyboard instead
psychomantis has the ability to read
your mind so he'll be able to dodge her
attacks Colonel Campbell says that to
defeat psychomantis you have to switch
your controller to the other port on the
console or for me it was using the
keyboard instead of the controller I had
plugged in this allows you to clear your
mind preventing mantis from predicting
your moves and thus making the fight
fairer this isn't the only time the game
forced you to do some out of the box
thinking either as to contact Merril you
need to look at the back of the CD case
you might assume it's the optical this
we got from Baker but it literally means
the back of the game's case as there's a
picture of Merrell along with a
frequency
similar to our talks about the real
footage used in the game it's something
I've never seen done before after
playing both death straining in Metal
Gear Solid I've really come to the
conclusion that Kojima just likes making
games and I don't mean that in the
obvious definition but more so that he's
not afraid to embrace what games can do
many games want to keep the player
immersed and try to remove as much of
the game's system as possible but Kojima
fully Embraces it by having you use
things outside of the game to progress
using a different port or looking at the
back of the game's case is immersion
breaking but it's Unique as no one would
dare try to do this especially nowadays
due to how many games that try their
hardest to keep the player immersed the
games that don't and embrace what they
are are remember more fondly if you've
played Metal Gear Solid 1 and still
remember this moment then it worked as
without these fourth wall breaks
psychomantis would just be another dead
villain in the series but this sets him
apart from everyone else and stays in
your mind is that one time you had to
swap controllers to kill a boss
what psychomantis said the two can
continue on but we have a chance to talk
to him before he passes metal grassola
one does this too with the other bosses
and is definitely used as a way to
humanize these villains and give us a
chance to learn more about their life
psychomantis had a pretty rough
upbringing as his mother died giving
birth to him which caused his father to
resent him he would then surely discover
his power to read minds and when he read
his fathers and realized how much hatred
he had for mantis fearing that he would
be killed by his own father he burned
his village to the ground killing him in
the process
he also started wearing a mask around
this time as a way to prevent unwanted
thoughts from entering his mind his
final line is him revealing to us that
he never cared for liquid's goal he just
wanted to kill as many people as
possible psychomantis is unsurprisingly
a psycho but his unique abilities forced
unwanted feelings and thoughts into his
mind which plagued him for years so it's
no wonder he ended up the way that he
did Mathis believes that all humans are
born into this world to spread misery
and pain instead of Happiness
furthermore he believes that by Nature
were designed to pass on our DNA to the
Next Generation which is why War exists
he is a very nihilistic view of the
world but like I said it's hard not to
see where he's coming from given his
rough upbringing snake then puts his
mask on allowing psychomantis to be by
himself in his final moments despite
being a hardened and emotionless person
at the time we can see that he does
start to care for the people he's
killing not in the sense that he
sympathizes with them but rather
recognizes that they're all just
soldiers and that none of them are
really the true winners here regardless
of the outcome real let's say they
continue forward and after I'm not even
joking another two minutes they come to
blows with another member of fox sound
of Sniper Wolf Wolf shoots Merrell in
both legs and her left arm leaving her
to bleed out on the floor this was done
not to kill her but to lure snake out so
that she could kill him snake recognizes
this and determines that he needs a
sniper in order to defeat her which
leads to the most confusing and
infuriating 15 minutes I had with this
game getting a sniper rifle requires us
to go back to one of the earlier levels
before we fought ocelot so we can open a
door grab the sniper and then go all the
way back firstly Merrill will shop a
high-powered sniper three times I'm
surprised she's not already dead and
secondly doing this removes all the
dramatic tension this brought to the
table this is literally like to win the
final mission of a game but then
stopping right before the final boss
fight to go grind side quests you've
just removed all the stakes by removing
the player from the encounter entirely
the fight isn't even that fun either and
I already dread doing this again if I
ever boot this game up in the future the
sniper can only be scoped in so the game
forces you to stay put and use the scope
to see the problem is that you can't aim
and pee click on more modern game so you
have to step in her line of fire just to
aim this means you have very little time
to aim and shoot her to make things
worse not only does snake scope sway
more than a drunk after happy hour but
if wolf shoots you will scoped in your
aim jolts in a random Direction my
strategy was to position myself facing
her and then scope in with the hope that
I find her if I took too long of a shot
I would unequip the gun face forward and
then re-equip it right after this was
the only reliable method I found that
worked there are some drugs that reduce
the sway which is almost a requirement
to beat it but that still doesn't get
over the more important hurdle the game
also really rubbed the salt in my wound
here since you have to fight her again
later in the same problems arise here
too
now I have heard that you can use the
two missile launchers to defeat her but
I didn't get a chance to test that out
myself so I can't say for certain but
what I can say is that this fight was a
mechanical nightmare from the
questionable setup of leaving Merrill to
die just to fetch a gun to the fight
being a complete hassle it was
definitely a sore spot in this otherwise
great game
that being said there is a light at the
end of the tunnel here as snake doing
this is rather unsurprising it seems
like snake has really taken a liking to
Merrell and was willing to fall into a
trap if it means saving her which is
just another example of our emotionalist
soldier boy showing some real humanity
and making his own decisions for once
assuming you can beat sniperwolf snake
then runs down the hall and gets
captured by her as it turns out she's
not actually dead snake then wakes up in
a torture room next to liquid snake and
ocelot liquid also states that he and
Solid Snake are the last surviving sons
of big boss implying that they're not
only Brothers but that this big boss
fella is their dad this is not as simple
as it seems though as they aren't just
brothers but I'll explain that shortly
to add to the mystery liquid seems to
not know what killed Baker it wouldn't
have been too far-fetched to assume that
liquid had a hand in his death but it
seems like he has nothing to do with
that liquid then leaves to deal with
launch preparations while ocelot
tortures snake he tells snake that if he
gives up then Meryl is dead but it's
going to require a lot of mental
fortitude and strength to deal with the
pain for the player this means
repeatedly tapping the circle button so
you can regain your health you actually
have the option to surrender here just
as also says but he keeps up his end to
the deal and Merrell will die there are
two endings in mgs1 one where Meryl is
dead and the other where she isn't and
it's right here where the ending is
decided to spoil things it is Canon that
Merrell lives given a future title so
snake was able to withstand the
punishment luckily because he wanted to
keep Merrill safe in between these
torture sessions snake is then sent to a
cell and can talk to some of the support
team we hear again that big boss was
solid snake's father but we also learned
that big boss died because solid snake
killed him after being tortured though
and sent back a final time snake ends up
being broken out by gray fox snake can't
catch a break though it seems as he gets
into another boss fight with Sniper Wolf
shortly after escaping defeating her
this time actually kills her which
upsets oticon it seems like oticon has
developed some kind of Stockholm
syndrome as he was in love with
sniperwolf during his captivity aracan
couldn't simply be killed due to his
knowledge of metal gear wreck so they
kept him around but forced him to keep
working this was likely around the time
he met wolf and developed a connection
with her even if it was possibly
one-sided aracan is very naive and very
fragile mentally I mean he's troubled by
everything that's going on here and it's
still hard for him to wrap his head
around it which is likely why he found
comfort in Sniper Wolf just like with
mantis though Sniper Wolf gives us her
backstory before dying she was born on
the battlefield and because of that all
she knew was war someday she would wake
up and some of her family were dead the
governments of the world weren't able to
help her or her country so she felt
helpless until big boss came and rescued
her she owed her life to him and would
never forget it but thanks to her
Newfound Freedom she lost sight of her
purpose in life she joined liquid so she
could take revenge on the world that
wronged her but that's not what she
wanted she just wanted to live but she
felt like she needed to do something
about her underlying anger this caused
her to lose sight of her purpose and be
the death of her as it was just now that
she realized that she was never waiting
around to kill people would rather
waiting for someone to kill her shortly
after this and I'm starting to sound
like a broken record here but we're
thrown into another boss fight this time
against Vulcan Raven now admittedly it's
not as badly paced as I'm making it out
to be it's just that a lot of stuff in
between these fights are combat
encounters so there isn't much to
discuss here I will say though that the
gameplay never got boring throughout its
entire run time and the pace of the game
felt well balanced there are still those
long dialogue sequences that could
bother some people but personally I
didn't mind it as it added more depth
and personality to the cast Raven though
is kind of strange he's a shaman that
has spiritualistic abilities and he's
about as stereotypical as you can get
most of the things he says are vague
like the path you walk has no end and he
claims to be one with the Ravens that
follow him all that's missing is some
kind of voodoo magic that causes
hallucinations but seeing as we already
have that with psycho mantis they opted
to give him a minigun instead I think
out of all the villains he's just the
one I couldn't get into his fight was
fun I just didn't like him his story is
kind of boring if I'm being honest and
it doesn't really add anything to the
narrative he says that snake and liquid
are from another world and one he does
not wish to given what happens at the
end I understand what he means by this
but then why did he join liquid in the
first place and why is he so keen on
helping us he gives us the key card we
need to actually deactivate wreck since
we lost it earlier and tells us that the
DARPA Chief was actually another member
of foxhound disguised as him it's a bit
out of character for someone like him
whereas psychomantis and wolf didn't
spill any details on liquid or his plan
but did mention how they only joined for
their own personal gain
circling back though that plot twist was
great it's also possible to Guess The
Twist before it happens as after
psychomantis first appears we see the
DARPA Chief in the torture room we were
in earlier but that doesn't make sense
since he apparently died in that room
but he's also dead in his cell on top of
that while in our cell we see the corpse
of the chief but it seems more
decomposed than it should be seeing as
he just died a few hours ago meaning
he's been dead a long time before we got
here the question then is why did decoy
octopus give us the details on how to
stop Rex if he's working with liquid
while he was lying to us too something
that's very consistent across the series
that the last few hours are full of
answers and it starts right about here
see the key was not a deactivation but
rather an activation code psychomantis
accidentally killed the DARPA Chief
before they could get his password so
they had decoy octopus trick snake into
thinking the key was to shut down Rex
rather than activate it but that still
doesn't explain why he died after
meeting with us well do you remember
when I told you snake was injected with
Nano machines before the mission well
inside the syringe was also something
called Fox die a virus that can kill
specific people unbeknownst to snake he
had carried this virus in him and and
unintentionally killed the members of
Foxon when he came in contact with them
the reason Baker was included seems to
be related to its creators the Pentagon
was behind the virus as they wanted to
kill the members of foxhound along with
those familiar with the metal gear
Project without any destruction so they
could keep the facility and Metal Gear
wrecks intact but snake is also part of
the Unlucky few who will be killed by
this thanks to Dr Naomi altering the
virus Dr Naomi wants to and doesn't want
to kill snake throughout the game since
the beginning her loyalties have been
questionable since she worked for
foxhound and the truth comes out during
this time Dr Naomi's family was killed
during a Civil War when she was a girl
but she ended up being saved by a Frank
Yeager who we know as gray fox oddly
enough gray fox was the person who
killed their family but he couldn't deal
with the guilt so he decided to raise
her instead the two were then considered
step siblings who later moved to the
United States thanks to the help of big
boss she has beef with snakes since he
killed big boss and gray fox a few years
ago he killed the two most important
people in her life which is why she
altered the virus to include snake she's
also responsible for Reviving gray fox
that he could fight him he was
originally taken from the battlefield
fill them fixed up into a cybernetic
suit but Naomi helped him escape the
facility the problem is that this event
made him unstable when he started losing
his mind and identity which is why he
freaks out after we beat him gray fox
didn't plan to kill snake though I mean
he did but he didn't care gray foxes
wanted to fight snake against that he
may die a warrior like how he was
supposed to before he was revived he's
sort of like a ghost trying to find his
place to die gray fox will end up dying
but arguably in a much better way than
originally intended as he dies saving
snake rather than fighting him because
right after inputting the keys stink
realizes he's been tricked and liquid
takes the opportunity to Pilot Rex but
the manipulation goes even further as
Master Miller snake's Mentor was
actually a liquid snake the whole time
this one is admittedly a bit easier to
spot as they both sound the same plus it
was stated that the frequency of the car
was short range meaning Miller was
nearby which doesn't make any sense is
the only thing nearby is the base I
really must express my gratitude
sorry to have involved you in that silly
shape memory alloy business
did you like my sunglasses
a big contributor to the notion that
Metal Gear Solid is confusing is that
it's a series of backstabs double
crosses and plot twists all put together
in a jumbled package while it is all
very confusing to decipher especially
when it happens in the span of 30
minutes I found that the plot twists
were handled quite well I've always
disliked when plot twists are just
thrown in and you're expected to be
surprised when that idea wasn't even on
the table to begin with but mgs1 teased
the presence of decoy octopus and liquid
in a great way one that's subtle enough
to not draw your attention but obvious
enough to wear once you hear it you
think how did I not get that the first
time
seeing as we made it to the finale
though it's time for even more answers
man the biggest one the relationship
between liquid and solid snake they are
not just twins but rather clones a big
boss in the 70s there was a project
called liaison voltarib or the terrible
children project the point was to take
big boss the greatest soldier ever made
and clone his DNA to make soldiers just
like him this is very similar to the
Human Genome Project which the game
actually references the Project's goal
was to determine and map out the base
pairs of DNA in our body this could help
with a variety of things like genotyping
specific diseases as well as identifying
mutations but many feared though that
this could create a societal problem
where people are discriminated against
based on their genetic makeup a metal
gear solid this was expanded upon as
Society had found over 60 different
Soldier genes these were genes that
would be used to benefit soldiers like
increased stamina and physical strength
the soldier genes were used to create
the genome soldiers we faced throughout
the game while big boss's DNA was used
to create the Clones they also made the
Clones unable to reproduce so as to not
spread big boss's genes and also made
them age faster than normal humans so
they wouldn't be able to Rebel or in
case someone had taken them for their
own gain originally there were eight of
them but six of the Clones were aborted
the only two to survive were solid and
liquid snake this is why we've never
heard their real names before I know
we're skipping ahead a bit but big
boss's code name before being called big
boss was naked snake this is likely why
solid and liquid snake are called that
seeing as their clone's a big boss but
those are just code names we don't know
their real names because they weren't
designed to have one their purpose in
life was to be soldiers so who cares
about extra formalities like names or
family Metal Gear Solid alongside its
plot also has a theme or message that
Kojima wants to convey to the player an
mgs1's theme is Gene as in your genetics
cells think was created to be a soldier
that's his whole purpose but the game is
telling you that you shouldn't let your
genes control your destiny Solid Snake
was created with some of the best
soldier genes in the human body he's
supposed to be a soldier because
genetically that's what he was made to
do but your genes do not make you who
you are that's the message of mgs1 we
learned during the finale that liquid
snake is superior to Solid Snake
genetically so by those metrics liquid
stank should win but he does wasn't we
defeat him the inferior one wins this
proves your genes don't inherently make
you a better person and you shouldn't
let your genes determine what you should
do with your life Dr Naomi is another
good example she wasn't old enough to
know much about her family or her past
life so she became a geneticist to learn
more about herself so she could figure
out what to do with her life she
realized though that this way of
thinking is wrong and that she should be
the one to determine her life not her
genetics it's a simple message but it
works really well and it uses elements
of the game to explain it if solid snake
a person born to be a soldier can become
more than what his genes tell him to be
then you can too
liquid was someone who couldn't see past
their genes and they did what they were
made to do he tells us how he wanted to
create a world where they needed
soldiers like him soldiers are a Dying
Breed so he wanted to create endless
conflicts that the world always needed
soldiers always needed people like him
but this isn't even his dream it's
actually the dying wish of big boss he's
just carrying the torch but we obviously
can't let that happen though War may be
an inevitable part of the human psycho
but that doesn't mean it's something
that should be continued snake rejects
this idea and says that he shouldn't
follow what big boss says liquid finds
this ironic as if he truly believed that
then he wouldn't be here remember Solid
Snake is a soldier and he said many
times before that he likes the
adrenaline of being in war that's why he
took the job because he enjoys killing
doing these missions makes him feel
alive or at least they used to snake has
grown throughout the game thanks to
Merrell as for the first time he's found
someone to live for
Otakon and snake frequently have this
talk about love and if it can truly
Bloom on the battlefield this was mostly
directed at oticon's love for Sniper
Wolf but was also talking about snake
and Merrell snake is not afraid to flirt
with his female team members but it felt
different with Merrell like it was more
serious rather than playful the two of
them have grown a deep love for each
other over the course of the game and
it's great to see snake gain a purpose
in life now it's just a shame that his
brother couldn't find one snake and
Maryland end up driving a Jeep out of
the base because Campbell tells him that
the US military is coming by to blow up
the facilities they can cover up what
happened here Campbell's trying to call
them off but we need to leave now just
in case Maryland snake then leave but
liquid is right behind them before they
both crash just outside the tunnel
leading out of the base liquid is about
to kill snake before succumbing to the
Fox die virus at the time this is very
concerning since we're told that the
virus didn't affect liquid so Solid
Snake should be fine since they're
genetically similar but liquid snake is
dead which means snake will die too
snake then asked Dr Naomi when he'll die
but she doesn't tell him she actually
doesn't know because she altered it to
be a random value at least that's what
this game says anyway but she tells him
that that's not important what's more
important is that you just live
you can input all the genetic
information but that doesn't make them
into the strongest soldiers
the most we can say about DNA is that it
governs a person's potential strengths
potential destiny
[Music]
you mustn't allow yourself to be chained
to fate to be ruled by your genes
humans can choose the type of Life they
want to live
snake
whether or not you're in the Fox die
program isn't important
the important thing is that you choose
life
and then live
Metal Gear Solid ends with Maryland
snake riding a snowmobile off into the
sunset is Campbell says the secretary of
defense was arrested as this was all his
idea and that the bombing was called off
in short liquid is dead and the world is
safe at least for now as in after credit
scene shows ocelot calling someone who
is not only the third clone of big boss
solidist snake but also the president of
the United States
Metal Gear Solid was ahead of its time I
don't like using that phrase often but
it's true Kojima had set out to create a
bridge between the world of video games
and movies and he succeeded in doing so
mgs1 plays like a typical action game it
felt like the plot of a bond or Die Hard
movie but that's a good thing as games
were lacking a lot of the flare movies
had back then the tech for games in the
late 90s was definitely inferior to that
of movies but if MGS one has taught me
anything it's that you shouldn't let
yourself be defined by your genetic
makeup mgs-1 was something that no one
thought was possible and it's truly a
one of a kind everything from the fourth
wall breaks to the cliche script may not
seem like much nowadays but the team of
Konami was doing this in 1998. it's just
one of the many things that set Metal
Gear Solid apart from other games at the
time and even now doing this kind of
Storytelling two decades ago was almost
unheard of and it's this unique aspect
of the game that allowed Metal Gear
Solid to propel itself into the future
where it could take things even further
Metal Gear Solitude was released only a
few years later and also happens to take
place a few years later as well we first
start in 2007 with the man himself Solid
Snake after the incident of Shadow Moses
snake and oticon worked together under
the name philanthropy with the sole
purpose of putting a stop to metal gears
and their producers that's why snake is
here on this tanker as they received a
tip that a new amphibious Metal Gear
called Rey is stationed here Metal Gear
Solid one set up the idea that metal
gears were things that were rare and
classified and they were until that game
happened what snake was being
interrogated back at the base ocelot
took the CD that Baker gave us the one
that has all the test data on Metal Gear
X he sold that info to the highest
bidder and how various countries and
private organizations have the blueprint
secret Metal Gears of Their Own snake
and oticon with the help of some other
friends like nastasha from the last game
had hoped to put a stop to this once and
for all but it's been difficult
Nostalgia wrote a book that outlined the
events of the previous game but it took
a while for Publishers to take her
seriously snake also has to do covert
operations like this just to expose
these people so it's not been simple
snake's actions though have earned a
negative reputation against Metal Gear
manufacturers which led to him getting a
bounty placed on his head this seems to
have caught up to him as once he lands
on a tanker ocelot appears and seems to
be expecting snake we'll see a bit more
of him in just a moment but the reason
snake is here is because of metal gear
Ray the tanker also seems to be owned by
the US military so it's safe to assume
that this tanker is a disguise that no
one suspects a metal gear is inside it
seems like we weren't the only ones who
saw through its illusion though as
suspense and as soldiers survive and
take the tanker hostage their leader is
Sergey gurlukovic we heard his name in
passing back in mgs-1 thanks to ocelot
but other than that we haven't heard too
much about him even now that he's
present we still don't learn too much
about him but we do know that his
daughter Olga is on this Mission with
him and not only does he not want her
here but she's also pregnant wound up
coming to flows with her and have to
take her down when she spots us don't
worry we're not killing her or the kid
as snake is equipped with a tranquilizer
this time around now this does still
call into question what a dozen track
rounds that are strong enough to take
down an elephant can do to a pregnant
woman but that's for another time snake
then makes it to the bottom of the ship
or the commander of the army Scott Dolph
is giving a speech about Metal Gear Ray
we then have to Traverse through various
rooms without getting caught so we could
take pictures of the metal gear allowing
us to expose it on the internet I know
this sounds a little bizarre a snake is
an American and basically hindering the
military capabilities of his own country
but not only are the Russians here so
stopping this would prevent them getting
it too but Metal Gears could be
considered too far many people nowadays
want countries to remove and dismantle
their nuclear missiles as they believe
it's too dangerous the metal gears are
even worse by comparison given what we
know of Rex and its design Metal Gears
being spread means everyone is going to
arm themselves with them bringing us
closer to the complete annihilation of
the species Metal Gears could easily
topple third of all countries that don't
have the money to make them and the
countries that could create them would
essentially eliminate themselves in the
process the proper term here would be
mutually or destruction if Russia nukes
the U.S the U.S or retaliate with their
own nukes and that would keep going
until they both wiped themselves off the
map so it's clear that it doesn't matter
who has them they shouldn't even exist
in the first place which is why we have
to stop them snake then takes the photos
and sends them to oticon then right
after this for reasons that are beyond
my comprehension urlukovic is able to
hold the commander hostage even with a
dozen men right next to him ocelot then
shows up and says that he's taking the
metal gear instead and shoots both the
commander anger lukovic without so much
as a shot fired back at him then
proceeds to put down only a couple of
the few dozen soldiers in this room
without being shot at once again and
then somehow walks to the metal gear
while all the bullets miss him clearly
the US and garlukovy to hire better men
if this is the state of their military
my terrible nitpicks aside ocelot says
during the scene that the metal gear
belongs to the Patriots at the time we
were unaware of what these Patriots are
but we'll hear more about them soon
furthermore ocelot seems to be
struggling with his new arm if we recall
from our time with mgs1 gray fox caught
ocelot's arm off during our boss fight
with him wasilot seems to have had his
arm replaced with liquid snakes arm as
he temporarily takes control during our
talk with him you know who I am
liquid
not so young anymore a snake God only
knows how that's even possible but
shortly after this the tanker will then
explode Metal Gear Ray escapes with
ocelot and control the mech and snake is
Left To Die in the middle of the ocean
we then skip ahead two years to 2009
where we're sent to investigate another
terrorist takeover a group called Dead
cell along with some Russian Spence and
has seized control of a decontamination
facility called Big Shell the official
group of him is called the Sons of
Liberty they're asking for 30 billion
dollars in cash is their main demand as
insurance they also have the president
of the United States as well as other
government employees as hostages we are
tasked with rescuing these hostages and
stopping the terrorists from blowing up
the big shell but we won't be doing it
with snake
the terrorists call themselves Sons of
Liberty Sons of Liberty the name of
their leader is Solid Snake
hero of Shadow Moses so that's why you
changed my code name right but he can't
be the Solid Snake he died two years ago
on that tanker after he blew its sky
high
in addition to being a new character
Ryden is also the official protagonist
going forward Metal Gear Solid is a game
about deception and lies it's also about
Twos for some reason it's game number
two with two chapters two different
years two main characters and is also
responsible for splitting the community
into two groups all those former
statements are what contributed to the
latter's reaction this game lies to you
constantly hell even before the game was
out it was lying to you it's definitely
getting a bit ridiculous at this point
but if we were to add another two I
would put the last of us part two that's
because this game and the last of us
went through similar experiences in the
trailer for The Game naughty dog hate or
outright replaced Joel on specific
cutscenes so as to not spoil the plot
gojima did the Same by hiding rodden
from the general public his name was
never mentioned or teased until this
moment which caught a lot of players off
guard since they likely bought the game
to play a snake this also isn't a
one-off mission either as just like Abby
the player is going to be stuck with
riding until the end as he's the true
protagonist of the game as you would
expect both games received immense
backlash for this decision but I'd argue
Ryden was even worse Ryden was so poorly
see that not only did the team add new
missions called snake Tales allowing you
to play a snake in some of the following
missions that the players can have that
feeling of playing a solid snake again
but there's an entire character in mgs3
called Ivan radanovich rykoff whose
whole existence is to be a parody of him
to say he was poorly received as an
understatement but just like this game
as a whole I think it got better with
age as many people not only like Ryden
as a character now but also understand
his role as the protagonist of mgs2
obviously I was shocked to see that we
weren't playing a solid snake but just
like the last of us I was willing to
play along so I could at least
understand why the switch was made Ryden
makes up at least 80 percent of the game
so this wasn't a decision that was
cobbled up and put together in a day it
was a deliberate decision to make a ride
on the protagonist so I stuck by Kojima
hoping he proved to me why this bait and
switch was necessary and honestly its
implementation was nothing short of
Genius but I'll have to explain why I
believe this towards the end so for now
let's just continue on within the
previous clip we were told that the
leader is solid snake or at least
someone going by Solid Snake we also
heard that snake died during that tanker
explosion the latter is a lie a snake
does reappear a bit later but as someone
named Iroquois pliskin as for the former
it is snake but not the snake if you
remember from the end of mgs1 we heard
that a third clone of big boss existed
named solidus this is the leader of the
Sons of Liberty the general public and
even some of the government didn't know
about the cloning project so they would
have no reason to believe that it wasn't
Solid Snake since they look identical
joining us on this mission is SEAL Team
10. although they don't know we're here
so it's best if we don't make contact
with them as they might treat us as an
enemy on the comms is Colonel Campbell
again and Rose ryden's girlfriend she's
a data analyst so she has the
qualifications but it's definitely odd
that they were willing to mix work and
their relationship on a mission this
crucial speaking of which I found Rose
to be insufferable to listen to Rose
during the mission will constantly call
Ryden and ask if he remembers what
tomorrow is she'll also get in arguments
with him about the relationship in the
middle of the mission Ryden is equally
as annoying but I felt that this for the
most part made sense this is ryden's
first mission he's done a lot of VR
Missions but in terms of on the ground
field experience this is his first so
naturally he's not going to be his
common collected as someone like Solid
Snake is a little later from now the Big
Show will be rigged to blow and we have
to defuse the bombs and Ryden goes but
but Colonel I don't have bomb disposal
experience I can't do this like holy
[__] get a grip son it's annoying what
it's supposed to be so while I didn't
like it at the time I started to come
around to the idea once I realized why
it was added on the other side of the
coin though dead cell is something I'm
still unsure about in terms of the role
they play in the story I like them but
as individuals they're extremely
puzzling the group consists of three
members Fortune vampid fat man Fatman is
a bomb expert who wears a bomb vest in
rollerblades Vamp is a vampire although
for some odd reason his name is not a
reference to the word vampire yet he
acts like one because Kojima and Fortune
is considered Lady Luck as both seem to
pass around her and grenades don't
explode if near her meaning she's
practically unkillable Fortune is easily
my favorite out of the three and I might
go as far as to say that she's the best
antagonist in the series so far at least
when it comes to the minor villains like
psychomantis Vulcan and Sniper Wolf
liquid snake and ocelot are obviously in
their own category given their
importance of the story at large so I
don't count them as a part of this group
the one thing that almost stopped me
from ranking her this High though is her
abilities I feel like metal gear solid
has gone too far with its technology I
was barely willing to forgive
psychomantis as he was designed to be an
anomaly given his constant fourth wall
breaks fortune and the rest of dead cell
though aren't meant to be mantis Fortune
is basically unkillable and Vamp is
literally a vampire I always hate
discussing stuff like this though
because it's extremely subjective to be
fair half this video is really just an
opinion piece but this is specifically
hard to discuss judging whether
something is too sci-fi or not is always
going to differ from person to person
for example Halo is a series with three
organic races humans Covenant in the
flood but Halo 4 added a new race called
Prometheans which were more Tech based I
found this to be too far for the series
which is a weird stance given that it's
a Sci-Fi game with alien races others
and maybe even you would disagree with
that and that's my point everyone has a
different tolerance all over this sort
of thing and I feel like mgs2 crossed
mine I would have personally preferred
if the Sci-Fi of the game was more based
around technology and not the
supernatural now if we we are being
super picky everything is Created from
advanced technology even ocelot himself
at one point says there's no such things
as miracles of the supernatural only
Cutting Edge technology but a lot of
characters in this series have abilities
that aren't explained so it's just
assumed to be Supernatural I want to
clarify though that this isn't a major
criticism of mgs2 or even the series
it's more just personal preference plus
like I said earlier when discussing mgs1
I'm glad they showed it to us early so
that we aren't confused when characters
like Vamp and Fortune start to appear as
it's just a part of the world thankfully
Fortune was interesting enough for me to
forgive her magical abilities but same
cannot be said for Vamp Vamp feeding on
people's blood and being able to run out
water is already too much for me but he
just has no redeeming qualities
whatsoever one thing I liked about
Fortune is that she surprisingly hates
her abilities because she can't be
allowed to die her group dead so was
also framed for various crimes and
killings they didn't commit forcing the
group to go Rogue this put a lot of
strain on Fortune who just wanted to
join her dead comrades but seeing as she
can't die she figured the next best
thing was just to kill everyone if they
can't kill her Vamp on the other hand
and just exists he kills a few dudes we
battle him he runs away he walks up a
wall he kills a few more people then we
fight him that's about it there's just
nothing interesting about him I've also
largely ignored fat man for this
discussion for the same reasons I have a
hatred toward Vamp fat man just exists
he attempts to blow up the Big Show we
stop him and that's about it he did at
least get a laugh out of me when I saw
the rollerblades though in terms of a
group to group comparison Fox Hound his
leagues above dead cell in every way
each villain in fox sound was given
enough time to meet the player allowing
them to develop some kind of hatred for
them they also have a reason and
motivation for why they joined the group
and took over the base this in stark
contrast to dead cell where Fortune is
practically carrying the team that being
said while dead cell isn't as
interesting as fox sound is they do at
least have a pretty killer soundtrack
okay
[Music]
returning back to the story as Ryden
will Patrol the first few areas of the
big shell and come across Vamp and
Fortune allowing us to see their
supernatural abilities this is around
the time we run into snake who's
disguised as Iroquois pliskin the reason
snank is hiding his identities because
he was deemed a terrorist for his
actions at the tanker two years ago but
it still doesn't explain why he's here
at this facility or given the fact that
he and otakan are part of an anti-metal
gear organization I think you could put
two and two together snake is reluctant
to share his mission details with us
though so for now let's focus on our
mission according to snake there was a
bomb defusal expert named Stillman who
came with the seals we're going to need
him since he'll teach us how to remove
the bombs that the terrorists have just
planted on the facility the big shell is
split into two shells with six struts
surrounding each shell we're going to be
taking shell 1 while snake handle shell
2. there seems to be 12 bombs in total
so one for each strut mgs2 also carries
over the series tradition of long-winded
cutscenes and it's around here where I
started to notice them we go about 45
minutes without any actual gameplay
around this point if we're being
technical we do get to take control of
Ryden during this time but it's mainly
just walking down a hallway or two
before getting to the next cutscene as
I've stated before long cutscenes are a
staple of Kojima games whereas other
games would prefer to get the player
into the action as fast as possible if
Kojima wants you to sit the right 20
minute cutscene then you will obviously
you can skip these but if you want to
know the story then you just have to sit
through it personally as someone who
enjoys the stories of games I don't mind
long cutscenes it's not the length that
bothers me it's the content within them
and while I wasn't really interested in
Stillman as a character I can see how he
fits into the game's story and its theme
Stillman taught fat man about explosives
when he was a kid but that's all he
taught him he never taught him other
things that parental figure should be
teaching kids Stillman also screwed up a
job a few years ago which caused the
church a nearby playground filled with
people to be blown up he didn't want to
ruin his reputation though so he faked
having a leg injury from the explosions
that people could pity him he ended up
choosing to ignore his past rather than
Embrace and accept it as a part of his
life passing the torch on to the next
generation and being able to accept the
pass for what it was is a key part of
this game's theme so I appreciate its
inclusion I think a lot of my distaste
for Stillman though stem sermon mission
for us he wants us to defuse those bombs
I talked about earlier and at that point
I'd rather have done literally anything
but that it just kind of feels like
padding at this point at the very least
though the moment-to-moment gameplay was
enough to keep me entertained the
gameplay isn't that much different from
mgs1 with the small addition of being
able to shoot in first person the
problem of looking at the map 24 7 still
exists but the game forces you to
activate nodes you can get the map
online so you're looking at it a lot
less than usual while most of the
section is focused on the gameplay the
few story beats we do discover are at
least interesting enough to talk about
that being the Olga and gray fox are
still alive there is way too much going
on here to explain all that right now
but just remember that Olga and gray fox
are at the facility we then get a
momentary roadblock in the form of a
boss fight with Fortune Ryden attempts
to shoot her but it goes around her
however this bodes well for him as it
ends up hitting Vamp Vamp isn't actually
dead though as for some odd reason he
can't die but it further reinforces
fortunes deteriorating mental state as
not only does her good luck prevent her
from dying but it also causes those
around her to die instead we don't end
up killing her in this fight for obvious
reason so instead Ryden will take the
opportunity to escape he will then
immediately run into fat man who gets
put down shortly after on top of the
soundtrack the boss fights themselves
were actually quite fun there wasn't a
single fight in this game or felt like
the mechanics were fighting me alongside
the boss some of the fights definitely
required a bit more finesse and skill
than others especially one towards the
end but overall things felt Fair it was
the first time I didn't dread the
thought of fighting a boss in this
series Once Batman is defeated Ryden
will then meet with gray fox who tells
them the location of a secret service
agent named Ames the main objective is
still to reach the president but we
don't know where he is so we have to
talk to Ames first so that we can get
his location we also learned that there
is a nuke on board the shell and that
the terrorists have the case required to
launch it fortunately it's not as simple
as it seems as they need their
president's vitals in order to access it
the case needs to check and recheck the
president's DNA blood and heart rate and
only then can they actually launch it
once we make it to Ames though hotels
for the president is as well as the
detail that the ransom money has nothing
to do with their objective their actual
plan is to launch the nuke and Detonator
into the air causing an EMP blast to
solve Manhattan before we can learn more
though ocelot comes by to interrupt our
conversation but Ames dies from a
mysterious heart attack I wonder where
we've seen this before ryden's disguise
is then discovered by ocelot but before
he's killed gray fox comes by and helps
him Escape Ryden then gets thrown into
another boss fight but this time against
solid as snake one thing I will give to
mgs2 is that they really told of me
regarding their president's identity at
the end of mgs1 we heard that the
president was the third clone a big boss
so I assume that the president everyone
kept talking about was solidus the whole
time this was incorrect on my part A
solidus was relieved of his position as
president in between games and another
took his place so Props the team for
keeping the whole thing a mystery even
after revealing it in the last game
solidus though claims to be the superior
clone of big boss due to his genes solid
state was given all a big boss's
dominant genes and liquid was given all
the recessive ones but solidus was given
the best of both sets to clarify since
this may confuse people dominant doesn't
mean better in the case of genetics it
just means more common solid snake has
all the dominant or most common genes
while liquid has the recessive or least
common ones that's why Solid Snake and
big boss have the same hair color while
liquid doesn't big boss's dominant gene
regarding his hair color is one that is
darker solidus was given the best of
each set as in genetics the recessive
gene might be better than the dominant
one so if the dominant one for example
made you weaker but the recessive one
made you stronger sawdust would be
implanted with the recessive one since
it makes him stronger so Genetically
speaking he is the superior one but mgs1
taught us that your genes don't Define
who you are and this is especially true
as Ryden someone who isn't even a clone
of big boss was able to defeat solidus
during this fight we didn't kill him
just merely wounded him but still we
were set up to lose and somehow came out
on top I do like the fact that the theme
of the previous game was carried over
into this one making it seem like the
themes of the games are not just a part
of a single entry but rather series as a
whole they're just more pronounced
within their respective entries
defeating zeldus causes him to retreat
by having Metal Gear Ray take him away
while snake and oticon arrived to
provide support the two have been
working together for quite some time so
naturally oticon would be here but he
has a personal stake in this Mission
which is that his sister Emma is
stationed here at the facility Emma
Emrick is a computer engineer who
specializes in AI she was here because
of the new metal gear that's placed
underneath the facility that we'll see
in just a moment before we meet with
Emma we have to go get the president
which we actually do this time finally
I'll be honest while I think the message
of Metal Gear Solid 2 is incredibly
important and very thought provoking the
story is lacking at times it's not
terrible not even close it's just that
it only starts to get interesting about
two-thirds of the way through the game
everything we've done so far has just
been busy work and we haven't furthered
the plot in any way in mgs1 we had the
objective of rescuing Baker and the
DARPA chief after we attempted to do
that was when we were given more hints
about what's going on here which we
learn had to do with the Pentagon and
Fox die in Metal Gear Solid 2 we have a
similar objective of rescuing a priority
Target and we're six hours into the game
and we just now found him along along
the way we've been distracted with
pointless busy work from fighting dead
cell to diffusing bombs look I do
genuinely enjoy Metal Gear Solid 2 and
think it's a great game it just took
ages for me to finally get interested in
what was going on and this was the first
time in the series where I wasn't as
excited to progress in the narrative
because we weren't really going anywhere
that moment where I started to get
interested though is right here as the
president gives us the details on the
Patriots according to him the Patriots
are a secret shadow organization that
controls the United States for behind
closed doors everything from politics to
military to the economy goes through
them they've been elected the president
as President Johnson here is just a pawn
that's being used by the Patriots the
group was made up of 12 men originally
called the wise men's committee who
controlled the country by telling the US
government to do exactly as they say
President Johnson wanted power and thus
pledged loyalty to the Patriots he
thought that by being the president he
would get that power until he realized
he was just a pawn for them the
president wanted to use the new metal
gear as a bargaining chip but solid has
got in the way is he wanted to actually
challenge them President Johnson
originally wanted to join solidus in
taking down the Patriots too but he came
to the the realization that if the
Patriots are gone then the spot they
leave open is the country's ruler would
eventually be filled by someone else
which would cause chaos and civil unrest
he recognizes that the Patriots
shouldn't rule the country but now that
they do they can't be taken down or the
resulting alternative would be worse if
they stayed in power the president then
goes on to say that saudus went against
the Patriots wishes and was the sole
reason the events of mgs-1 even happened
he sent ocelot to provoke liquid snake
into taking over the base and
subsequently Metal Gear wrecks the
Patriots did not tell him to do this so
they took him out of office and replaced
him with President Johnson solidus was
supposed to be killed for going against
the Patriots but ocelot was able to
sneak him out unharmed saurus then vowed
to defeat the Patriots but needed help
if he was going to pull it off that's
when he Enlisted the help of dead cell
and its members since he created them as
well as gurlukovich's Army which is why
they're here at the facility When we
arrive but having more men isn't enough
to defeat the Patriots he only called
him to his Aid so they could defend the
facility while he finished his
production on the new Metal Gear Station
down here Arsenal gear unlike the metal
gears we've seen so far Arsenal gear is
not only much larger than any of these
mechs by a long shot but its purpose is
the most important aspect Arsenal gear
is a mobile Fortress fitted with over
thousands of missiles and troops but
inside is an AI called GW that can
censor remove and tamper with internet
communications the Patriots want to
control The Narrative of the world so
their identities can be hidden in
addition to policing what they deem is
necessary for the public to see it would
essentially be a war on culture and
information and create censorship on a
global scale all to fit the agenda of
the Patriots it is without a doubt the
single most dangerous Creation in the
history of the world
can you see why I started to get
interested now I was just expecting
another stronger Metal Gear with bigger
guns but a metal gear that can change
the course of human history is not what
I had anticipated
after this bombshell of information the
president gives us a disc with a virus
that can stop Arsenal gear if it's been
activated he then takes bryden's gun and
forces us to shoot him as if he dies and
they can't launch the nuke Ryden
struggles to make up his mind before
ocelot does it for him and shoots the
president if we recall our previous
interactions with him we heard him say
that metal gear Ray belongs to the
Patriots which Alba confirms that ocelot
is working for them and is most
definitely going to betray solidus Ryden
still stunned by what just happened
allows ocelot a chance to escape so he
decides to continue on with the mission
and go find Emma once he does Emma tells
him a bit about herself and apologies
for repeating myself but once again for
reasons that are genuinely beyond my
comprehension Kojima decided to make
Emma's backstory and by extension the
Emerick families the most concerning and
uncomfortable thing I've ever listened
to Emma and Otakon are step siblings and
when they were younger they used to play
house together with Emma being the wife
and oticon being the husband according
to the wiki Emma is 18 which I don't
recall ever being mentioned but none of
that matters as she was easily no older
than six during this time thanks to the
family splitting up that's because
oticon's stepmom or Emma's biological
mother had seduced atticon into having
sex with her aracan's dead then learned
of this and then attempted to kill
himself by drowning in the Family Pool
Emma was also drowning along with him
but it's unclear if the father did it on
purpose or she just happened to be
dragged under the water regardless
aracan's father died but was
unsuccessful in taking Emma with him
arakan naturally felt immense guilt over
his actions and decided to leave the
family and caught all contact from them
from Emma's point of view though she
thought oticon had abandoned her which
is why she harbored such hatred for him
to make matters worse when Emma's mom
remarried her new father ended up
sexually assaulting her which resulted
in Emma attacking him in self-defense to
turn this story towards something more
positive for once Emma like her
stepbrother was extremely talented when
it came to computers and technology so
much other her skills were recognized by
the Patriots which is how she came to
create the gwai they used for Arsenal
gear alright so maybe not exactly
positive but it's a lot better than
everything I've just said regardless
what the hell was that this entire
situation is not only weird but
extremely illegal the playing house
thing is not illegal per se as they were
kids and likely didn't know any better
but its inclusion is weird
Otakon also had to be no older than 15
or so at the time so his stepmom seduced
a minor I think the weirdest part about
all of this is somehow this actually
matters originally I thought this was
just made for shock value part of me
still believes that but Kojima at least
played into this backstory as oticon's
questionable relationships and hookups
could be attributed to his stepmom
Otakon obviously plays the geeky nerd so
to further fit The Stereotype oticon
luckily has or had no friends and
girlfriends this makes his bond with
snake all the more important since their
two guys with no extended family they
found solace in each other's company but
it also explains his relationship with
sniperwolf having his first relationship
be with his stepmom luckily ruined a lot
of his perception when it came to love
and could explain why he had felt a deep
love towards sniperwolf even though it
was likely one-sided aracan seems to be
the kind of person who will jump
straight into someone's arms if they so
much as breathe in his Direction and
probably can't tell if he's being
manipulated which is why he thought that
him and sniperwolf had something
together this idea also comes back
around with Dr Naomi appears in the
fourth game but we'll talk about that
later still it seems to reinforce the
aforementioned details and also makes
you care for oticon more by getting you
to sympathize with his rather tragic
backstory I also like how before this
conversation Otakon reminded Emma of
their family history in the dangers of
continuing it Otakon and mgs1 says that
his family history has always been tied
to nuclear weapons his grandfather was a
part of the Manhattan Project which was
a project that created the first nuclear
weapons
oticon's father created an AI weapon
called the Basilisk that could launch
nukes oticon himself contributed to the
development of metal gear wrecks and
Emma helped create an AI that be used
for Arsenal gear this entire family for
Generations has been connected to
nuclear technology and seeing oticon
break the family Destiny is fantastic as
it not only shows genuine growth but
this Destiny he's breaking is directly
tied to the themes and story of Metal
Gear Solid since it has to do with the
nuclear weapons this backstory of oticon
has always been my favorite part about
him this whole stepmom thing though I
don't want to touch with a 10-foot pole
which is unlucky for me is we'll have to
talk about his father later which is
going to be a real true great thankfully
the whole thing ends in a much better
way than it started although not
entirely as while escorting Emma out of
the building she's stabbed and killed by
Vamp Emma and oticon have one last talk
before she succumbs to her wounds but
the trauma isn't over yet thanks to her
pet parrot Emma had a parrot with her at
the facility and since she didn't have
any friends there she would talk to the
parrot they're also commonly known to
repeat words people say and the parrot
repeats various sentences like I miss my
brother and I love you Hal
oticon breaks down after hearing this
knowing that even after everything
that's happened between the two she
still loved him not in a weird way but
in a more natural way as sibling should
it makes you feel terrible for oticon
and hit me pretty hard too as I was
hoping to see the two siblings team up
and maybe even take this partnership
into future entries I hated that she
died shortly after we met her but I'm
not disappointed that I felt that way as
that was intentional so huge props to
the team forgetting me to care about a
character I'd only known for 20 minutes
foreign shortly after this Ryden meets
with gray fox and learns that it's not
the gray fox we know but rather Olga as
the tanker was exploding snake went and
rescued Olga for some reason and the two
were able to survive Olga's role is a
bit hard to Define because she like
Naomi for the prior game is working with
and against us after the tanker incident
she and her Russian mercenaries joined
an illegal organization unbeknownst to
her was that this was controlled by the
Patriots she was also about to give
birth to her child around this time so
she went to a hospital that also
happened to be owned by the Patriots
after she went into labor they took her
child and forced her to work for them or
she wouldn't be able to see her child
again her job was to support Ryden on
this Mission and make sure things go
smoothly but that doesn't make any sense
as we're supposed to be against the
Patriots and that's the Twist from here
on out things start to be a lot more
clearer the Patriots are behind
everything that's happened on this
Mission as a part of their S3 plan the
S3 plan was the ultimate manipulation
the plan was to see how much they could
coerce someone into doing what they say
this all starts to make sense once we
talk to the colonel Olga has writing
captures at snake and sneak into the
Arsenal gear undetected after he gets
out the colonel comes back and starts
acting strange in fact the whole game
starts to act strange the colonel
references previous events of mgs-1 and
Metal Gear 1. he even repeats exact
quotes from the game and even tells us
to turn off the console there's also a
video of a random woman that appears in
the top right and the colonel states
that Rose is cheating on riding with
another man the reason behind all this
is that the kernel was never actually
real it was the aigw posing as the
colonel everything that has happened
here at the oil rig has been carefully
reconstructed by the Patriots in order
to see how far they could push riding
into doing what they want him to do
after the tanker from two years ago sank
they took another tanker filled it with
oil and then sank it in that exact same
spot this caused oil to spread all over
the harbor so clean a facility was
created to get rid of it the big shell
but the big shell was never meant to
clean it up it was just a cover-up so
that no one bothered to look underneath
the site which is where Arsenal gear was
being produced solidus after hearing
that the Patriots tried to kill him
vowed to hunt them down he was then
joined by Olga and her mercenaries as
well as dead cell but the Patriots had
purposely framed deadself for numerous
attacks under force them to go Rogue and
Olga was working for the Patriots
because they have her child their final
step though was the most important of
all they were to send a single soldier
who would have the mission of taking
down these terrorists Ryden
ryden's been working for the Patriots
the whole time the big shell is meant to
mimic Shadow Moses so that they could
push right into his limits each place is
located offshore both groups demanded
money even if the money this time was
just a lie dead cell is meant to be a
stand-in for foxhound the kernel and a
cybernetic ninja appear in both missions
and at least two other smaller details
like the fact that each one had hostages
that we needed to rescue even Ryden
himself is a connection as his
relationship to solidus is like that of
big boss and solid snake as it's one
that solidus raised Ryden and made him a
Child Soldier when he was just a boy if
you ever thought while playing wow this
specific thing in this game is like that
thing from mgs1 then you've fallen into
the Trap without even realizing it while
some games reuse assets boss fights or
concepts to save time during development
Metal Gear Solid used it to sell a story
this is why Ryden being the protagonist
was the smartest decision that could
have ever made Ryden is meant to be us
there's a point in the opening moments
of the game where we can write our names
in date of birth on a dog tag this is
supposed to connect us to Ryden there
was a slight disconnect in Metal Gear
Solid 1 because we are a new player
playing as the legend Dairy Solid Snake
but a Metal Gear Solid 2 we and riding
around a Level Playing Field both of us
want to feel like an action hero just
like how we felt in mgs1 when we faced
off against the liquid and foxhound the
big shell mimics Shadow Moses even down
to the emotions you felt when playing
that game like the previous games this
twist is also one you could have seen
coming if you paid attention the colonel
keeps calling this Mission a simulation
and mentions that Solid Snake was not a
part of the simulation this is also why
Ryden is laughed at when talking about
Ransom money or about how the terrorists
executed a hostage none of that actually
happened it was just to see if rotten
would follow orders even when things
started to go wrong but this doesn't
just extend to Ryden but to the player
as well we are riding after all that's
the point of the dog tags so the
Patriots weren't just manipulating Ryden
but us as well and we kept playing along
the S3 plan or selection for societal
sanity was created to see how well the
Patriots could manipulate the events of
the world and the individual and by
playing the game we help them complete
their testing we foolishly obeyed
everything they said which resulted in
the complete success of the plan Ryden
is naturally confused and devastated but
it's about to get worse as Rose was also
working for the Patriots too Rose
meeting and falling in love with Ryden
was not a coincidence it was all set up
by the Patriots the only thing they
didn't anticipate was that Rose would
actually fall in love with him so they
set up another Fail-Safe if Ryden
disobeys or die so will Rose in oga's
child so he has no choice but to follow
along
the reason he was chosen for this test
was because he refused to accept his
past and would shy away from any
conversation or mention of it he was
impressionable and emotionally fragile
which made him an easy target
somehow after all this Ryden is still
determined to do the mission even after
his whole world has just come down on
top of him which just goes to show how
strong he truly is he's also being aided
by snake who arrives just in time to get
him to the core of Arsenal gear snake
will stay behind to deal with Fortune
while Ryder meets with solidus Olga
jumps in and sacrifices her life in
order to save him because she knows that
if Ryden dies her child goes too Ryden
isn't able to escape though and both he
and snake are captured ocelot will then
come by and double cross all of them he
monologues about all the info I just
told you earlier since he is a member of
the Patriots with the added detail that
the virus Emma made was actually
designed to eliminate all the info GW
had on the Patriots if you remember the
Patriots won Arsenal gears that they
could control the spread of information
all the info they want to be censored
are removed will be contained in GW sort
of like a hidden file folder so if you
wanted to see that info you'd have to
hack the AI itself but the virus
destroyed GW meaning they have
officially removed everything about
themselves and no one could know who
they are but that doesn't mean that the
Patriots have no AI either as there's
others GW is just one of five AIS the
group has at their disposal Fortune
immediately attempts to kill ocelot for
this but is killed before she could get
the chance the force field stuff she had
was just technology the Patriots had
developed so he just turned it off as I
said everything was a part of the
Patriots plan the only part of their
play that didn't turn out as they
planned was the arrival of snake other
than that everything else went off
without a hitch ocelot attempts to leave
before being taken over by liquid now
it's a real proper family reunion but
the clones have never seen eye to eye
which is why liquid wants to destroy
solid and solidus so that he could be
the real big boss and then eventually
defeat the Patriots that's why liquid
ended up choosing ocelot as his host
that he could get closer to the Patriots
this doesn't make any sense though since
liquid died so how was he not only able
to control ocelot at all but choose
ocelot as his host even after death
narrow machine son right anyway liquid
runs away with snake going after him and
Arsenal gear crashes into Manhattan
solidus and Ryden and battle it out as
he wants to bring back what matters most
rights freedoms and Free Will things the
Patriots would take away Ryan has no
choice but to kill saldas though as
refusing means that he rose and Olga's
child would die right before this though
was a Kodak call with the Patriots and
it's easily the most important 15
minutes of the whole game the AIS posing
as the colonel explain their problem
their plan to combat the problem and
their solution and all of it has to do
with the world itself this call is why
so many people consider mgs2 to be one
of the greatest games of all time and
also a game that was way ahead of its
time it explains it was created in the
White House 200 years ago I don't
believe this to be true as that would
mean it was created in the 1800s so I
believe it's to be a metaphor as the
aisr representation of America's
knowledge they say that as long as the
country exists they will too so in a
sense they are the country the AI goes
on to explain that thanks to the Human
Genome Project they were able to see the
path that Humanity would go down in
regards to Evolution the problem is that
those only have to do with genes and not
things outside of it like culture
history and ideas if mgs1 was about
passing down your genes mgs2 is about
passing down things outside of your
genes like beliefs and values humans
have existed for thousands of years and
since then these memories ideas and
beliefs have been passed down from
generation to generation but only some
of them have made it through not
everything was able to be passed down
since it wasn't necessary for example if
a caveman touched fire and burned
himself he would tell his tribe the
reason we know that fire hurts is that
thousands of years ago someone touched
it and it hurt we then passed this info
down because it's important this method
of passing down information was easy to
do back then but thanks to the current
digital age the world has been consumed
by junk data and thanks to the internet
being ageless this junk data will never
go away to provide another example let's
talk about the Flat Earth theory flatter
theory is the idea that the Earth is not
round but rather a flat plane this has
been scientifically disproven for years
and to the AI would be considered junk
data since it's incorrect and harmful
but thanks to the internet people were
able to research and find this data
allowing the myth to be spread even
today this exists all over the internet
in the form of misinterpretations
various Petty issues that are
inconsequential to the human race and
fake news the AI then goes on to explain
that the world rewards human flaws and
pushes convenient half-truths it also
mentions things like Echo Chambers and
how people only listen to what they want
to hear so they can't be proven wrong
the AIS want to stop this spread of
unnecessary information from happening
and as AIS they claim to be able to make
that happen while listening to this
section you may have started thinking
about real world issues and how they
connect to what we're talking about and
that's the genius of this call Donald
Trump the former president of the United
States was banned from Twitter in 2021.
many people saw this as an attack on not
just Free Speech but also conservative
values in response Donald Trump and many
of his die-hard supporters then moved to
parlor due to this the app parlor is
deemed by many to be a far-right
conservative platform putting away your
political opinions about Trump you can
see how the situation could create an
echo chamber to add to this CNN is
predominantly a Democrat or a liberal
news station as such conservatives would
have a hard time agreeing with their
opinions while Democrats would be
pleased once again you can see how an
echo chamber could be formed here due to
these places catering to specific
audiences these companies and platforms
have also been known to either lie or
stretch the truth to fit their agenda
people flock to these places though
because it makes them feel safe and Echo
Chambers allow them to stay in their
bubble this doesn't just happen in
politics but everywhere and no one is
removed from this idea the Patriots
hoped to removal this pointless data
said Humanity can evolve and not be
stopped by these distractions you might
think that the Patriots have the right
idea and it does sound appealing but to
do this they would have to remove one
thing that makes us human free will the
Patriots would basically be dictators
that choose what we see this is not only
terrible but also ironic as in AI they
have no moral compass and don't have
human emotions so they in theory could
find the proper data and filter out the
bed but the AIS were made by humans so
naturally human emotion is going to play
into the equation the Patriots are also
a group that are willing to lie and
manipulate people in order to get their
way and also had GW destroy all evidence
of their existence to further reinforce
this we have to look back at an earlier
conversation with Emma she goes on to
explain that the Y2K incident was when
the Patriots had awakened the gwai Y2K
was a scare that happened around the
turn of the century back then computers
in their stores were expensive so to
save on the space the companies cut
Corners to save time when people were
writing dates instead of writing
something like 5'5 1997 they would just
ride 5 5 97 since it was easy to
understand it's the same reason we say
things like yeah the 80s were a crazy
time back then you don't talk about the
1980s because that's just how we were
conditioned to think the problem is that
by not adding the first two digits or
the 19 in 1997 the computer wouldn't be
able to distinguish between 1997 and
2097 since they both end in 97. this was
fine for manual data like spreadsheets
but for things that were automated like
clocks and screens the computer might
mistake January 1st 2000 as January 1st
1900s since it wasn't set to go past
1999. the world naturally found ways to
Circle recommend the issue but in the
world of Metal Gear Solid the government
used a program combined with an OS
application that was given to everyone
to solve the issue but as we know the
Patriots control the government so this
program was created by them the program
isn't fully complete though as they
needed to test its Effectiveness and
judging situations so they created one
involving some I don't know
blonde-haired individual at a facility
that was created to exploit and
manipulate him the last part of the
program was the test we and ride him
were fold into doing which not only
means that they have all the data they
need but shows us that the Patriots are
not some Divine beings trying to further
Humanity but rather make Humanity
conform to what they deem as important
Emma then asks riding about the alphabet
and I'll ask you the same thing how many
letters are there 26 right what if there
were 30. right it could have been 30
letters what if the four deleted letters
were controlled by a program impossible
it's not in fact something similar is
already underway do you know how many
genes exist in individual about 30 to 40
000 right that's what was announced at
the turn of the century but there's
actually a
according to the original Theory
immunity information regarding the
remaining 60 000 was suppressed by the
Patriots no why how would you know do
you know what a gene looks like did you
count them yourself there are research
organizations of course and their
reports have already been subtly altered
they're even beginning to believe the
doctor reports GW is a system that
allows the Patriots to decide what will
be recorded in tomorrow's history so
what we're talking about is one huge
censorship system for deleting
information which might be inconvenient
to the Patriots exactly Metal Gear Solid
2 is not trying to show us that the AI
and the Patriots are right but rather
both sides of the spectrum are wrong the
digital age as it is now sucks thanks to
people conveniently lying to fit their
agenda which causes other people to
spread these lies believe in that their
truths but automating the system and
removing our right to Free Will is not a
better alternative as it removes the one
thing that makes us human free will to
relate this back to the message of the
game take what you believe and pass it
on to the next Generation but don't be
afraid to seek out information that
opposes your viewpoints and be willing
to consider any alternatives rather than
dismiss everything you see as lies or
falsehoods also make sure to call out
any fake news as it arises so that
impressionable or unwary people aren't
corrupted by that info and spread it to
others and this doesn't just have to be
on a political level it could be
anything if someone is spreading misinfo
about a person in your life or about a
game you play then let them know that
they're wrong in doing so we should be
able to set Humanity on the right track
it's not going to be perfect and we're
definitely going to miss some things
along the way but it's the only way for
us as a species to evolve and come
together without losing ourselves in the
process for as much as Metal Gear solids
who bored me at the beginning I can't
imagine anyone not being swept up by
this finale and its message this is one
of the strongest and Most Fascinating
messages I've ever seen and this was all
created in 2001. it's a message that's
only relevant to the story but it's
relevant to our real world both when it
was released and even today thankfully
we don't have some AI cabal trying to
run things and also don't have to deal
with a former president gone Rogue oh
yeah back to that sorry I got swept up
in the message Ryden will defeat solidus
bringing an end to his plan sadly the
Patriots have concluded their testing
and thanks to riding it's been an
overwhelming success the AI then Cuts
Communications and disappears leaving
the player thinking about what the
future of the world will be like now
that we've given them everything they
wanted snake will then meet with Bryden
and tell him not to worry so much about
the mission and to just focus on himself
he may not have had much choice in his
objectives but everything he did and
everything he felt was real he then
suggests that he start fresh and clean
the Slate start a new life one where
he's the one in control Ryden then takes
the dog tags we made and throws them
away symbolizing that he is removing our
control from him and vowing from this
day forward to be his own person one who
makes his own decisions the game then
ends with snake showing right in the
virus disk as we know the disc is used
to destroy info regarding the Patriots
but since it's a code there needs to be
parameters in place to Define what
counts as info on the Patriots so snake
and out a comp plan to reverse engineer
it in hopes of finding who they are but
an after credit scene says that the
Patriots all died a hundred years ago
meaning that info they got from Arson
gear was fake and likely another plan by
the Patriots while that happens Ryder
then meets with rose the two seem to be
expecting a child and they embrace one
another as Ryden seems to propose to her
before cuts to Black all this will leave
us with many questions but also with the
hope that these questions will turn into
answers soon
Metal Gear Solid 2 was an impressive
follow-up to an already impressive game
I had a bit more negative things to say
this time around but I did have a
pleasant time with the game it does take
a bit of time to get going but if you
can accept the fact that Solid Snake is
not the protagonist and be willing to
stick it through to the end then you
like me will come out with a much more
pleasant attitude towards the game Metal
Gear Solid 2 story ramps up the
intensity and once again weaves the
active and overarching plot together
seamlessly it also sets up the main
antagonist of the series and gives us
something to look forward to when the
sequel comes the active story of mgs2
though was decent but definitely lacked
in a few key ways Denzel was not as
interesting as Fox island due to the
lack of time spent with them and lots of
the game's objectives felt like busy
work and weren't really pushing the
narrative in any kind of Direction
overall though many people myself
included were happy with the product and
interested to see what the sequel would
have in store for us but that sequel was
not a continuation this whole time we've
been talking about Big Boss the Patriots
and ocelot yet we still don't know much
about them the Patriots used to have
people in their group but where did they
go ocelot's motivations are still
unclear as he seems to switch sides with
whoever is winning and big boss has just
been a name for the most part where did
the idea of cloning Big Boss come from
where do the metal gears come from well
to do that we have to go back in time
while Metal Gear Solid 3 serves as the
origin point for the series taking place
in 1964. it's also the origin point of
big boss depending on who you are your
feelings toward big boss you're
different in Metal Gear 1 solzig is
betrayed by a big boss which believes to
his death well sort of as he ends up
coming back in Metal Gear 2 and fight
Snake once again those games make big
boss out to be a villain but we don't
have the context of why the metal gear
games don't really elaborate on why and
the solid series does even less but this
is why Metal Gear Solid 3 was created to
not only give us the origin of big boss
but also see what started his descent
into villainy the game's story plays
into its own theme which is the idea of
perspective in context we'll Circle back
to that at the end though as we have a
lot more important things to discuss
first like the actual plot of the story
we first start with a man Halo jumping
into a russian-controlled Zone this
individual is known as naked snake or as
we know him
Ryden right mgs3 has a questionnaire at
the beginning of the game which asks if
I liked MGS one two or three I picked
two which apparently replaces my face
paint with Riven once that's taken off
though we can see the actual protagonist
naked snake or as we know him big boss
the mission he's embarking on is of
utmost importance currently we are deep
in the Cold War so tensions between the
Russians and U.S are at an all-time high
the states got word that a Russian
scientist named sokolov wants to defect
to the West he was then stuck out of the
country by the Berlin Wall until he was
sent back during the Cuban Missile
Crisis just like in real life President
Kennedy had issued a warning to Russia
which told them to pull their missiles
out of Cuba they obliged but the twist
as they wanted sokoloff is payment in
order to avoid nuclear war Kennedy
agreed and sent him back over well
spoiler alert he wants out again and
we're gonna sneak him out again I know
that's an odd way to start a story but
you have to consider the fact that
Russia removed dozens of missiles from
Cuba one of the closest land masses to
the us all for one man that's because
sokolov was designing a new type of
weapon called the shagahad according to
him it's a mobile nuclear ballistic
missile system it's not a metal gear per
se but it's very metal gear-esque
sokolov like oticon though does not want
to create this kind of weapon as he sees
the dangers in its design so he wants
out so a snake we're gonna find him and
smuggle him out of the country again
just like the previous games were joined
by another Motley Crew of individuals
major zero is our mission advisor the
boss who is snake's former mentor and
paramedical monitor our vitals and allow
us to save
this Trio Harkens back to our classic
team of Roy Campbell May Ling and master
Miller from the first game the snake
reaches sokoloff though he stopped by a
major ocelot the same ocelot that we've
come to know and love or hate depending
on how you feel about him ocelot then
wastes no time putting down the Russian
soldiers that have held this at gunpoint
according to sokolov these Russian
soldiers and ocelots are on two
different sides sokolov was being
guarded by the KGB what was being hunted
by the grew at the time the Gru and the
KGB were Rivals but both fell under the
rule of Russia the crew is being led by
a colonel vulgin and is the main faction
we'll be dealing with back to the point
ocelot summons his guys to attack snake
by meowing
screw operatives
I feel like mgs3 was a test to see how
much Kojima could get away with wait a
few weird things happen in MGS 1 and 2
but the level of stupidity and silliness
in this entry is unmatched this isn't
even the only bizarre thing that happens
in this game either and it also just so
happens that ocelot is somehow involved
in most of it for example a little later
we'll meet a girl named Eva who not only
uses a staircase as a ram to get onto
the roof of a building but also does a
backflip on our bike using ocelot's face
as a wall surprisingly not only do these
elements of silly and serious blend
extremely well with each other it also
serves to display certain personality
quirks among a few characters ocelot
completely revolves around this idea as
right when he's about to shoot snake his
gun jams snake tells him that the
techniques he uses are more suited for
revolvers he then comes back with a
revolver only to be stopped by snake
again because he didn't realize he shot
all six rounds snake also tells him that
the engraving he has is pointless
because it serves no tactical Advantage
after getting beat a second time ocelot
comes back again later with not one but
two revolvers both of which have no
Engravings on them ocelot at this point
in the timeline is in way over his head
but he respects snake enough to apply
the lessons he taught him he also seems
to want his validation which is why he
keeps coming back hoping to show him how
much he's learned so he can prove
himself to the man who defeated him it's
chaotic because all this happens within
about an hour but it's implemented so
well that it can tell us how ocelot acts
without even outright saying it and
coming from Kojima who so far is a
tailbone show kind of person it's very
appreciated as I said earlier though not
all the silly elements are there for a
reason some are just really dumb for the
sake of it but that's a quirk of Kojima
himself blending the series with the
stupid so as to give the player a break
from the action like how paramedics main
personality traits is how much he loves
movies snake have you seen 007 From
Russia with Love
[Music]
snake I don't think the Mage is going to
like you saying that and even though
it's fiction I can't help but comparing
myself to bond what exactly don't you
like about James Bond I mean is it the
Fantastic gadgets the cars the guns hey
jar snake wouldn't you like to have a
gun shaped like a pen
good is a pen gonna do me in the jungle
I'd look like a fool then what about a
snake-shaped gum you could make it look
like you're grappling with a giant snake
and then get a shot in on the enemy
while they're distracted
okay now you're being ridiculous it had
so much charm to the series and I feel
like if you're going to add comedy to a
game like this go nuts with it and mgs3
does it also goes nuts with the
supernatural again as after snake
defeats ocelot he can sokoloff wait for
extraction the plane seems to have gone
off without a hitch until it doesn't as
the boss arrives and takes Circle off
for herself while sokolov was defecting
to the United States the boss was
defecting to the Soviet Union she's also
Wildlife herself with Colonel vulgar and
ocelot in addition to her old team
called the Cobra unit as you would
expect this is our new faction we'll
have to deal with and their abilities
are truly something to behold the boss
is surprisingly normal but her crew
couldn't be further from that the Cobra
unit consists of five members the end
the pain the fear the fury and the
sorrow the boss even has her own
nickname called The Joy one thing that
sets them apart is that each member's
name is based off an emotion they carry
into battle what's more interesting
though is their abilities the fury is a
pyrotechnic that's just like a cosmonaut
the end is considered the father of
sniping who can photosynthesize with
their environment and uses his pet
parrot as a spotter the fear can contort
his body in unnatural ways as well as go
invisible the pain shoots Hornets out of
his hand and also uses them as a
protective shield and the sorrow can
literally talk to and summon ghosts
given my thoughts on dead cell I think
you can see how I feel about them
putting all that aside though from a
story perspective they're not that great
either just about every one of them
falls into the same trap were introduced
to them around the time they attack us
and then five minutes later they're dead
we don't learn much if anything about
them various people will tell us about
the group as a unit and how they were
the ones that put it into World War II
but we don't hear much about them
individually we never hear how they got
these powers or why they even fight us
they just exist as roadblocks for the
player to overcome and given how the
story transpires that may have been
intentional it's possible that the Cobra
unit was testing snake because if he
can't defeat them then he surely can't
defeat the boss but you could also say
that snake has to overcome these
emotions in order to defeat the boss as
well regardless the reason I brought up
killing the boss is because that's going
to be our next objective as once the
boss betrays us she breaks snake's arm
and throws him off the bridge volgin
being the madman he is though goes well
I got a few nukes why not test one out
and proceeds to blow up the nearby
facility where sokolov was originally
being held some would argue that this is
what set the whole Metal Gear series
into motion is this not only change
various plans that were happening at the
time but also our current plan having
heard that a nuke went off in his
country and that American Helicopter was
spotted nearby Khrushchev the current
leader of Russia at the time calls
current president Lyndon B Johnson to
ask what the hell happened President
Johnson restates the truth that the boss
defected and with the help of Colonel
volgan and the Cobra unit took a nuke
and blew up the facility in their
country Khrushchev doesn't believe him
but is willing to consider his argument
if he brings him proof he has a week to
procure this proof or he'll have no
choice but to put his army into maximum
alert meaning World War III will begin
this leads us to operation Snake Eater
the operation in which the game is named
after and the objective is simple rescue
sokoloff again destroy the shagahad and
kill the boss in bulgin it sounds simple
on paper but executing it is going to be
a pain in the ass especially since we're
going to be on our own again as we're
back in Russian territory thankfully we
still have our support team with two new
members to boot sigint is a weapons
expert and Adam will be on the ground to
help us major zero tells us that two NSA
code Breakers named Adam and Eva
defected to the Soviet Union both of
them them are being trained by the KGB
as a way to spy on the guru and Adam has
already made it into Colonel vulgan's
ranks so he'll be helping us from time
to time I figure I should mention this
as well but paramedic is the Dr Clark I
talked about earlier and sigan's real
name is Donald Anderson the same one
from mgs1 one snake makes it into the
jungle the mission already goes south as
the boss arrives to stop him she doesn't
kill him but rather wounds him destroys
his gun and shoots the aircraft he
arrived in to elude the guards you get
the sensor that the boss doesn't want to
kill snake this is true for a few
reasons I'll discuss later but it could
be assumed at this moment that she's
struggling to kill him because they're
friends the boss and snake have known
each other for over 10 years snake at
one point says the relationship was
deeper than love it's a combination of
friendship mother and son an apprentice
and Mentor all in one they clearly care
for each other and it would naturally be
hard to kill someone you loved even if
you are enemies on the topic of that a
lot of the boss's dialogue is about
enemies and friends and how it's all
relative saying things like today's
allies are tomorrow's enemies or how
politics shape the world and its
Soldiers the Cobra unit is a good
example of this as it's assumed that
they were all Russian soldiers except
the boss during World War II they fought
together as a team but since Russia and
the US are at a standstill thanks to the
Cold War they are technically enemies
now the idea of Rights and Wrongs not
being absolute and that things change
depending on the times is the common
theme of this game and it ties back into
our earlier discussion about big boss
it's only been about an hour and you've
already started to feel sympathy for him
he was just betrayed by the person he
loved most and now has to hunt them down
in his mission it definitely paints big
boss in a much different light than
before snake after being defeated again
will eventually make it to the location
to meet Adam but he doesn't show up as
it's actually Eva who meets us here I'm
going to clear this up now so as to not
confuse you but this isn't Eva either
the two code Breakers that defected were
both men and Eva here is clearly a woman
the real Eva is a guy this person posing
as Eva is a spy for someone else still
I'll be referring to her as Ava
throughout the video since we never see
the real one the scene is also a great
example of how the stupid moments in
this series can actually be used to
characterize its cast naked snake is
very intelligent when it comes to
weaponry and you never waste an
opportunity to compliment some fine
craft
the feeding ramp is polished to a mirror
Sheen the slide's been reinforced
and the interlock with the frame is
tightened for added Precision the sight
system is original too the thumb safety
is extended to make it easier on the
finger a long type trigger with non-slip
grooves a ring Hammer the base of the
trigger guard's been filed down for a
higher grip and not only that nearly
every part of this gun has been expertly
crafted and customized Kojima has a
history of over explaining a lot of
details in this series and always feels
like he does it in a specific way so
that it makes him sound intelligent like
when major zero goes into detail about
the aircraft he's in even though it
provides no benefit to the story at all
but in the case of naked snake it works
as he's known to be a very talented
Soldier he is currently on a one-man
mission that a Phil will result in
nuclear war so clue he has some
impressive credentials which is why his
detailed analysis of a singular gun is
not as bizarre as it seems after this
Eva will tell snake where to find
sokolov and the two split up from here
on the game starts to open up and we get
a real good look at the gameplay mgs3
offers the biggest change to the series
by far and to me out of all the games in
this series its gameplay is only
outclassed by one
it seems like Kojima really wanted to
commit to the idea of making snake's
mission one of survival snake now has a
stamina bar that drains over time the
lower the bar the worse your accuracy so
it's best to keep this topped off by
eating food you can find items like
rations and ramen noodles lying around
but they're quite rare so most of your
food will be scavenged by yourself you
can kill snakes rabbits crocodiles and
other animals allowing you to eat their
flesh to gain stamina some food will be
better than others though so it's on you
to experiment and make sure your
inventory is filled with food that will
help you rather than hinder you mgs3
also has a camouflage system in the top
right that shows you how concealed you
are within your environment wearing
green camo in an area with tall grass
will keep you more hidden than if you
wore something like white or blue this
helps you get the jump on enemies and
also gives you a better chance of
sneaking by them logically it makes no
sense how a snake can do this but it is
amusing to imagine that snake is taking
off his clothes and replacing it with a
different colored set in battle every
time he changes though but inevitably
something's going to go wrong and you'll
be hurt so the overall the healing
system by making it more complicated I
personally found this to be more
annoying than anything as there's at
least seven or eight items you can carry
that all heal your wounds you have to
select the correct item in order to
apply it but if you pick the wrong ones
nothing happens so instead of actually
thinking about what to do I just spammed
all my options until it was gone I do
think the system has some Merit to it
though mainly when you start getting hit
with poison or fire attacks when it
comes to normal gunshot wounds there's
just so much to do that I just spammed
all my options until I finish the
procedure all the previous gameplay
systems also tie into the boss fights as
well and while I'm not a huge fan of the
Cobra unit narratively they are some of
my favorite fights in the series not
only are the set piece is very well
designed like the fears being covered in
trees or the ends being a lush Forest
but the stamina bar completely changes
the flight the end is an old man so
tightly advise that you drain his
stamina bar with tranquilizers instead
of killing him since it'll be over
faster and the fear drains his stamina
fast thanks to his erratic movements he
replenishes this by eating any food he
finds but you can also drop food you
know to be poisonous which tricks him
into eating it and applying the same
effects the game offers a lot of options
to defeat them and can also connect to
what we said earlier about snake
overcoming them in order to defeat the
boss each one challenge is snake in a
very specific way and could be cited as
the reason that he is the soldier he is
today all this though creates a
surprising amount of complexity which is
why it's one of my favorite gameplay
systems in the series
getting back on track snake will make
his way through the jungle and run into
ocelot and it's probably the greatest 40
seconds in this entire game
ocelots are proud creatures
they prefer to hunt alone
[Music]
12 shots
God I love this game as I said before
ocelot is at the brunt of the comedy
here hell even his design is hilarious
he's a root tootin cowboy boot wearing
spurs been in major in the Russian KGB
those are two completely different
styles from two different countries that
shouldn't go together but somehow he
makes it work he's in way over his head
here and he's trying his hardest to beat
snake in combat he'll even forbid his
unit from shooting you as he wants a
fair fight ocelot is just a kid though
and very inexperienced so snake is able
to put him down with no problem right as
the battle is about to come to a close
though they're interrupted by a hive of
hornets the pain from the Cobra unit has
arrived and is here to challenge snake
this is what I meant by a lack of story
as the pain is thrown into the game but
then dies five minutes later never be
heard of again this is the same for all
the Cobra unit with the exception of the
sorrow who at least gets a few mentions
outside of his boss fight while
memorable in some ways it's hard to care
much about them when the game doesn't
bother to make you care for them it
feels like the team wanted to design the
most ragtag group of individuals say you
remember them based on how batshit crazy
they were rather than their roles in the
story which severely brings down their
quality as characters another thing the
Group shares outside their naming
structure is that they all have bombs
inside of them that go off once they die
the Cobra unit was a pretty important
group that carried out top secret
missions so this was likely designed as
a fail-saving case they were captured
once the pain is defeated snake will
then spawn a conversation between volgan
the boss and ocelot nearby is sokolov as
well as his lover Tatiana not much
happens here though as it's mostly just
an excuse for ocelot to toy with someone
but it does give us a chance to see how
the cast interacts with one another
volgan also joins ocelot and snake who
together make up a list of characters in
this series who have a catchphrase or
signature move they use often volgen
loves to say kuabara kuabara when
lightning appears originally I thought
he said this because he was a fan of
YuYu Hakusho but it seems to be a
Japanese saying that some will say in
hopes of warding off lightning ocelots
got his own little hand gesture too that
he likes to do and while not incredibly
important to the story at large it is a
nice detail that gives them some unique
personality even if it is a bit corny at
times eventually snake makes it to the
lab where sokoloff is supposed to be but
ends up finding a man named granin
instead despite being a Russian official
he doesn't see snake as an enemy mostly
because he's too drunk to care but also
because snake's Mission could provide
some mutual benefit to him Brandon was
the original creator of the metal gear
and his design documents prove this
he'll eventually end up passing these
documents over to a friend in the United
States who we learn as Huey Emerick
aracan's father yet the same one the
reason he's doing this is because
Colonel volgan decided that sokolov shag
Ahad was a much better project to put
his time and money into so he rejected
granin's idea kind of giving us a key so
that we can get closer to the facility
where sokoloff is being held the problem
is that the facility is quite a ways
away and will require us to go to the
summit of a nearby Mountain on the way
there we'll also run into the fear in
the end who get put down as well more
important than all that though is the
boss fight right after this a comically
large ladder
it's not actually important it's just
really damn long for some reason
that the Summit is where he made Eva
who's in the middle of getting changed
snake comments on her scars and she says
that they are from Colonel volgan saying
that he's a sadist that enjoys
inflicting pain on others after their
talk and a bit of flirting she'll give
snake a key and a look at the facility
where sokoloff is located the building
we need to enter could only be accessed
by Colonel vulgan and major Ivan that's
the Ryden parody we have to steal his
outfit but they never tell us how so we
can either kill him or knock him out if
we want to this Choice was for those who
hated Ryden and wanted to enact some
form of pain on him before we can enter
the base though we have to battle the
final member of the cobras the fury his
fight goes about as you would expect I
know it seems like I'm just skipping
over them on purpose to prove a point
but there really is nothing to talk
about here each of them is just an
obstacle and that's all they provide to
the plot
the fury does at least tell us that he
was sent into space at one point but
ended up seeing a world engulfed in
flames which is what contributed to his
Pyromania but that's it I mean it's a
story not anything remotely interesting
and a far cry from Alexa fortune in
foxhound which is why I decided to put
in as much effort as the game puts into
them similar to mgs2 the game really
started to lose me at this point in fact
mgs3 has the same problem as two it
takes at least two-thirds of the game to
complete the first objective all we've
done for six hours is run around on a
goose chase looking for sokolov we've
done nothing to advance the plot in any
way and it really starts to drag down
the quality immensely I'll say now just
like mgs2 both games end on a great note
but both also take just as long if not
longer an mgs3's case to go somewhere
most of this could be attributed to its
length as mgs3 is roughly a 10 hour game
so obviously it's not going to have as
much time to really develop the
characters but for a series that's
completely fine with having you listen
to conversations about James Bond for 10
minutes you would think the same effort
would be put into the actual story
itself because think about it what have
we learned so far the Shag Aaj still
being worked on the boss ocelot and
Colonel vogen are still working together
and sokolov still hasn't been found
probably the most interesting piece of
information that we found ever since the
boss's defection is how the metal gear
documents made it to the United States
which is something that isn't even
related to the current story and rather
recontextualizes past games plots plus
if I want to be extremely picky this
information is also a retcon as it was
told to us in mgs1 that oticon created
Metal Gear racks not granin but mgs3
changes to fit its narrative although to
be fair you could argue that create and
design are two different things in this
context
to live to regret this
and when they themselves become the
targets of my creation they will know my
true greatness
I don't need you I just need your brain
I created Rex it's my right my duty to
destroy him regardless it was quite
frustrating playing this game at times
as it felt like things were going
anywhere and I was just being dragged
along and told to do pointless side
objectives for no reason thankfully
though it does get a little bit better
after this one snake deals with the
Ryden parody he'll make it to the base
and meet with sokolov sokolov then tells
him about the details of the Shag a hot
and how one's face to his complete he'll
likely be killed by Colonel vulgans
since he won't be needed anymore so we
have to hurry volgan also plans to mass
produce the Shag a hot and chip into
some of the Soviet Union's Eastern
allies as well some other third world
countries to likely cause an all-out War
the likes of which we've never seen
before we can get more info out of him
though the boss and volgan arrived to
ruin the day again the boss immediately
sees the raw disguise but volgan is less
convinced it needs to feel snake's dick
to see if it matches major Ivins
incredibly odd detail aside snake is
then taken and tortured by volgan the
scene where vulgan beats up snake is
great as it displays the sheer
difference in power between these two
and could in a very roundabout way show
how much he cares about Ivan since he
has no idea what we did to get this
outfit which means to volgan his Lover's
possibly dead he absolutely manhandles
snake here and his subsequent torture is
going to be even worse volgan firmly
believes that snake is here because of
the Philosopher's Legacy and then he
just spills out the entire plot in grave
detail he basically says the Legacy the
Philosopher's Legacy the Legacy with a
hundred billion dollars the one made
from the three great superpowers the one
I have hidden in My Vault underground
like he's just asking to get it taken
from him and it's a poor attempt at
explaining to the player what this
object even is because volgan should not
be saying This plus this scene is
absolutely hilarious in hindsight given
who's in the room with him now you could
say this is a 200 IQ play from volgen to
lure out the Spy as he does know there
is a spy within his ranks but this is
also the same dude who shot a nuke at
his own own countrymen so I find that
hard to believe the game also pretty
much confirms the detail most players
saw coming as right after he says where
it's hidden Tatiana and the Boss look at
each other both of them right before
they leave also talk to snake in private
the boss tells him to run and Tatiana
tells him how to escape this confirms
that the former doesn't plan on killing
snake and or wants him to succeed in his
mission and that the latter was Eva all
along I have zero idea how it took snake
that long to figure it out given that
there isn't many long blonde-haired
women in the Soviet Union especially
when you consider that not only did he
ask her about her scars but she also
tells him that she has her other part to
play implying that she has to be Tatiana
I guess all his intelligence went
towards survival tactics rather than
Common Sense although maybe if he wasn't
looking at her tits the whole time he
probably could have noticed how similar
they look but by far my favorite part of
this scene though is when snake is
attacked so much that he drops a
transmitter according to the ball she
placed a transmitter on him so that she
could keep track of his movements when
Colonel volgan asks for proof that she's
not working for snake she challenges him
and volgan backs away the dude is very
clearly scared of her which just shows
how terrifying the boss is Not only was
she the leader of a unit that has
Supernatural Powers when she herself has
none but she's also able to intimidate
volgan these are the kind of things I
love to see in this series small details
that aren't mentioned but just shown to
the player there's no need to bring
attention to it since the scene does a
good enough job on its own and I'm glad
that something like this was included
ocelot will then take the opportunity to
screw with Eva by doing his Russian
Roulette thing again and ends up
shooting snake in the eye luckily it
missed his brain but now he's
permanently missing an eye snake is now
locked up in prison and needs to escape
however if he went in first person when
the boss was leaving though you would
have seen the sorrow who gives in the
code frequency that opens the door we'll
be meeting the sorrow in just a moment a
snake manages to escape only to be
cornered by ocelot and his Squad he then
takes the opportunity to toy with him
before snake jumps realizing he has no
way out instead of waking up though he
meets with the sorrow despite the health
bar this isn't actually a boss fight but
rather a message walking along the river
are ghostly apparitions of the people
you've killed I don't know if it counts
every single person but the more people
you kill the more show up here now mgs3
was definitely the hardest game for me
at the time so ended up killing quite a
few people it's not that I couldn't
progress I just kept getting caught
while sneaking around which resulted in
me having to go loud quite often to
escape though you need to use a fake
death pill along with your Revival tooth
which is an item you were given at the
beginning of the game and has other
practical uses outside of this boss
fight but it's nice to see that your
equipment was taken into account here
here while walking along the river the
star will comment on snake in your
performance it's not as bizarre as
psychomantis but it's just to get the
player to think about the lives they've
taken the ghost walking through the
river also hurt you so I can imagine
this being quite the difficult fight on
the harder difficulties as it forces you
to not kill as many people prior to this
fight set the walk Downstream isn't
impossible the star will also mention
that snake will be killed by a sun in
the future referring to solid snake
killing him in Metal Gear 2. a snake
wakes up though he hears the final
memory of the sorrow and it shows us
that the boss killed the sorrow in the
past which is why he's dead in the
present the boss and the saw were not
only allies but also lovers at one point
as the two had a child she would end up
giving birth to him in the middle of a
battlefield but her child was taken by a
group called The philosophers she and
this Aura would then end up being on
opposing side sticks of the Cold War and
was forced to kill him or the child
would die Instead This is what leads me
to believe that the sorrow and by
extension all the Cobra unit are trying
to help snake given his relationship to
the boss they want to teach him how to
survive while also going out in a blaze
of glory as they likely don't have a
purpose anymore snake then makes his way
to a nearby cave and talks to Eva who
gives him some explosives that he'll
need to destroy the Shag
the two also take some time to relax and
hang out before getting back to the
mission Evo is ultimately still a spy
but she does love snake to an extent
it's quite the adorable relationship
they have going on but their time is
going to be cut short as they have a
mission to complete I will say though
Eva is a fantastic character and was
very well written as the attractive
double-crossing spy she toys with the
player quite a bit as you know she's not
loyal to the US and likely has her own
motives so you know she's just teasing
you but she is very charismatic at times
snake seems to like Eva as well but he
doesn't seem to show any sort of
affection towards her because of the
mission I wouldn't say that it's the
mission as a whole bow but rather what
it entails as he's being told to kill
someone he's known and loved for years
and he's still trying to Grapple with
the fact that she betrayed him in the
first place for as much as he puts on
this strong cocky face he's very broken
and hasn't had much time to come to
terms with what's going on so naturally
he's more focused on that than Eva snake
will then make it to the shakahad and
attempt to destroy it before being
caught by ocelot Vulcan and the boss
again seems like Eva was also caught as
vulgan found her with the Philosopher's
Legacy the legacy is a microfilm that
contains the transactions that were made
by those in control of the money who are
the members of the three superpowers
China Russia and the us as I jokingly
stated before the philosophers had a
hundred billion dollars that they pulled
together they then used this money to
fund the recent World War so the Axis
powers could be defeated after the war
ended the money was supposed to be split
evenly amongst the members but volgan's
father devised a series of plans that
allowed him to gain control of all the
money this Legacy is also one of the
main reasons the Cold War even started
because after this happened the members
split into three groups perspective of
the three countries and attempted to
seize or keep control of it if you
happen to need more proof that
everyone's pretty much double crossing
each other at this point not only does
the boss talk to Eva in private instead
of killing her as she said she would but
ocelot nods to her shortly after
implying that everyone is working for
and against each other at the same time
I'll explain their loyalties later but
basically everyone's playing volgan at
this point which makes the previous
scene hilarious as he leaked the
location of the film The Three spies at
the same time we then have to face
volgan in one of the many boss fights
soon to come his fights aren't as
Innovative as the Cobra unit so there
isn't many tricks involved in defeating
him but seeing as he's supposed to be
one of the climactic Final Bosses it
makes sense defeating the kernel allows
us to escape the hangar before it
explodes but vulging's not going down
that easily which results in the next 10
minutes being a full-on action movie
James Bond finale it's even got one of
its age-old tropes driving down a
highway on a bike while being pursued by
a large vehicle at top speed Eve is the
one who's going to be driving while
snake does the shooting the jagahot
though is way too durable for snakes
bullets so they have to use explosives
that Eva planted earlier but not even
that works the fight between volgen is
the best final boss fight in the series
so far I understand that the game isn't
over yet but the Shag a hot is
reminiscent of the metal gear fights
from the previous games and out of those
this one is certainly the best I think
for the time those fights worked but
things should definitely be escalating
now so I'm glad they added multiple
phases and set pieces to really drive
home how dangerous these weapons are but
as I said this isn't the final fight
defeating volgan is just one part of the
finale as even snake end up getting
chased by some of allgan's men before
crashing and falling off a cliff Evo is
severely wounded so we have to escort
her to safety just like we did with Emma
in the last game escort missions usually
suck but I didn't find this to be too
annoying as Ava could hold her own and
walks at a somewhat decent pace plus
given how much screen time she's been
given you've likely grown attached to
her and want to help her once the two
make it out of the forest though Eva
starts the vehicle she left nearby while
snake deals with the boss without
wasting a moment the boss calls for her
men to launch a nuke forcing snake to
fight her at this point it's pretty
obvious that the boss isn't trying to
fight us but we still don't know the
full story of why she refuses to tell us
and rather lament about her past life as
a soldier and how she's seen the world
change many times throughout her life
she continues talking about her allies
and friends and it sounds like she's
trying to get us to sympathize with her
choices but depending on how you feel
about her you might see her as a traitor
but that couldn't be further from the
truth in fact she's one of the most
patriotic people in the United States
the boss never intended on betraying the
United States but she had to in order to
save the world as we know the
philosophers are a group of people from
the three superpowers that funded World
War II the people within that group have
changed over time but the original
members used to refer to themselves as
the wise men's committee the last time
we heard this name was when we discussed
the Patriots and that's not a
coincidence the philosophers in the
Patriots aren't connected in any way but
you could say that the Patriots are the
successors as the philosophers would
soon disband thanks to the Cold War and
the Legacy being taken the original
philosophers came together to stop War
but once the original members died their
group views became corrupted instead
steered towards creating endless Wars
the organizations in their respective
countries were controlling the
government at the time and would
continue to do so until the Cold War
they hoped to create endless conflict as
a way to gain and keep their power as
war and its consequences would feel even
more war a good example would be how the
world transitioned from the first to
second World War World War one saw
Germany weakened thanks to losing most
of its military as well as it being
taxed and treated this led to its
eventual ruler that one guy from the hit
game Wolfenstein deceives power as he
promoted lots of pro-germanic propaganda
and also denounced the Treaty of
Versailles now obviously there is a lot
more details involved in that man's
Reign but still you could see how the
results of the previous world were
partially responsible for the cause of
the next and that's what the
philosophers hope to achieve keeping the
world at war keeps them in power as they
control lots of their country's
governments either by donating large
sums of money to them or by employing
some of their own soldiers to serve with
them one of the members of the original
philosophers was the boss's father but
was eventually killed by the group The
philosophers were also the ones who
forced the boss to kill the sorrow and
took the baby they conceived together on
the topic of that I guess while it's
unexplicitly stated it's way too much of
a coincidence to not be considered true
but an optional Kodak call reveals that
ocelot was also born on a battlefield
which confirms that the boss and the
sorrow are his parents which once again
makes that scene with volgan even
funnier sometime after this the boss
would be selected for a mission that
involves doing the Legacy she was to
gain Colonel vulgan's trust in order to
steal it from him and defecting to the
Soviet Union was volgan's idea that's
why snake being at the bridge caused a
bit of a problem for her as vulgum would
have easily killed snake without
question so the boss opted to throw him
over the bridge herself hoping that he
would be strong enough to survive snake
nor the player were informed of his plan
so to us she was betraying us but that
was all a part of her plan until volgan
shot the nuke the nuke was the reason
Khrushchev called President Johnson and
why operation Snake Eater even started
the boss's orders also had to change the
KGB needed proof that the US didn't
betray them and the boss was set up to
be the Fall Guy and the best way to
convince him that the US wasn't lying
was by having one of her former students
be the one to put her down the boss
never betrayed her country and never
planned on it in fact her role as the
Fall Guy was to save her country neither
snake nor the player know this just yet
though and they won't know until after
they kill her so that revealed that the
boss was innocent the whole time hits
pretty hard especially when you consider
the fact that to the broader World
she'll be known as a war criminal and a
traitor despite her actions being the
reason the world is still around today a
it's one of the greatest reveals and
finales in the series and the boss is a
fantastic fight the arena itself is
gorgeous it reminded me a lot of ishin's
Arena from sakuro there's always
something about an open field filled
with flowers that really adds to the
aesthetic of a location tying this back
to an earlier scene this is why a lot of
the boss's dialogue is about enemies
being relative and not absolute the boss
was a close friend but now an enemy
thanks to the times and the boss's Cobra
unit went from friends to enemies to
friends again thanks to the times time
is an ever-changing idea and as times go
on relationships change turning enemies
to friends and Friends into enemies it's
supposed to convey that there isn't such
a thing as good or bad guys it's just
two different people with different
ideologies shaped by their environment
in the current times it's also a meta
message in that sense as the game is
asking us to look at snake differently
remember prior to this big boss was seen
as a villain but this game puts things
into perspective especially when you
realize that this is how he earned the
name Big Boss the US government gave him
the title thanks to him surpassing the
boss it's incredibly tone deaf and
really makes snake question his own
loyalties things of the country he loved
throwing both him and the boss under the
bus because it suited them big boss
while a villain in later games is at the
moment a dedicated soldier who was asked
to kill someone he loved all to find out
it was a setup and that the boss was
never betraying him he was being used
like a pawn and sacrifice that the U.S
could get a Checkmate snake may not have
died physically but naked snake died in
that fight all that's left is Big Boss a
man who's broken and would eventually
want nothing more than to change the
world but not in a way that would be
beneficial after the boss dies Eva and
snake Escape before the bombs go off we
didn't see them relax and share a few
private moments with each other before
we realized that Eva was betraying snake
too this is one I definitely saw coming
but her role is not something I would
have guessed evil is still a spy so I
figured she would have taken the
Philosopher's Legacy when she had the
chance but that doesn't mean that evil
was lying to snake her feelings toward
him were real which is why she had a
hard time deciding whether or not to
kill him as she was supposed to
eliminate anyone who was involved even
though it was working for the Chinese
philosophers but she wasn't the only one
gunning for the Legacy the end credit
scene shows us that ocelot was Adam one
of the two code Breakers that defected
in addition him also being a spy for the
KGB and CIA a typical ocelot fashion
he's double in triple Crossing everyone
it also seems like the Legacy Eva Stole
was a fake and that the real Legacy and
its funds were split into two half going
to the US while the others go back to
the KGB the game that ends with big boss
receiving his title and medal for all
his hard work you can tell none of this
is satisfying to him though give him
what he had to do to get it big boss
then goes off alone to visit the boss
and man talk about getting hit in the
fields
[Music]
while this happens some government
officials start talking about creating a
unit like Fox to use in the Army this
would uncreatively be called foxhound
also went creatively is the Game ending
with a timeline showing what will happen
in the coming years the only real
important details is that major zero was
disbanding Fox the US philosophers
renamed themselves to be the Patriots
and that big boss carried on the legacy
of fox by Leading foxhound it's a bit of
an odd way to end the game especially
after the emotional ceremony and tribute
to the boss but seeing as this was
supposed to be the end of the series I
guess it makes sense besides it's not
like it takes away from the finale which
is easily one of mgs3's strongest acts
the beginning and the end just like mgs2
are the best parts of the series third
entry but just like its predecessor its
middle is extremely weak even more so
with mgs3 as the Cobra unit only serves
to be Pace changers for the gameplay
alone story-wise They don't serve much
purpose and further delay the story from
going anywhere this was an issue that
plagued mgs2 as well but I think mgs3
takes it even further as finding
sokoloff our first objective takes way
too long and it makes you feel like
you're just walking around and killing
people without any sense of direction
overall though this game like its
siblings is incredible and had the
series ended here it would have left us
with a lot of questions but it wouldn't
have been on a bad note metagrosala was
ahead of its time in both gameplay and
story and its themes and messages are
conveyed exceptionally well and are very
thought-provoking even today getting to
learn more about the world of Metal Gear
Solid through these three games was
fantastic and something I wish I'd done
earlier each game expands your brain a
bit as you start to really listen to the
messages of these games and really
listen to what Kojima is talking about
he may be a Madman at times but he's got
some good points every now and then
putting all this together though it's no
wonder why the series took off the way
it did and managed to Garner such a
devoted fan base but much to some fans
and even kojima's surprise the series
was nowhere near finished yet
Metal Gear Solid 4 is a game that
shouldn't have existed the development
Behind these games is as spotty as the
story of them but according to an
interview with Konami Kojima said quote
I intended from GS3 to wrap up the
series with so many people wanted to
know what happened after two things like
the identity of the Patriots and so
forth I plan on leaving those Mysteries
as Mysteries but people weren't
convinced that the series was wrapped up
so ultimately we ended up making four
originally Kojima was going to step down
in series Creator and give the reins to
another director but after receiving
numerous death threats from fans he was
forced to return and as you would expect
being forced to make a game you didn't
want to make in the first place is the
first step towards failure now mgs4 is
not a bad game but it's definitely the
worst one we've covered so far if I had
to give it a numerical ranking I'd say
it's probably a 6 out of 10. I might
even be convinced to give the IGN
special depending on the day by all
accounts that's not bad we're given that
this series so far has produced nines
and tens you can see why it's the lowest
on the list thus far a lot of the game
shortcomings though don't make itself
known until the second or third act as
the very beginning of the game was
rather impressive it first starts with a
sequence of TV shows that you can flip
through at this point I'd become so
desensitized to the methods of Kojima
that I honestly had no reaction to it
had any other game did this I definitely
would have been confused wondering if I
bought the wrong game but this is Metal
Gear Solid we're talking about so this
stuff is just par for the course as
bizarre as it seems there is a message
involved in all this as every channel
has something to do with war and
violence there's a cooking show that
takes place in a bomb shelter a game
show with all the questions being
related to war in the military as well
as various commercials about pmcs pmcs
are private military companies and in
the world of Metal Gear Solid these guys
are a hot commodity this game is a
sequel to MGs S2 it takes place five
years after the events of that game in
2014. currently the world has delved
into chaos with war being the thing that
fuels it the league contributor to this
has been the newly created sop system or
sons of the Patriots it's a highly
Advanced system that is almost essential
when in combat for a soldier it allows
them to sync up with their team allowing
each other to take hits without feeling
pain coordinate attacks in quick
succession and even block out mental
emotions like trauma so you're always in
Tip-Top shape for high-ranking officials
like commanders and captains they can
assess a person's entire body from their
blood type and DNA to even their
feelings allowing them to see how their
soldiers are faring and be able to make
rational decisions the SOP system also
has ID locks on guns and vehicles so
only the owners can use them this
prevents enemy guns from falling into
the wrong hands and also prevents PMC
soldiers from defecting or choosing not
to fight as the system would lock them
out of their weapons leaving them
defenseless it's really cool and also
very terrifying as it's not only ramped
up the intensity of War for years but
it's also such a powerful tool that
people have become dependent on it
clearly sop has its benefits so armies
are going to need it if they want to leg
up on the competition just about every
country and government that can afford
it has the system and their soldiers and
even some police forces have it as well
this overdependence will naturally come
back to bite everyone in the ass later
but the First Act of the game is used to
show how the system works and also how
the world has been faring since the
Manhattan incident which brings us to
where we are now as we start mgs4 back
in the saddle with the man himself Solid
Snake who's deep in the Middle East we
can see that the accelerated aging has
started to take an effect on him as he
looks noticeably older despite it only
being a few years according to oticon
snake has about a year left to live
which is very sad to hear he's still
going to make the most of it though
which is why he's here on the front
lines again currently a war is going on
but snake is here for a completely
different reason who are the groups that
are fighting who knows why are they
fighting who cares to be fair there is
sort of a reason why they're here but
it's mostly just to show that war is so
common that oftentimes the motivation
behind it is unknown or even
non-existent thanks to the SOP system
and the Patriots the world has become
reliant on War as a way to balance the
economy many governments have also
started hiring pmcs in order to fight
proxy wars for them the five largest
pmcs are under a mother name called
outer Heaven run by liquid snake this is
also why Solid Snake is here is because
he plans to take down liquid in between
the events of mgs2 and 4 it seems like
liquid has fully taken over ocelot's
body and Now controls him this whole
thing with liquid is really hard to
explain so for right now just go with
the fact that this is liquid snake and
ocelot's body as we'll Circle back to
this at the end regardless the Reliance
on war has created What's called the war
economy and it's become so ingrained
into society that removing it would
essentially [__] the entire world
remember back in mgs2 when President
Johnson said that he originally wanted
to stop the Patriots but realized that
without them the resulting alternative
would be worse this is what he meant the
world has become so reliant on the war
economy that's stopping War altogether
would destroy the economy this idea is
going to reappear a few times throughout
the game and is one of the main hurdles
that we'll have to deal with so keep
this in mind helping him on the mission
is oticon as usual as well as a girl
named Sunny she's actually the child
that Olga gave birth to but never saw
thanks to the big shell incident
Otakon decided to take her in and race
her seeing his Olga had passed which was
nice of him the person who actually gave
the group their mission though is none
other than Roy Campbell he wants snake
to meet up with a group called the rap
Patrol who's located in the combat zones
that he can get more info on liquid's
whereabouts the first few scenes give us
a real good lookus that not only stinks
to equipment but also the effects of War
a reoccurring theme in this game is the
idea of war and how PTSD manifests in
each person differently these militia
men are no match for the coordinated
attacks of the pmcs especially when they
bring out the geckos which are these
highly mobile combat units that
absolutely decimate anything it sees
these soldiers are fearing for their
lives and were able to see this happen
in real time as there's a Bunker full of
injured and dead soldiers as well as
dozens of men who are cowering in you're
hoping to see tomorrow it's terrifying
and PTSD is a theme is one of mgs4's
strong suits as it affects everyone even
snake as these weird flashbacks could be
attributed to some of his past battles
sometimes when specific characters or
actions happen we can press the x button
to see a previous memory to be fair it's
not perfect though as some of the
flashbacks reference things that
happened earlier in the mission or just
things snake never saw like when he
salutes in a flashback of mgs3's ending
appears still though I think some of it
could be used to convey the idea that
snake's old memories are resurfacing and
while he's doing fine mentally there is
some underlying trauma there this game
more than any before it though was the
one that really convinced me that
violence wasn't the answer here as at
least within this act we have no stake
in this war each game we were fighting
people who are opposed to us but right
now we're a third party we have no stock
in this war so killing these people is
pointless sadly most of our hard work is
undone as many of the soldiers end up
dying by each other's hands anyway but
despite being older now snake shows us
that he can still hang with the best of
them even when times get tough not just
due to his own combat prowess but also
his new suit the Octo camera well this
mechanically is an automated version of
the camo system from mgs3 as simply
lying on anything will change the suit's
color to match the environment this does
make combat though a breeze as you can
hide in plain sight even when it's
bright and sunny out sadly it's not as
intricate as the cutscene showcases like
how the one section of his leg turns
green thanks to the melons near him but
the general idea is still there the game
even lets you save the camo patterns you
have just in case you got a really cool
design and even lets you handle the camo
manually like mgs3 but I never saw a
need for that we'll talk about the
combat in just a bit though as we are
still missing one key part of the game's
mechanics but on the way there we get a
brief cutscene with Otakon and snake
which repeats the mission briefing we
showed earlier once that happens though
my game crashes
oh yeah Jesus it's been five minutes and
already have to talk about this yeah
mgs4 runs like [__] sort of mgs4 was
originally released on the PS3 but
unlike literally every game in this
video it's never been ported to another
console I could understand console
exclusivity but PS3 only is a bizarre
decision especially since this serves as
the ending of the entire Saga Metal Gear
Sola 1 had an expanded version called
MGS integral a PC port and a remaster
called MGS twin Snakes even Metal Gear 1
and 2 got re-released not just on other
consoles like the NES and famicom but
both are a part of the HD Collection
that comes with mgs2 3 and peacewalker
but mgs4 has to stay on this console no
matter what this became a problem for me
since I never owned a PS3 so I decided
to emulate it but mgs4 does not play
well with emulators it's definitely
gotten better over time but I've decided
that buying an original PS3 was a better
alternative my unimportant sob story
aside there is a discussion to be had
about why this game is only on this
console it's one of the few games in the
series that many people will just not be
able to play as it either requires is a
powerful PC and enough know how to
emulate or enough money to buy a PS3
just to play this one game and that
sucks because even though this game's
writing is questionable at times it's
important to play not just because it's
a core part of the series but it's the
ending of it thankfully this is my job
so jumping through various loopholes to
get a game is not a problem but not
everyone has the foresight to save an
old console they don't touch anymore or
has the funds to buy a used one for 150
dollars just to play one game they may
not even like even though mgs4 is not
some people's favorites and it's not
mine either I still think making the
game more available should have been a
top priority for Konami but it clearly
wasn't which means that this game will
likely be a lost Relic forever stuck on
this console even if emulation is making
great strides to prevent that from
happening the one positive is that
YouTube playthroughs exist and no game
benefits from this more than mgs4 since
a large portion of the game is cutscenes
this has been a series wide phenomenon
as we've discussed before but this game
is long even by Metal Gear Solid Zone
standards to give you an idea of what I
mean the first two acts of the game are
roughly five and a half hours but only
two hours of that is actual game play
now this is a very rough outline and not
completely accurate but still hopefully
this gives you a general idea of what I
mean when I say this game is a movie
Just Like I said before as a concept I
don't mind the idea of a long cut scene
as long as the cutscene provides
something of note and it's not just long
for the sake of it and this extends the
gameplay as well the problem is that
mgs4 is a game of great ideas with poor
execution and there are two pretty good
examples to convey what I mean later in
act 3 we're tasked with tailing a
resistance member so we can find their
Hideout as an idea I like it as the
series doesn't have a whole lot of
variety in its missions despite it being
a stealth game killing people is a
common Mission objective in stealth
games but Metal Gear Solid hasn't really
capitalized on it so I appreciated its
inclusion the issue is that the tailing
Mission lasts about 25 minutes and all
you're doing in the meantime is
following some guy while occasionally
taking out guards along the way the
other example is this scene a little bit
later when liquid is surrounded by
hundreds of military soldiers the scene
is supposed to convey how people are
surrounding liquid and also how strong
he is since he's about to defeat all
them by locking their gun IDs it has
liquid going out into the open while
dozens of vehicles from boats to trucks
to helicopters surround him it's a great
scene but this one interaction lasts
four minutes I know that's not long but
given that there's still more to the
cutscene and this is just one part of it
you would assume it'd be 30 seconds to a
minute at most just about every scene in
this game goes two or three times past
its necessary length which is what adds
to the run time plus given that Kojima
is a tailbone show kind of person you
know a good portion of these cutscenes
are just Exposition not all the scenes
are like this though in fact some of the
cutscenes are actually better when they
are long like this fight that happens
much later but certain parts overstay
their welcome which really contributes
to the notion that mgs4 is really just a
movie with the occasional gameplay level
and that it's long and drawn out getting
back to the story though after calling
through the trenches of the combat zone
while each side is piling on its
casualties snake will make it to a
building with a monkey next to the
monkey is dreven a gun launderer due to
the war economy guns are hot on the
market but since IDs prevent people from
using them German takes the guns he
finds or moves the tags and sells them
off to the highest bidder he's basically
playing for both teams as each team will
need the guns and he's got him so he
sells them off to the pmcs and militias
they die he collects them again resells
them to someone else and the cycle
repeats now Dragon makes it explicitly
clear that he doesn't get his hands
dirty as he's just a businessman so he's
not killing anyone to get their guns nor
is he going out and getting them himself
as he has agents to do that for him and
snake is about to be one of them drebin
also gives him a shot of suppressor Nano
machines so that he can use some of the
non-id guns this is something that's
going to make less sense the further we
continue so let me just say now that
dragon is lying inside this range is
actually another version of Fox die
we'll just call Fox die 2. as we know
Fox die 1 was already inside snake's
body but now he has Fox die too it
follows the same idea of only killing
specific people but we don't know who
those people are the only reason drebin
was given this was because he was
working for someone given the major
players that play here it's not really
hard to assume who he's working for but
he doesn't seem to be hostile to snake
despite this he's still a businessman
through and through and will make sure
snake's life is not in danger as he's a
valuable customer but his bosses clearly
have it out for snake regardless drebin
and his shop are a core part of mgs4's
gameplay he kind of reminds me of the
re4 merchant except driving can be
accessed from the menu at any time and
doesn't have any set locations he says
that if you pick up any guns off the
ground you'll get drebin points you can
use to cash in for ammo guns or
attachments so what you'll be doing is
Scavenging battlefields for guns that
you can get his points to use him in his
shot honestly I was kind of hoping that
mgs4 was really going to go further with
its Stealth gameplay since ID guns means
we can't pick them off the ground thus
forcing the player to play more
passively as you won't be able to use
any old assault rifle to deal with your
problems this system completely flips it
on its head though as I'd argue the game
actually encourages you to kill people
and doesn't shy away from putting you in
dramatic action scenes there's this
whole bike chase scene like the one at
the end of mgs3 there's another one but
this time on Dragon's APC numerous Comet
encounters were forced to go loud and
don't even get me started on the metal
gear fight later it's definitely the
most action-heavy game thus far and
while not a bad thing I do miss some of
the old stealth encounters most of that
is present in the early acts but as the
game goes on it starts to drift more
towards high octane action rather than
stealth as an action game though it's
not too bad and still has some of that
metal gear charm in it my only complaint
is that it felt too easy at times not in
regards to difficulty but more along the
lines of ammo and strategy as running
out of ammo in this game is a minor
inconvenience as all it takes is a trip
to drive and Shop to get more ammo and
not only is it extremely cheap you can
do this from whenever you want in the
pause menu so essentially you could run
out of ammo made boss fight pause then
come back with a full stack of 700 a
minute or two later it's definitely a
bit bizarre but while not one of my
favorite combat systems in the series I
can see how many people have taken a
liking to it as the system does have its
merits as for drebin himself though
personality wise I think he's great he
and his monkey are extremely
entertaining to listen to and they make
for some incredible moments relax it
won't hurt
you're scared of needles or something
[Laughter]
my only issue is that Dragon starts to
be the resident lore keeper a bit later
as he seems to know everything that's
going on in the game and it starts to
really become clear that he's being used
as an exposition tool for the writers to
convey certain things about the story to
the player
continuing on though once treven leaves
snake will eventually make his way to
the building where he's supposed to meet
the Rat Patrol after a quick interaction
they realize that they're on the same
side so they seize fire leading this
ragtag group of individuals is Merrell
who we haven't seen since mgs1 there is
a surprising amount of old characters
that are thrown into this game and it
seems like this was done in a ways to
wrap up their stories but sometimes it's
okay to just let things labor they are I
don't mind Meryl being here but it did
originally feel like the team went okay
who haven't we seen in a while and then
landed on Merrell and decided to make
her relevant to the story again but I
liked her placement in the story as
she's the one who fills us in on the SOP
system and what it entails she also
seems to be in favor of the system
despite it very clearly being a major
breach of privacy Merrill even
recognizes this but says that the
benefits outweigh the negatives as it
helps them do their job she like many
are a slave to the system but don't seem
to mind it which relates to another
theme of this game and that's an over
Reliance on technology all these pmcs
have become so dependent on the system
that once it's gone they don't know how
to function which will have some dire
consequences soon the other members of
the team are quite forgettable except
this master individual named Johnny he's
a more relevant version of the bathroom
soldiers we've seen throughout the
series in each game prior there was a
jail guard who would have stomach issues
which will give us the opportunity to
escape while they're in the bathroom
this game doesn't have a torture or jail
sequence which makes it the first in the
series so they opted to just make a
character based around them Johnny is
also a reoccurring character although
you'd be forgiven for not knowing who it
is as not only is he the bathroom Guard
from mgs1 but he's also the guy Meryl
knocked out in that game what snake
leaves the DARPA Chief cell Merrell
points a gun to him while wearing a
soldier's uniform that guard she took
the uniform from was Johnny we could see
him positioned right behind her during
the cut scene another very odd inclusion
for the mind of Kojima especially since
Johnny reappears throughout the story
quite a bit and even shits himself
during a firefight which is about to
happen right now before that happens
though we have to talk about Maryland
snake is the last time we saw them the
two were in love but it doesn't seem
like that anymore while snake distanced
himself from Mara left her mgs1 since he
joined up without a Khan to form
philanthropy she eventually realized
that he never accepted her and didn't
want anything to do with him so the two
broke it off it's a bit of a shame that
the two had a falling out but she does
still seem to care about him especially
if that bandana she's wearing was the
one from mgs1
circling back to the firefight earlier
the Rat Patrol and snake make their way
to the basement while defending
themselves from the Frog unit this is
one of liquid's main troops as it's an
army of Nano machine enhanced women
there isn't much to note outside of this
although I would like to ask where
liquid found these women since my
mother-based stats and peace Walker was
a 96-4 split when it came to gender so
he must have all the women combatants in
the world given how many frog units we
face in the game either way that's not
the only woman he'll be facing as snake
comes in contact with the B and B Unit B
and B or beauty and beast is a group of
four deeply traumatized women who fight
for liquid and whose sole purpose is to
hunt bound Solid Snake is they believe
that killing him will set their minds
free in terms of an introduction they
have one of the strongest in the series
as they're seeing completely wiping on a
squad without any issue the battle also
shows us their strengths as each one
attacks in ways that are beneficial to
them their introduction is wonderful
everything else about them is
questionable firstly the members of the
group are laughing octopus raging Raven
crying wolf and screaming mantis their
group name references their two
different forms their outside beastial
form and their interview Beauty form
once the Beast form is destroyed
personally though I think the name
should be changed to the fan service
unit not the traditional definition mind
you the other one that references Easter
eggs and homages as the B and B unit is
an amalgamation of the three previous
groups put together each member has two
words in their name the first one
represents an emotion similar to that of
the Cobra unit the second word is a
reference to someone from foxhound and
the weapons they use are once woothed by
the members of dead cell for example we
can look at laughing octopus laughing is
a happy emotion similar to The Joy which
was the boss's name the octopus is a
reference to decoy Octopus from foxhound
and she uses a P90 and tentacles to
attack you like solidus does this same
idea can be applied to the other three
members without fail which begs the
question if they're just the three
previous factions put together what
makes them different and separates them
from the groups that they make up
well that would be the other definition
of fan service this might be the most
puzzling aspect of this group as it's
done in a way that's not only harmful
but also takes away from the unit's
message fan service as a concept is not
an issue it's just the specific people
it's being used on and the order in
which it's being used here is the
problem each member of the unit is based
on four real-life models that help
provide the motion capture for them this
fits given that they're supposed to be
both Beauties and beasts then the game
Devils into full-on fan service once
their beauty form has been Unleashed the
game positions the camera so you can get
a good long look at their bodies as well
as a few first-person povs that also
focus on their assets furthermore
they're not only wearing extremely tight
clothing so as to show off their
physique but they walk rather
seductively towards the player once they
do catch up the snake they damage him by
rubbing up against and hugging him to
top it all off if you wait a few minutes
during this phase of the fight then
you'll be transported into a clear white
room where you could take pictures on
your camera and have them pose for you
or play music off your iPod which has
them sing like the leader of an idol
group it's both bizarre and very
confusing as it conflicts with the
message of this unit it greatly now I'm
not willing to cast aside the room since
it's in the game and the way to access
the room is one of the easiest things in
the world is the women in the beauty
phase are very easy to defeat so Kojima
clearly wanted the player to see this
but even if we did ignore this detail
the framing and design of the unit goes
against exactly what the unit is about
each one of these women have some of the
most horrific backstories I've ever
heard and the fights themselves showcase
this trauma to the player each of them
was captured as a child then forced to
do something that would permanently scar
them for Life laughing octopus was
forced to torture and kill her own
friends and family and had to laugh the
whole time or else she'd be killed
raging Raven watched all the other kids
near her be eaten alive by Ravens
screaming mantis had to hide from
enemies in a room that'd be used as a
torture chamber by those same soldiers
she had to survive inside the room for
weeks because they surrounded the area
so she had to drink 30 water off the
floor and eat the corpses that littered
the room in order to survive and crying
wolf was hiding from a group of soldiers
with her baby brother when he started to
cry so she covered his mouth on her to
keep him quiet but she ended up
suffocating him on accident her mind was
so damaged that while walking out of the
combat zone with her dead Brother In Her
Arms she saw the Spirit of a wolf that
would follow her she ended up reaching a
refugee camp and end up hearing other
babies crying similar to that of her
brother to which the wolf came by and
killed them all this wasn't the wolf
though as it was just a hallucination in
actuality it was her smothering them
it's some of the most horrific stuff
I've ever heard which is why it's so
bizarre that the game does this and then
also focuses on their bodies during the
fight had the game just stayed in line
with itself it would have been great as
any time the game focuses on their PTSD
it's amazing during the beauty phase of
the fight you can hear people scream and
cry as they and their loved ones are
being killed each member also starts
seeing some kind of hallucination and it
really sets the tone for how broken
these women are you feel extremely
uncomfortable when you're watching this
and you're supposed to but then the game
goes well at least they got good looking
bodies though it's only a complete
conflict of emotions but it's also
incredibly disrespectful as is basically
just played for Laughs it's like the
game is saying don't worry about their
tragic backstory just focus on how hot
they are and take some sexy pictures
while you're at it it's gross and
disrespectful especially when you learn
that Kojima not only wanted the unit to
be nude in game but couldn't do the
censorship laws but also wanted the
actors to be nude while performing the
motion capture which may remind you is
the fashion models themselves Kojima
clearly created the unit with one hand
on his dick and it sucks to have to bear
witness to it especially when other
backstory is relayed to you by drebin
after you kill them drebin for some
reason knows every nitty-gritty detail
about them and always tells you after
you defeat them sadly the gameplay ain't
that great either with the exception of
laughing octopus her fight is a hunter
versus The Haunted kind of setup where
she uses her octo camo to hide in UF to
find her and she's surprisingly pretty
hard to spot she goes up on the ceiling
hides in plain sight poses a dead corpse
and even tricks you into following
oticon's robot the fight is great and it
plays to her strengths as a soldier the
others though are quite boring raging
Raven just flies around and is somewhat
unique even if it is similar to the
other flying boss fights we've had from
years ago but crying wolf is literally
just Sniper Wolf with Fortune's railgun
it even takes place in the same Arena
you fought sniperwolf in and screaming
mantis fights just like mantis did and
even as you knocking out Merrill against
it you can defeat her it just feels
really uninspired which is a shame as
just like mgs4 the group is full of
great ideas but ideas that are terribly
executed
after his running with the BMB unit
snake will make his way down the street
where he ends up finding the pmc's main
Outpost and also happens to find liquid
among the crowd Marilyn the Rat Patrol
are also here too but before any of them
can make a move on liquid he activates
something which causes all the soldiers
to start acting strange earlier I said
the SOP system blocks out any mental and
physical pain so the soldiers can
continue to operate well think of it
like a wall once it's removed nothing
could stop it from going through so all
that pain they felt is coming back to
them all at once snake is also affected
by this but to a lesser degree as he's
already had experience many of these
soldiers haven't experienced any kind of
pain that comes from war thanks to sop
but snake has been fighting way before
this was implemented so he's more
resistant to its effects snake ends up
collapsing before he gets the chance to
shoot liquid who's also joined by Dr
Naomi hunter from the first game
thankfully snake is able to survive the
experiment thanks to Johnny of all
people as he has no Nano machines in his
body overall though act 1 is my favorite
in the game there isn't a dull moment
throughout its entire run time it
showcases the tragedy of the world post
mgs2 gives us a look at the new faction
unit and also gives us subtle hens as to
what we transpire in the coming chapters
these actually be making you ask
questions while also getting you
intrigued enough to pursue those answers
and act 1 does that exceptionally well
which brings us nearly over to act 2. We
Begin the second act one snake wakes up
and we see Sunny making the group some
eggs the group lives on a plane called
The Nomad seeing as they're still likely
wanted for their whole philanthropy
business which is a problem for sunny
since her whole life has been spent in
this plane she's not doing what
seven-year-old girls should be doing as
she's instead cooking dinner for the
boys and helping atticon on occasion
when he needs it sunny is basically a
child prodigy when it comes to computers
in programming and she's able to encrypt
some Civic vials with ease and get into
the databases of well-known governments
without being seen according to Sunny
Naomi is apparently located somewhere in
South America so they head out in search
of her once snake lands we see that Vamp
is back and working with the B and B
unit which also means he's working for
liquid as well vimp wasn't a great
character in mgs2 and while he's still
not amazing in mgs4 he at least has some
more screen times he was able to cement
his role as the villain a lot easier
once Vamp leaves snake gets a call from
Campbell and tells him that he's given
him the frequency of a psychiatrist that
he can keep his psych gauge in check the
slight gauge replaces the stamina gauge
of mgs3 but ends up working the same way
the lower the bar the worse your
accuracy you lose psych by being in
active combat in a high stress situation
stations mechanically it's nothing to
write home about but I did like its use
narratively as a chose how snake is
feeling a time since the psychage can be
lower during cutscenes for whatever
reason though the psychiatrist that will
be helping us is Campbell's wife
Rosemary the same one who dated Ryden
after mgs2 Ryden was naturally shaken up
and had trouble talking and opening up
to people this caused him to start
neglecting his relationship with
rosemary by not coming home some days in
the days in which he did come home he
was drunk riding her would eventually
end up going their separate ways she
would go on to marry Colonel Campbell
and Ryden took a job from a woman called
big mama she wanted the location of big
boss's corpse in an exchange she would
give him the location of Sunny who was
in area 51. that's how sunny ended up in
oticon's care as he gave her to them and
then left this is all well and good
except the marriage is a lie Rosemary
and Campbell are tricking everyone into
thinking that they're married because
Campbell being a former Commander to
Ryden feared that his wife and son's
life would be in danger thanks to the
Patriots so he remarried her in order to
keep her and her son's life hidden I
have one question though and it is an
actual one how does that protect them I
don't recall the game ever explaining
how Rosemary Marion Campbell protects
them I assume it's because Ryden was
hired to do work against the Patriots so
breaking off the relationship would mean
they can't use her against him like
before but that doesn't make sense
either since they're the Patriots they
know ryden's history with rosemary and I
highly doubt she'd be that hard to find
plus even if they thought this was a
brilliant plan why didn't they tell
Ryden about it Rosemary nor Campbell
ever told him that this was a lie in
fact Rosemary went even further and told
him she had a miscarriage so the whole
time he has no idea that his son is
actually alive the whole plan seems to
have been conducted by these two alone
since Merrill hates her father for
remarrying a woman that's close to her
age she also hates him for not telling
her that he was her father since he had
an affair that resulted in her birth so
the dude's already a complete scumbag
but this is just the icing on the cake
still though what is the point of this
whole plot none of it makes any sense
and it feels thrown in for the sake of
adding unnecessary drama it's supposed
to make you hate Rosemary and Campbell
which is why the twist isn't revealed
until the last few minutes as a sort of
subversion to make you realize how wrong
you were about them but it actually
makes me hate them more I can understand
why Rosemary would break things off of
the bride and had it ended there or
would have been fine as a sort of
mirroring to snake and Merrell's
relationship but everything after that
is just unnecessary and if anything made
it worse who tells their husband we're
getting a divorce and oh yeah I
miscarried by the way sorry and then
goes off and marries the Rex husband's
commanding officer to make matters worse
Rosemary is even less important than she
was in mgs2 at least in that game she
had a connection to Ryden so talking
with her would give us some insight on
their relationship but she's completely
useless here and here all of her
dialogue is about your psych level and
it only relates to certain game
mechanics like removing weight if you're
carrying too much in your inventory she
does have some interesting lines when
you talk to her after dying and
reloading a checkpoint but other than
that I never found any of her dialogue
to be interesting or helpful honestly
forgot she was a part of the game for a
while Rosemary is a good example of this
game trying to cram at as many of his
past characters as it can but there's
only so many spots they can take up so
more often than not they become like
Rosemary and are easily forgettable I
talk about riding in Rosemary segues us
right into the next part of the story as
soon after this we get a call from Ryden
himself almost as if that was
intentional Ryan's currently doing his
own thing right now but he's in the
general area and tells snake that Jack
is dead referencing that his past life
is gone it's very weird hearing that
after playing the game knowing that his
own wife and commanding officer are
tricking him just like the Patriots did
a big shell seems like our cyborg Ninja
really can catch a break snake can seem
to either as he's thrown into another
war between one of liquid's PMC groups
in the local militia right after snake
makes it through some of the following
areas Draven comes by and talks with
snake this is where he turns into the
lore keeper and tells snake that the BNB
unit is hunting him as they believe that
killing him will cleanse their minds of
the horrors they've endured in addition
to the massive bombshell of information
that states that the Patriots have
implemented some kind of speech
recognition forcing people to not utter
the word Patriot this is another strange
detail to me as I I don't recall this
ever being mentioned ever again another
name for the Patriots is the LA Lele low
which is the code word Eva was supposed
to say in mgs3 and is something that has
been mentioned in the previous games
before but it's never been given much
weight until now due to the Patriots
controlling the flow of information and
the Nano machines in people's bodies
thanks to sop they're able to stop you
from saying the word Patriots and
instead have them say low this may also
be why Merrell says this after snake
utters the word Patriot I think the idea
of the Patriots can join the people to
the point that they can't even say
certain words is really cool I'm just
kind of surprised that this wasn't given
more attention it's just brushed aside
as a random piece of information despite
how dangerous that is drebin also
explains why stake and oticon heard that
the Patriots died over 100 years ago
back in mgs2 that's because the Patriots
no longer exist at least not physically
major Zero from mgs3 was the original
founder of the Patriots but after some
time he fell ill and decided to pass on
his vision to something with less
emotion and AI he created the AIS that
make up the Patriots like GW from mgs2
the four AI are named GW TJ TR and Al
which are the initials of the four
presidents on Mount Rushmore with a
fifth AI called JD or John Doe who is
the leader of them breaking into the AIS
is almost impossible but liquid's hoping
to achieve this since he's trying to
hijack the system we don't know how he's
going to do this but he planned to
create some kind of Haven a sort of safe
place away from Patriot control his
little experiment in the Middle East was
a part of this plan and he's about to
enact the next experiment soon but first
we have to find Naomi she's located in
the back of this mansion and seems to be
alone on top of moving the word Patriot
from people's speeches it seems like
they removed buttons or something along
those lines given Naomi forgot to button
up this morning despite that she's able
to remember quite a bit about liquid's
plan she goes on to tell us that liquid
and her discovered that sop was not able
to control soldiers but also control
their emotions which is what we
discussed earlier Naomi Likens the idea
to what happened to gray fox back in
mgs1 but twice is worse but both Sheen
snake are confused though because snake
was affected by this despite not being
in the system so she wants to study him
and see what happened he then takes off
the Octo camo and man to see look Gruff
his physique is still rather impressive
for someone his age but it's still hard
to think that six years ago he looked
like this to clarify it's not just a
visual change either he's actually aging
faster than normal so he has the Pains
of someone in their 50s and 60s snake
even hits his back on occasion due to
his constant back pain it's quite a
scary thing to imagine living a full
human life in half the time and that's
exactly what he's going through age
really came at him fast and it puts
things into perspective now that he
realizes he doesn't have much time left
she further goes on to state that the
reason snake hasn't died to Fox diet was
because his DNA in liquids was too
different so it only targeted liquid and
not snake this is one of a couple
details that's changed constantly in the
series so as to fit the current
narrative at the time and it's
definitely something I'm not a fan of
ocelot hypothesized in mgs1 that snake
would die soon after Shadow Moses but he
ends up coming back in mgs2 so the game
had to change the story by adding that
Naomi set it to a random value so it
might kill him in a month a year or a
decade from now but now it's been
altered to be that it was never going to
kill him in the first place due to
having different DNA Metal Gear Solid 4
also does this with the the whole liquid
ocelot thing which is why I'm going to
talk about it later but it's just really
annoying to have these details set in
stone only for them to be changed in the
next game because the writers decided
their new idea was cooler this isn't the
last time this happens either not just
in this series but also this game so
sorry to disappoint you but we're not
done with this conversation yet moving
on though the final thing she mentions
that not only is there a new Fox die in
him which is that Fox die 2 he got from
drebin but also that the original Fox
die is mutating Fox die is supposed to
only kill people with a specific genetic
code which is why only specific people
died back at Shadow Moses we'll do the
snake rapidly aging the Fox die mutated
and is changing the code meaning it
could kill anyone or to put it bluntly
snake is about to become a walking bio
weapon in about three months the only
solution is to kill the host AKA snake
himself so not only is his age catching
up to him but now he's going to become a
bio weapon if he doesn't do something it
really lays on snake's mind as it
finally starts to hit him that he's
running out of time around the time
their talk comes to a close laughing
octopus comes by to attack snake we've
already talked about her at length so I
won't reiterate my earlier points but
when she's dealt with with snake will
chase after Naomi as she's taken by some
pmcs while snake was distracted he'll
eventually rescue Naomi from vamp's hand
before driving comes away to pick them
up as the geckos have arrived to stop
them once they leave we see the soldiers
activate strange as they start walking
like zombies this is liquid's second
experiment and it seems to have failed
as well as we know liquid's plan is to
try and take over the SOP system if we
remember his speech from mgs2 liquid
wanted to defeat the Patriots and he can
do that by hijacking sop for some reason
though he needs the genetic code a big
boss in order to access it but he
figured that since he was a clone he'd
be able to circumvent the issue which is
what that experiment in the Middle East
was he was hoping that he could take
control of the system but it just ended
up killing the soldiers so we decided
that snake's blood might be the key
since he's also a clone a big boss but
his blood caused the zombie-like
soldiers we see he was only able to
procure this Blood thanks to our meeting
with Naomi just a second ago just like
mgs1 her loyalties are questionable I'll
talk about it more towards the end but
I'll say now that she's working for
liquid of her own volition because the
Patriots are a threat to everyone she
knows that liquid shouldn't rule over
the city system but she also doesn't
want the Patriots to keep the rule
either so she's hoping to put a stop to
the Patriots and she can only do that by
helping liquid eventually the APC will
crash near a small village that's
surrounded by geckos until Ryden shows
up to deal with them his clearly gotten
some upgrades since we last saw him and
he's also a lot more confident with his
sword fighting abilities this is what I
meant by earlier when I said some of the
cutscenes are much better when they're
longer I have no issue watching riding
Kick-Ass for over 10 minutes hell I wish
it was longer one thing to note though
is that when Vamp arrives and stabs
right in his chest bleeds white during
his mission to capture big boss's corpse
he was captured himself and experimented
on by the Patriots it seems like he went
through the same process gray fox went
through when he was revived and just
like him Ryan was able to escape thanks
to Big Mama and her resistance the
problem is that Ryden has become
critically injured from this fight with
Vamp and he can't just get a simple
blood transfusion so we'll have to go
back to the doctor that originally
operated on him when he escaped
thankfully that doctor also happens to
be near where snake will go next and
that's big mama's headquarters liquid
plans to pay a visit to Big Mama and her
team because thanks to Ryden they have
the corpse a big boss and he needs his
DNA to get into the so op system so
snake is going to make sure that doesn't
happen sadly Ryder won't be able to join
us due to the wounds he suffered plus
he's going into autotoxemia if death
straining has taught me anything though
then a simple Shake should be able to
fix him but I guess they didn't think of
that this means that while Sonny and
Naomi go meet with a doctor that fix the
Bryden snake will then go find Big Mama
which is where that tailing Mission
comes in before they land though we get
to see the cast interact on The Nomad it
seems like Naomi has ulterior motives
given that she's carrying a USB on her
necklace she's attempting to create
another virus uncreatively named Fox
alive that'll destroy the AIS that
control the Patriots but she needs help
to finish it she was originally going to
get oticon to help but realized that
Sunny was the better option the two seem
to be getting close to each other but in
a very calculated and predicted move
Otakon fumbles
to be an anime otaku
oh yeah maybe don't start with that
seems like it didn't matter though as
oticon is able to show the audience that
metal gears on the only things that are
solid and has him alone time with Naomi
in one of the Choppers but oticon is
over two when it comes to women and the
third time is not the charm as Naomi is
absolutely going to portray them again
later once snake lands in Europe becomes
in contact with big mama who we discover
is Eva from mgs3 Eva tells us that she's
actually snake's mom the clone's a big
boss weren't grown in test tubes or
rather birthed naturally this is rather
strange given that there used to be
eight kids but six were aborted so as to
encourage the other two to grow faster
but that just doesn't make sense to me
it isn't uncommon to give birth to twins
but I felt like the whole thing about
eight fetuses makes more sense if they
were grown in test tubes by the way Eva
goes into a long Exposition about the
Patriots major zero and liquid she says
that liquid is fully taken over ocelot's
body and is now trying to take on zero
major zero as we know is the original
founder of the Patriots but alongside
him was Eva Big Boss ocelot sick and
paramedic who we all know from mgs3 zero
use big boss in his status to push the
power of the Patriots he would even lie
or exaggerate old stories to drum up
more Fame for the group Big Boss
disliked being the group's Uncle Sam
though so he left which created some
tensions between big boss and Zero's
ideals each one wanted to carry out the
will of the boss and change the world
for the better but each one had a
different interpretation zero saw a
World Without Borders to mean a world
under one border or complete unification
which is why he created the Patriots Big
Boss interpreted this as a place without
any borders he wanted to make a world
that would be a safe haven for soldiers
a place where they weren't discriminated
or used this isn't the full truth though
as Peace Walker and mgs5 evolve his
original idea but regardless the two had
a falling out and were at odds of one
another once big boss left the Patriots
realized that they needed another poster
boy which is what led to the terrible
children project and the creation of the
snake clones zero also realized that
Humanity would not be able to carry on
his idea of the will which is why he
made the AIS do it for him but what
ended up happening is that the AIS went
against his original idea which is why
the world is in ruin zero was struck
with an illness in the 80s we don't know
what the causes as mgs5 will clear that
up but the effect is that the AIS were
instructed carry on his will but
deviated from his original plan as they
lacked empathy and also saw the war
economy as more beneficial this means
that everything the Patriots have done
in mgs2 and 4 has come from the AIS she
then ends the conversation saying that
she and ocelot have went up against zero
and Allied themselves a big boss and in
doing so she used gray fox to kill
paramedic and had ocelot kill the DARPA
Chief Donald Anderson whom we know is
sickened this is quite a lot of
information and is naturally conveyed to
us through a 10-minute slideshow because
of course it is that being said the info
is helpful and gives us a bit more
context as to what happened after mgs3
right after this one of the BNB unit
arrives alongside a few dozen PMC mercs
in an attempt to steal big boss's corpse
the plan is to get him out of the
country and to do this we're going to
help them Escape his body though is
looking less than ideal and definitely
brings up the question about whether or
not this is even morally right he
doesn't seem to be conscious but this is
still not a pleasant way to live even if
he cancels all that he's alive to begin
with right on cue though Otakon calls
snake and tells him that Naomi dipped
and is likely trying to meet up with
liquid snake will then ride with Eva and
the rest of the resistance in hopes of
escaping the pmcs this section is
exactly like the end of mgs3 and is
definitely an homage to that last level
this is also where the game starts to
dip into full-on action which I didn't
mind as it was a fun level it also shows
how impressive the game looks mgs4 came
out in 2008 and is easily one of the
best looking games of that year this is
the same year that produce games like
GTA 4 Fallout 3 Dead Space and dmc4 yet
mgs4 manages to lead the competition in
graphical Fidelity with the only games
that are close competition to it at
least out of the ones that I'm aware of
anyway being Gears of War 2 and Mirror's
Edge the team was really pushing the
game to its limits and you can feel it
in the gameplay as a lot of scenes drop
frames quite often which is a bit
disappointing but this thing's
practically put in the PS3 on its knees
as is so it's to be expected towards the
end of the chase scene the two fall off
the bike and Eva is injured in the same
spot as before it's a bit of a weird nod
to the previous game but it is an
attempt at showing how much Eva cares
for and misses big boss as she starts to
see a lot of him in Solid Snake sadly we
won't be getting an escort Mission like
the last game as we have to handle one
of the BNB members raging Raven while
that happens and I know this is a very
odd time to bring this up but the
history of Eva's voice acting is
fascinating to me her original VA and
mgs3 was a Suzette Minette who you won't
recognize because she doesn't exist that
name is a fake used by the actress
likely to hide her identity to this day
it seems like no one actually knows who
voiced her but it's interesting how the
voice actress is using a fake name and
then playing a character whose whole job
was to spy on people and use a fake
identity in mgs4 though she's voiced by
Lee Meriwether who is not only one of
the original Catwoman from the 1960s but
also won Miss America in 1955. and I
find the fact that Eva is now voiced by
a woman such as her to be very fitting
for her character minor Tangerine aside
defeating raging Raven allows the two to
press forward but they end up running
into liquid snake soon after here
without a moment's notice defeat snake
and then burns the boat that houses big
boss's corpse this in the following
scene are rather confusing because once
liquid gets out of the water he's
surrounded by the military he doesn't
seem phased though as he lets all of
them get close and then turns off all
their technology liquid has officially
succeeded in assuming control of the
sons of the Patriot system now called
The Guns of the Patriots the game's
finale will be feel the real truth but
basically that is not big boss's corpse
it's solid a snake from mgs2 I have no
idea how he's not dead given what
happened at the end of mgs2 but he's
apparently being kept Alive by Nano
machines and seems like liquid figure
this out as he burned the corpse now
that he has complete control of the SOP
liquid's able to turn off all the guns
and vehicles the US military used and
then let his frog unit attack the
defenseless Army Marilyn or crew are
here too but fortunately they live the
attack Eva won't be so lucky though she
slowly succumbs to her wounds it almost
seems like snake and everyone else is
about to die too but lore keeper now
turned deus ex machina is back and helps
snake out once more I know that drebin
has a Tracker of sorts on him so it
makes sense why he keeps showing up but
I just don't understand why he can't
just be a gun Merchant the writers are
trying to throw in a dozen characters
and then give them all an important role
in the story but most of them suffer
from it and while drubbin has a
wonderful personality I just can't get
over the fact that his whole existence
is based on being the thing that moves
the story or the game forward whether
that's rescuing snake when he's almost
dead or revealing any kind of info he
needs right when he needs it
thanks to drebin though the team is able
to reconvene and discuss the next steps
Otakon was able to seek the metal gear
MK2 robot he uses onto the ship and
discovers that liquid is trying to
destroy JD despite being destroyed five
years ago liquid is able to reconstruct
GW the AI is now under his control but
he needs to take away control from JD
the leader AI in order to remove the
Patriots control from their own system
the SOP system is under liquid's control
but JD still has supreme authority over
it meaning he'll need to destroy JD the
problem is that JD is a satellite in
space so the only way to destroy it is
to use a nuke but the system has ID
locked most nukes except one specific
creation made and abandoned before the
system was created liquid plans to use
the railgun and Metal Gear racks to
launch a nuka JD which means we're going
back to Shadow Moses mgs4 is a game for
the fans in more ways than one seeing as
this game was made because of fan death
threats but mainly that the reference is
an homages to the previous games are for
the fans that love the series for the
past characters to amalgamations of past
units to the flashbacks to the full-on
Recreations of old areas MGs S4 is a
love letter to the fans and for the most
part it works well most of it doesn't
seem tacked on for the sake of nostalgia
and Shadow Moses is a decent example
it's a very important time it's naked
out of Khan's lives it's the first time
they met and could be considered a
tragic moment in their lives given what
went on there the game also pays homage
to that game by having you go through
the first area again within the old
PlayStation 1 style after the small
encounter though were dropped into
Shadow Moses for real this time and the
layout is pretty much identical all the
classical areas are there like the
helipad the rumor we fight gray fox the
other room where we have to launch that
guy to missile across an electric floor
and dozens of others the game will also
bring mention to those moments back then
and I couldn't help but smile whenever I
heard them amazing
yep it's been nine years hold its snake
time to change the disc I know I know
it's a pain but you need to swap disc
one for disc two you see the disc
labeled two nah
no huh
Oh wait we're on Playstation 3. it's a
Blu-ray disc do a layered too no need to
swap damn it autocon get a grip yeah
what an age we live in huh snake wonder
what they'll think of next
the trip through Shadow Moses is nice
and it was cool to revisit the place
again especially given its modern
graphical touch-up but I do wish there
was something more here gameplay wise at
least most of it is just walking through
old locations and outside of crying
Wolf's boss fight it's all mechanical
enemies despite these moments being
nostalgic for the player though I'd
argue they're quite dramatic for snake a
lot of things happened here for snake to
B4 is back here after all these years
it's no wonder his mind is starting to
conjure up those memories both good and
bad he also has to find metal gear
wrecks again which was a core reason why
the events of that game even happened
sadly he won't be able to just walk in
and out as Vamp is here to stop him Vamp
is a fairly simple fight but his
difficulty comes with figuring out how
to kill him to do this you need to use
the syringe Naomi gave you earlier and
use it on Vamp when he gets back up this
suppresses the Nano machines in his body
and allows him to be quote unquote
mortal again we won't be able to deliver
the killing blow though as Ryden has
come here to challenge him we'll have to
defend him from an army of suicide
geckos while he deals with Vamp I do
like the change in perspective during
this fight although it does suck that
you can't watch most of it since you're
too focused on the geckos once he's
defeated though Naomi comes about a
stabbing with with another syringe which
kills van for good shortly after she
stabs herself with the same syringe
Naomi has had cancer for quite a while
but the Nano machines kept it at Bay
using the syringe stopped and Nano
machines meaning she'll succumb to the
cancer I have no idea how it killed her
this quickly but her reasons for doing
so are fairly sound Naomi's loyalties
have always been hard to pinpoint
throughout most of the series and that's
true even now Naomi was responsible for
a lot of dangerous experiments like Fox
die and was also the same reason Vamp is
able to survive his wounds she can't
erase her past which is why she's been
trying to atone for her mistakes it's
sad to see her go but the likely
reaction to this is confusion rather
than sadness given how much he
flip-flops between sides plot twists and
double crosses are a staple of the
series but Naomi's never felt satisfying
to me her change of attitude in mgs1
made sense and she originally wanted to
kill snake but then felt bad about it
later after realizing he's not the
monster she made him out to be in Metal
Gear Solid 4 though we don't even know
what she's doing as it face value she
joined liquid joined us joined liquid
killed Vamp then killed herself we don't
even know what she's trying to do is
that fox Alive's stuff I talked about
earlier doesn't come up until the act
after this there's also no build up or
chance to catch on to what she's doing
because she never even explains what
she's doing in the first place which
ultimately makes the scene more
confusing than anything I also really
tried to take this scene seriously but
seeing Naomi hug the robot and having
Otakon cry on the camera was a little
funny to be fair though it does suck
that another woman he loved died
furthering the idea that oticon's life
sucks and isn't getting any better
once she dies though snake oticon and
Ryden will then use Rex to escape before
being ambushed by liquid who's inside
Metal Gear Ray this is the first time
we've ever been able to Pilot a metal
gear and also fight another wall inside
one and for what it's worth it's pretty
cool given that mgs4 was designed to be
an action game I'm glad they decided to
add this as it perfectly fits with the
tone of the gameplay once Rey is
defeated the two brothers both come out
injured with liquid racing to his
warship outer Haven not to be confused
with his PMC company outer Heaven snake
tries to catch up to him but it's too
late liquid then takes the opportunity
to kill snake but thankfully he's a
[__] as instead of using the hundreds
of guns on his ship he spins it around
and Rams it into the pier Ryden is able
to rescue him though just in time by
holding the shed back I find this
absolutely hilarious as two minutes ago
he was stuck underneath a pile of rubble
but is somehow able to stop a ship as
large as Arsenal gear and also do it
with one hand the ship is too strong for
him though obviously and Ryden is
crushed thankfully he's not dead as him
dying here would be the worst way for
him to go but given that lots of people
didn't like rotten to begin with having
the script magically give him the
strength of Superman only for him to
fail 10 seconds later might have
actually made people happy to add to the
convenience of the scene Mei Ling shows
up with a ship and prevents liquid from
hitting snake again Mei Ling did appear
in the mission briefing earlier so it's
not like this is a huge surprise but
once again it's another one of those
moments where the game needs to make
every single plot relevant character
someone from a previous game even if it
makes zero sense to include them this
then ends up bringing us to the
beginning of act 4. the next ACT is the
final one but before we continue let's
discuss the previous act so far a
complaint I had in the previous games
that it felt like specific objectives
were created to add padding to the game
thankfully mgs4 doesn't have many if any
of those moments since the game felt
quite streamlined at what it was trying
to do the only difference is that some
of them were too long the tailing
mission is a great Mission as it makes
sense in the context of the story and
doesn't feel unnecessary but it's also
25 minutes long on top of this it also
felt like the ax had been on a downward
spiral since the first one each of the
acts are passable on their own and do
contribute something to the story at
hand but a lot of the smaller moments
are what bring down its quality from the
formulaic being and B fights to drop in
doing his best to get as much screen
time as possible to the overuse of
exposition since the team still can't
find a proper way to relay the
information to the overabundance of old
cast members appearing because this is
the Smash Bros ultimate or Metal Gear
Solid it all drags down the story
heavily there is no need to add in every
character in an effort to wrap up their
story mailing could have easily just
banned a character in one game and
there's no reason to bring her back
Campbell is an okay addition but his own
Quirk was being the mission leader and
most of that is taken away by the other
characters who are either drebin oticon
or Naomi so he just serves as a callback
for those fans who remember him
Rosemary's entire existence is pointless
and her fake marriage at Roy is also a
waste of time Merrill is probably the
only character I'm okay with given her
relationship to snake and because she's
shown to be this naive soldier who
wanted to be recognized as one by her
own hero only to be a slave to A system
that gives her the strength to fight Eva
is one I'm torn on given that her role
could have been replaced with another
new character but instead becomes
another callback but she does provide us
with Vital Information on the Patriots
and their creation but once again that
could have just been given to someone
else like liquid since he has no issue
talking about his goals in past the
snake still her exploiting the events of
mgs3 along with what occurred between
big boss and zero are nice to know but
why does it have to be a 10 minute
slideshow it's one of the laziest ways
the game has expunged its plot and it's
shocking how many times the game does
this these Mission briefings in between
each Act are also pretty much a
guaranteed 15 minute episode that just
repeats the same dialogue constantly The
Briefing before Shadow Moses shows
Otakon and snake listening to the
recording he made while liquid's boat
they both hear the name Metal Gear Rex
and yet no one says anything snake will
then mention hearing Rex's name a bit
later to which oticon finally perks up
and says that must mean they're going to
Shadow Moses then Campbell comes by and
says Metal Gear wrecks again and then it
finally Clicks in their heads that
they're going to use Rex to destroy JD
even though liquid literally says that
already in the recording
will launch of stealth nuclear warhead
at JD I thought you couldn't control the
nuke with GW
we can't
that's where Rex comes in it's not only
making these intelligent characters dumb
for the sake of the plot but it also
adds time to a game that's at least a
few hours too long the plot twists so
far have also lacked the charm that the
other games have had we aren't at the
end of the game yet so some of the real
truth hasn't been revealed yet but the
twist I have discussed which was big
boss's corpse actually being solidus was
impossible to guess it's exactly the
thing the other games didn't do and
that's have plot twists that are
impossible to see coming each of them
had some kind of hint that makes itself
known on a second playthrough but this
one isn't possible it's also another
example of the game just doing things
because the plot would be cooler this
way like changing how Fox die works and
bringing back solid is because it sounds
like a cool idea all of it brings you
out of the experience and it sucks given
how amazing the start of this game was
it's such a weird feeling that these
acts are connected to the first one as
they feel like two totally different
games at this point the imagery of the
Soldier's cowring in fear the showcasing
of how much of a hold sop and War has on
the world and how much these battles of
affected snake were fantastic but then
the game delves into this number places
some of its human enemies with robotic
balls and goes into long speeches that
could have easily been cut in half and I
just do not know how we managed to get
here and act 5 isn't going to solve our
problems in fact at times it even
perpetuates it it first starts with a
presentation from Mei Ling about what
they're going to do once they get close
to liquid's warship the only reason she
was able to present this information was
because Naomi gave the info to Sunny all
the internal blueprints of outer Haven
and the solution to stopping GW which is
located inside the ship was given to
them by her whose side was she on anyway
finally someone's asking the real
questions here too bad it took 12 hours
to finally do it just about everyone is
on mailing ship and is ready to work
together to stop liquid even drebin is
here which for once actually makes sense
as he states that thanks to liquid
taking sop business has been slow
selling a stock to snake and the crew
will not only keep him in business but
also prevent liquid from controlling
people which would also hurt his
business like I said anytime the game
stays in line with itself is great
drebin helping snake because he wants to
keep his business going is the exact
kind of attitude you would expect from a
gun launder who gets rich off War the
group then sets out to defeat liquid and
his ship snake and Merrell then land on
the ship with Johnny falling into the
ocean snake will run into screaming
mantis and just like I said earlier it's
very similar to psychomantis but just
less interesting psycho Mendes does at
least come back at the end to vibrate
your controller again and also tries to
read your mind but can't since we're not
using memory cards anymore it's just
mantis being mantis again and while a
bit out of nowhere given that this is
another instance of him committing to
his bit I was cool with it plus his boss
music returns for the fight which is one
of my favorites in the series
behind mantis is a hallway that leads
the GW the issue is that it's covered in
microwaves so snake could burn up and
die if he's not careful he figured that
he should be the one to do this though
seeing as he's already close to dying
anyway Merrill then vows to protect him
while he goes in which is a nice full
circle moment for her since snake was
always the one protecting her joining
her is Johnny and the two have quite the
weird conversation Johnny ends up
confessing his love to her while they're
killing hundreds of frog members and
then asks her to marry him she says no
which I was totally on board for until I
realized she only did that so that she
could be the one to ask for marriage I
have no idea what Meryl sees in him
given he's a complete nuisance to be
around plus he literally tried to grab
maling's ass not even an hour ago but
hey if they're happy so be it the two of
them at least show how in sync they are
even without the system to Aid them as
they're able to take down most of the
Frog unit with ease snake gets to the
door where the microwaves are but is
stopped by more frog units until Ryden
comes by who literally has no arms at
this point and vows to also defend snake
while he goes inside the guy can also
just conjure up lightning now which
seems to have come from his time on
Shadow Moses to be fair volgan could
also do it too I just always thought
that was something he was born with
Ryden just got this power like an hour
ago similar to Meredith's a nice
opportunity for riding to pay back snake
for all the times he helped him plus the
fight scene is just as great the scene
then changes perspectives and attempts
to show how close this is coming Merrill
Johnny and Ryden are close to being
overrun and mailing in the crew are
barely hanging on it's a great scene as
everyone's really giving it their all
for this final battle as it'll determine
the fate of the world snake then barely
manages to make it through and now has
to defend oticon while he uploads the
virus Naomi made into GW
Otakon finishes the hack just in time
for everyone to survive what the heck is
not only a racing GW but the other AIS
as well the plan was to originally stop
GW since that would prevent liquid from
shooting down JD destroying JD is that
hurdle I talked about earlier as it
would have removed the Patriots
completely and cause total chaos given
how much influence they had what
President Johnson feared is about to
come true until a message from Naomi
appears saying that everything is going
to be all right thanks to Sunny they
were able to remove the AIS without
compromised the infrastructure of the
system it's basically The Best of Both
Worlds the Patriot rule is over and the
world doesn't devolve into utter chaos
it's an interesting twist even though
it's never mentioned how that's even
possible so the game just kind of hopes
you'll accept it plus it's another
example of Naomi switching teams more
than ocelot does but nonetheless it's
still a decent scene Naomi was always on
the good side of this war but she needed
to switch sides in order for it to work
which is why she always kept going back
to liquid as I said earlier she always
agreed with liquid's plan to stop the
Patriots but didn't agree with him
taking it over afterward so she had to
agree to liquid's plan while also trying
to stop him from reaching the next step
after which he succeeded in doing so
thanks to the help of Sunny snake after
enduring all this pain seems to die but
ends up waking on top of outer Haven
snake and liquid of Ed B for a while so
now it's time to settle it with a proper
1v1 even though the game stumbles and
Falls constantly throughout its run time
this is the best moment in the game it's
not only a great boss fight mechanically
but it's a perfect example of nostalgia
Done Right the flight has four phases
and each one changes the names and HUD
to match that of the previous games the
music also plays the most iconic song
from each game including mgs4 it's the
fight to end all fights and having it be
a fist fight between the two clones a
big boss as the game slowly transitions
itself throughout the series really
makes the entire Journey worth it yay
[Music]
no
foreign
[Music]
fight snake is able to beat the liquid
out of him literally as liquid loses
control of ocelot and the man comes back
to deliver one last hand gesture to send
off the series
before that happens though look what
goes on to say that he's won he stated
that his true objective was a world of
chaos and removing the Patriots was the
way to do that at the end of mgs-1
liquid said he wanted to make a world
where soldiers like him were always
wanted he wanted the world to delve into
chaos thanks to the Patriots losing
control of the us but as we know Sunny
was able to make it so that didn't
happen liquid was somehow outsmarted by
a seven-year-old which kind of leaves
the game off at a lukewarm note but the
fight was glorious too bad we're not
even close to done as despite this being
the last thing the player will do we
still have another 70 minutes to go it's
not only the longest cutscene in the
game and series but also ever as it won
a Guinness World Record for it too bad
it is terrible and ruins the game
immensely I dislike just about
everything that happens in the last 70
minutes with the exception of a couple
scenes it first starts with Merrell
getting married to Johnny they are
really moving things along Roy has come
by to congratulate his daughter but as
we know Meryl is still upset with him
but she tells him that this is the time
to make up for it may I remind you one
of the reasons she's angry at him is for
remarrying another woman even though it
was all complete lie at the reception is
out of Khan and drebin who then reveals
that his employers were the Patriots and
was instructed by them to help snake out
on his mission he also says that Merrill
and her rap Patrol were also under the
same orders but it's unclear if they
knew that from the start the Patriots
wanted to help snake since liquid was
going to destroy them and they realized
that that was their only option but it
kind of takes away all the hard work the
team went through since once again it's
all the will of the Patriots the scene
after this is where Ryden learns that
Rosemary was lying and that she not only
still loved him but her miscarriage
never happened I'm happy for the guy but
I still think a lot of this was
unnecessary plus thanks to Rosemary and
Campbell being completely irrelevant to
the story we never get a real answer as
to why getting married would have
protected the family the final scene is
snake sitting at the cemetery with a gun
in his hand the Fox die is still
mutating and he's going to become a bio
weapon soon so he decides that now is
the time to end it he pulls the trigger
and the game ends except it doesn't
because this is a metal gear solid game
and we need a last minute twist and that
comes up during the credits as it shows
big boss's name despite him not being
present in this game and he wasn't until
now right after this big boss shows up
up in greet snake let me repeat that
again Big Boss the man who's been dead
for years at this point is back to add
to the absurdity major zero is here too
I for the life of me cannot figure out
why this is even here the game plays
this off as one of the greatest twists
of all time but these two have been a
complete non-factor not just for this
game but the series as a whole zero is
the worst example of this as all he's
done is be the mission advisor for snake
in mgs3 and that's it yes he's the
founder of the Patriots but we only know
that because of Eva's long Exposition in
a post-credit timeline from mgs3 plus
anything regarding the Patriots has been
done without Zero's will because he
passed it off to the AIS before MGS one
and two even happened so he's Irrelevant
in the one thing that makes him a
relevant character big boss is some
amount of screen time but once again he
goes from a soldier who felt betrayed to
a mercenary to just showing up here
chronologically he hasn't been seen
since Metal Gear 2 and not only does
that mean he survived a second time as
he was supposed to die in both Metal
Gear games but his role has been
completely unseen most of what we know
about him regarding his time in between
mgs3 and now has been through the same
means as zero a post-credit timeline and
Exposition by Eva even now their roles
are pointless as zero is in a vegetative
stage is about to die and few minutes
and big boss is only here to give a
20-minute speech that pretty much
removes half the story we just went
through this last 20 minutes is where we
learned that the body liquid burn was
solidus and not big boss we also learned
that big boss was also being kept alive
like solidus but somewhere else he
couldn't escape the things to the
Patriots holding his body Hostage to get
big boss to wake up the Patriot system
needed to be destroyed which is what
liquid was trying to accomplish as
liquid was never actually liquid ocelot
and Eva had two goals kill zero and
rescue Big Boss ocelot then decides to
trick the AI system by becoming liquid
just like with Fox die this is another
twist the game changes for the sake of
the current story mgs2's explanation was
that liquid took his body over by
Supernatural means which is why liquid
came out at the most inopportune of
times mgs4 says that ocelot took Nano
machines and enhanced hypnotherapy to
become a doppelganger this being an mgs4
was always ocelot but he made everyone
believe he was Liquid by adopting his
mannerisms and speech patterns this
clearly doesn't make sense when
comparing its mgs2 as if that was the
case then why would liquid just appear
when ocelot lost control of his body
this means that it's another rewrite
the plot twist is also incredibly
contrived for no reason as this means
that even knew liquid was ocelot acting
as liquid which also meant that she knew
this body was solidus and not big boss
from what I can tell it seems like
ocelot went so far in his liquid Persona
that he fully believed he was liquid
which is why we knocked the delusion out
of him at the fight but still what a
completely unnecessary twist and that's
not even the end of it as big boss was
told by Naomi to tell snake that Fox die
2 isn't going to make him a bio weapon
anymore apparently Fox die 2 was eating
away at Fox die 1. so it was actually
removing the mutation instead of
spreading it furthermore Big Boss also
tells us that Fox die 2 the one the
Patriots had Dragon put in a snake was
tasked with killing Big Boss ocelot and
Evo which is how all of them die Eva and
ocelot didn't succumb to their wounds
they died to Fox die too in big boss is
about to die soon as well I can see why
zero would try to Target them as he's
trying to kill big boss and his allies
while they try to kill him but not only
does that lessen the impact of their
deaths but it also removes the plot of
snake being a bio weapon the only time
it's mentioned in the story is when it's
introduced with name me and right now
it's the worst story beat in the game as
it goes nowhere it's taken out of the
story hours after it's introduced as a
way to scare the player into thinking
snake would die when it was never going
to happen in the first place plus
there's also the fact that big boss of
all people knows this information which
is something I still don't understand he
claims to have been comatose like
solidus and was only awoken after the
system went down meaning this moment
right here is when big boss was sprung
back to life which is after Naomi and
Eva had died yet Naomi had the foresight
to record a message for big boss that
explains everything once again it's all
relayed to us through a 20-minute speech
despite the fact that Fox die 2 should
be kicking in right now and killing him
I cannot understand this but this scene
literally just keeps going on we meet
with big boss then we meet with zero
zero dies and then big boss seems to be
joining him he falls to his knees while
trying to make it to the boss's grave he
leans up against the tombstone and talks
for like eight minutes about Fox die and
how the original one won't kill snake
and how the new one's killing him he
then finally makes it to the boss's
grave before collapsing again he gets up
again salutes collapses again talks for
another two minutes and then finally
dies
holy [__] this whole scene is baffling
from start to finish that being said
there is one great thing about this
scene and that there's this genuine
feeling of closure Big Boss even tells
snake that it's over and that he can
stop now for the first time in years
he's truly free in that piece solid
snake has gone on such a long journey
and you can see it in his face as his
smooth and handsome face in mgs1 and is
still arguably handsome but more old and
burn face in mgs4 are practically night
and day he said quite the difficult and
traumatic life in being hugged and told
by who I would argue is technically his
father that he can rest now got me in
the fields while the conversations that
occur throughout this cutscene are
questionable at best the overall feeling
of the ending was wonderful as it feels
like a proper ending for Solid Snake
something that he and likely the player
have wanted for a long time snake also
vows to make the most of his freedom and
spend the rest of his time left with
aracan and sunny which is adorable Big
Boss himself also comes full circle and
realized how wrong he was he realized
that the boss only wanted peace and for
people to respect the will of others
while also believing in their own values
and beliefs she wanted a nation for your
borders and Solid Snake did that by
defeating the Patriots thus removing
their Reign Over the people and bringing
us back to square one as I've said at
length mgs4 is a game of great ideas
ideas that are good enough for me to
understand why people love this game so
much while playing this series I've been
updating you all through the community
Tab and a Common Thread I've seen is an
appreciation for this game while it's
definitely not my favorite in the series
I'm not naive enough to not see how
people could like this game as there
really is nothing like it metal gear
solid as a whole is a unique series but
mgs4 is an outlier in a series full of
them you can't really find something
like this anywhere and even with all of
its faults its message is still an
important and well conveyed one as I've
mentioned before I don't consider mgs4
to be a bad game I just personally think
the other Metal Gear games are better
than it there is a lot of great things
about it but there's also a lot of
things that stop me from ranking it as
high as the others and a large
contributor to that was how it did big
boss which is why I'm glad I'm not the
only one to have recognized this mgs4
seems to have lit something under Kojima
as the next two games he would create
peacewalker and mgs5 all center around
big boss and attempt to bridge the
much-needed gap between his Antics and
mgs3 his mercenary role of Metal Gear 1
and 2 and his full circle realization
here and mgs4
Peace Walker would be the first game to
explain what happened to Big Boss and in
release order minus portable Ops it's
the next game in the series after mgs3
it starts 10 years after that game in
1974 and we can see that big boss has
started his own Merck outfit called msf
or soldiers Without Borders thanks to
mgs4 we know that big boss would start a
new Merc outfit after leaving the
Patriots and this is the start of that
group msf was created to give soldiers a
home a place that accepts them for who
they are but this isn't some kind of
retirement home or living quarters
they're still going to be fighting but
they won't be affiliated with a specific
government especially one that throws it
soldiers onto the bus
it sounds like big boss is going against
the boss's will by creating this team
and he kind of is but he's got a strict
moral code and won't fight for anyone
just because they have large sums of
money to throw at them it's also not
like he's forgotten the boss in fact I'd
say it's quite the opposite he can't
stop thinking about her he thinks about
his past mission every night and even
has a similar scar pattern on his chest
to remind him of her it's clearly taken
a toll on him and this Mur group is
luckily his way of carrying on her will
while also ignoring the past among the
soldiers is another leader of msf
kazuhira Miller we know him though as
Master Miller from mgs1 he led a team of
his own in portable Ops but when Big
Boss defeated him he was offered a spot
on the team to which Miller Accepted
next to him is a teacher named Galvez in
one of his students Paws it's learned
very quickly though that Professor
Galvez is not a professor but actually a
member of the KGB according to him the
CIA are encroaching on Costa Rica
luckily in an attempt to take it over as
this game still takes place within the
cold war after learning that he's KGB
Galvez further explains that controlling
Central America is vital to winning the
cold war in the kgb1 Costa Rica so they
could set up a base near the North
American Border her they also tried to
Rally some of the local militia mainly
the Sandinista Liberation Front to get
them to help by pitting them against the
sozuma regime in the 70s there was a
proxy war between the samosas and the
sandinistas which was later called the
Nicaraguan Revolution peacewalker takes
this exact incident but also adds msf
into the mix and has them Ally with the
sandinistas big bosses reluctant to
fight for them though as this causes him
worth his time but Galvez provides more
info more specifically a cassette tape
that plays an audio recording of Paws
and her friend according to the audio
the two were looking around for Birds
when they were captured by some Soldiers
the audio also plays the sound of a
horse and a woman nearby that specific
woman being the boss somehow the boss is
alive in Costa Rica and no one knows how
they boss that immediately decides to
take the mission he claims that it's For
Paws Sake but it's definitely because of
the boss his reasoning does end up
changing though as once he makes it to
the nearby military base he discovers
that the CIA is bringing in nukes to
Costa Rica in a tube of the game
officially starts already we have
another great start for the series the
threat of nuclear war is not anything
original in the Metal Gear Solid series
but that's not a bad thing as it's
consistent with its themes Metal Gear
Solid is an anti-war game and nuclear
war is the deadliest version of War so
hearing that it was another nuclear
threat didn't bother me as it's par for
the course plus Metal Gear Solid always
likes to mix things up by adding in
different ways of enacting that war and
peacewalker might actually have one of
my favorite iterations of it I'll admit
I didn't have any high expectations for
peacewalker mainly because the game was
originally released on the PSP so I
figured the quality wouldn't be as high
as the previous titles that being said
it's not as bad as I thought it would be
but I also wouldn't rank it amongst the
greats of the series either I have the
same opinion about this game as I do God
of Wars PSP titles its biggest strength
is its novelty a portable metal gear
solid game that you could take on the go
portable Ops was also a PSP game but I
think peacewalker is much better in this
department as such though the gameplay
is going to be at the Forefront and the
story quality is always going to be a
downgrade when compared to the previous
games but while it's not one of my
favorite story-wise the gameplay is
actually incredible and I could have
definitely seen myself singing lots of
hours into it had mgs5 not taking this
system and made it better in every way
as thanks for helping Galvez gives us an
offshore plant as a home base called
mother base this plays into the gameplay
of peacewalker as you build up your base
by snatching up prisoners and enemies
and recruiting them into your team each
Soldier has specific grades in each stat
meaning some characters will be suited
for different departments characters
like Huey Emerick and Doctor Strange
Love Are Scientists so their r d skill
is higher than any other so putting them
anywhere with the r d unit would be a
waste of resources each unit also has
its own benefits the combat unit can
take their own missions called outer Ops
or even be controlled by you in extra
Ops and the r d unit can research new
weapons and equipment for you to use
there is a couple other units as well
but I think you get the gist the
gameplay was genuinely really fun and
there's enough Ops to take part in that
it could take you a while to 100 the
game assuming you want to go down that
route peacewalker though is just one of
those games I'd play for the gameplay
and not the story doing these kinds of
videos can be difficult because I can
like a game for the gameplay but also
have to scrutinize it for the story and
thus make it look bad clearly there is
more to a game than the story and most
people play and judge game games based
on both that's why I take a bit of time
to discuss each game's gameplay since
it's quite integral to the overall
experience so while I wasn't a huge fan
of most of peacewalker's story at least
when compared to the others in the
series I don't consider it a bad game
not even close as the gameplay kept me
hooked for a long time I think its
biggest strength is that it's the first
length that bridges mgs3 in the rest of
the series and when it focuses on those
elements it's a really good game
everything else though is somewhat
disappointing like some of its
characters big boss will eventually come
across the sandinistas it will recruit
their leader Amanda and her little
brother Chico Amanda and Chico are quite
forgettable and I didn't really care
about them during the story Chico being
a Child Soldier was definitely something
that perked in my ears especially when
Big Boss recruited him but outside of
that I didn't really care for him Amanda
was the same way but even less so since
she's just the stereotypical militia
leader that mixes in Spanish with her
speech the game doesn't really give you
much time to connect with these two as
they only occasionally appear in
cutscenes and then sometimes in briefing
files and even then most of her dialogue
is about the mission itself and not
anything remotely interesting the latter
though is Main only on the fault of the
missions themselves is their objectives
and structure are puzzling towards the
middle of the game big boss has to enter
a Mining facility take out the guards
and defeat a boss named the Cocoon to
which he then sneaks inside the real
facility and gets captured this is four
separate missions as the game splits up
each objective entering the Mining
facility requires you to walk around and
kill four guards and then move to the
next area that's the whole mission many
of the side missions are like this too
where you go to one area and do a thing
and then you're out in 10 seconds I can
sort of excuse the extra Ops as their
side content plus many of those one area
missions are supposed to be easy on
purpose since the later side Ops are
much more difficult but I feel like
adding more to the main missions would
have made more sense I think the reason
why they did this is because there's no
checkpoints you have to restart the
whole mission when you die personally I
didn't really consider the game to be
that hard quite the opposite actually
but I feel like the solution would have
been to I don't know add checkpoints
maybe like it's not a foreign concept
that can easily work with the hardware
of the PSP and by not adding this they
inadvertently end up disrupting the
story as the game always stops for each
boss fights at the next mission can only
be about the boss fight so as to not
force players to prep for both the fight
and the guys before it there's also this
time where big boss has to get inside
another facility using a key card but
the Game Stops to start a random boss
fight with a helicopter then stops you
again because the ID card doesn't work
but then stops you a third time once you
find the ID card as guarding the
entrance the facility is another boss
and only after defeating the boss can we
then finally enter the facility these
stops are when the mission ends and
forces you to go back to the main menu
so you can either prep for the next one
or reorganize the base it just feels
like a lot of these missions could have
been grouped together as most aren't
really that difficult either especially
since you can do them with other players
although I couldn't find anyone myself
those missions take roughly 5 to 10
minutes each and grouping them together
could have lessen the issue as currently
you're just getting blue balled over and
over again
getting back to the story Chico ends up
getting captured by some cie mercs once
we rescue him he tells us about this
giant robot he saw called the Basilisk
he only noticed the thing because he was
out scouting enemy camps Chico is a
soldier but everyone treats him like a
child and forbids him from fighting but
he sees himself as an adult which is
hilarious given that he says I'm not a
child anymore I'm 12 as if that's not
still considered a child but I can
understand why Chico would want to help
out as this is his home and he doesn't
want to sit idly by while it's destroyed
especially since his dad used to be the
commander of the sandinistas before he
died but children should not be fighting
in Wars which is why I found it bizarre
that big boss actually encouraged him to
fight and even told Amanda to stop
treating him like his brother and more
like a soldier not exactly the route I
would have taken but it's the start of
big boss's descent once he rescues Chico
Big Boss ends up finding a tunnel filled
with cargo trucks which he assumes used
to hold the nukes they were bringing in
right after he discovers this he
overhears a conversation between Huey
Emrick and CIA director hot cold man I
am not even going to bother to get into
that name because their conversation is
more important here we apparently worked
on a robot called peacewalker which is
that basilisk that Chico was talking
about he made this as a way to provide
deterrent for the U.S Coleman wants to
perfect this to turn by showing the
world its strength deterrence is defined
as the act of discouraging an action or
event through instilling doubt or fear
of the consequences in regards the Peace
Walker and by extension the Cold War
nukes would be the deterrent since both
the Soviet Union and the us know that if
they launch a nuke at each other they'll
get hit right back peacewalker is
supposed to be a perfect deterrent by
guaranteeing retaliation
if a human had the hypothetical nuke all
button they might chicken out as they
might consider how many people would die
as a result of the retaliation
peacewalker only attacks after someone
else launches a nuke and would do so no
matter what it basically takes the human
element out of the equation so for the
Soviet Union it's not a question of
whether or not the U.S would retaliate
because peacewalker would do it no
matter what thus preventing them from
attacking as they know that they'd be
wiped out as a result it's a strong idea
but it all hinges on the fact that the
US government would hesitate to fire
which will bite him in the ass later
Coleman wants to test this and show the
world that they can launch nukes by
actually firing one first Huey like all
emericks though doesn't agree with their
Creations being used this way and
condemns Coleman for doing this big boss
then arrives which prompts Coleman to
release the pupa an unmanned vehicle
used for war among the pupa is its other
butterfly-esque Brethren like the
Chrysalis and the Cocoon peacewalker
doesn't really fit with this theme but
it does have a butterfly on its head
symbolizing that it's the most advanced
and complete version of the unmanned
weapons each one is representative of
the butterfly's life cycle but it may be
that butterflies represent peace in some
cultures in my defense I've only heard
it be used as a reference to
reincarnation though so let me know if
that's accurate but assuming that's true
that would make sense given the premise
and the name of the game peace is quite
an important theme of peacewalker some
of which is a bit heavy-handed at times
like how Paz and kazuhira are both names
that mean peace in their respective
countries but even still the theme is a
good one and the game does a great job
at revolving its story around the theme
of Peace regardless we'll meet with
peacewalker and his other brother and
later as for now we have to fight the
pupa this was another aspect of the game
I found quite disappointing as the
bosses are lacking the only actual
antagonist at the moment is Coleman
given that he wants to launch a nuke
which is fine I just can't apply that
same feeling to a bunch of vehicles
their only purpose in this game is to
break up the action and force the player
to fight a large boss from time to time
they don't say or do anything and
they're introduced right when they
arrive so there isn't any build up
peacewalker is easily the best of the
group given it's named after the game
but the others aren't that interesting
from both a story or gameplay
perspective
once Pupa is defeated though big boss
talks to Huey who tells him that he was
the creator of the robot if you remember
from mjs3 I said that Graham was going
to take the metal gear Blueprints and
give it to Huey these AI weapons
including peacewalker are what he
created using those documents but Huey
takes it one step further by not only
saying that he's the original Creator
but he also copies what grainen said
back in mgs3 so I went back to where it
all started
that
legs walking power
you need something else
look at these
nice shoes
no
legs legs that allow it to go anywhere
obviously he's trying to pass off this
creation as one of his own but we of
course know better than to believe that
he further States though that peace
Walker is actually incomplete as it's
missing an AI brain the current AI only
follows the commands that humans tell it
to do this AI for peacewalker needs to
be able to make decisions on its own
without human input but the CIA hasn't
finished it yet as it's currently being
worked on at a facility nearby however
once big boss gets there he realizes
that the AI that is in control of Peace
Walker was created after the boss
herself which is why she was heard over
the cassette tape now it's not actually
the boss it's just an AI who thinks like
her because it was programmed using all
her past missions as data the leader of
the project is a woman named Dr
Strangelove who's the boss as the AI
since she thought of hers the most
rational individual this then leads to
the two going back and forth about the
mission in mgs3 one thing that's been
plaguing big boss's mind has been her
decision to defect he knows why she
defected and what her mission was but he
doesn't understand why she would accept
such a mission he doesn't understand why
the boss would be okay with dying this
feeling of his is really the turning
point for big boss which is why he's so
villainous in later entries as he thinks
the boss betrayed him by putting down
her gun and forfeiting her life this is
why he tries to talk to the AI Core
because he wants to hear from the boss
herself obviously it's not actually her
but it's the closest thing he's got he
doesn't get the chance to speak to her
though is once he enters he collapses
inside the boss's AI Core and awakes in
a field of flowers while the AI pot is
taken away he attempts to stop them
before being attacked by Chrysalis our
next boss fight Miller will hop on the
comms after the fight and tell Big Boss
where that a iPod was going which is
north of his location stopping us from
entering the new facility is another AI
weapon called cocoon I know it sounds
like I'm skipping ahead again but this
is truly how the narrative is
progressing at this point we discussed
these fights earlier so you already got
to see how we go from Chrysalis to
cocoon is all it requires is killing a
few guards the main draw for this game
was the side missions as in a vacuum the
main missions alone aren't that well
paced but when you break it up by
playing the side content it feels more
fulfilling the issue is that there is no
story in these side missions so there's
no point in discussing them either way
once cocoon is defeated big boss is
captured by the CIA mercs Miller was
initially worried about Big Boss since
he didn't think he'd be able to kill the
AI Big Boss tells him that he's fine but
he also has a similar scar pattern on
his chest so he's clearly lying a lot of
this attitude changes once he actually
meets the AI and he asks it about
operation Snake Eater but it claims to
have never gone on such a mission this
changes his view of the AI since he no
longer sees it as the boss just a cheap
imitation of her so he has no qualms of
killing it he won't get the chance to do
so as hot Coleman arrives just in time
to stop him he's then captured him
because this is a metal gear game we
have to dedicate some time in the script
to the main character getting tortured
in a prison cell Coleman also decides
right now is the perfect time to test
his deterrent by falsifying nuclear data
and claiming that it's coming from other
base so peacewalker can intervene and
nuke our base this is because he
considers msf to be its own kind of
deterrent and msf and peacewalker can
both exist as deterrence so he's going
to get rid of it to make matters worse
he also has pause so we need to get her
back and stop him big boss really has
his work cut out for him here but he's
able to overcome peacewalker with a
minimal issue sadly the damage that was
done didn't hurt it more like pissed it
off so it decides to run off and head
for the Border Big Boss wasn't quick
enough to stop it though and now both
peacewalker and paws are gone but both
Miller and big boss are still trying to
wrap their heads around why pause was
taken as she's just a kid the two assume
that it was a metaphorical way of saying
that we killed Galvez to get to her so
don't bother trying to fight or you risk
losing her too but it ends up actually
being quite the opposite we discovered
that Galvez and Goldman were working
together but it's another series of
double crosses when Big Boss entered the
facility he noticed that Soviet troops
were here which is strange given this is
an American base that's because Galvez
and hot Coleman were working together
but galvez's KGB so he was only helping
to a certain point he needed to get
close to Coleman so he could steal the
nuclear codes from him he would then
point the Nuka Cuba and since Cuba is an
ally of the Soviet Union it would look
like an American attack on Soviet soil
thus making all of Latin America enemies
of the US
Galvez whose real name is actually
Vladimir zidornov then takes paz's hand
and forces him to shoot Goldman Paz
thankfully lives up to her name and
refuses forcing zidornoff to do it
instead he didn't actually kill him
though since he needs to enter the code
so he's going to make him do it by force
given that he was KGB it really gave off
a villain kind of vibe it was
practically foretold that he was going
to betray us but the way he did it was
not something I had expected zodornov
also wanted to use this moment to kill
big boss as he wanted him to be a martyr
like Che Guevara while the name Che
Guevara may not ring any bells his face
surely does given that he's quite the
prominent figure I also think that's why
Big Boss looks like this in peace Walker
as is meant to mirror the image of him
now I'm not too familiar with his past
life so please do correct me if I'm
wrong but for one I can gather he was a
Marxist revolutionary who played a very
integral role in the Cuban Revolution
Jay also seems to be someone very deep
in the gray area when it comes to his
morals as he had built factories and
schools for the people of Cuba but he
was also ruthless and would execute
those that disagreed with him or tried
to leave his unit from what I can tell
he's in ends justify the means kind of
person and assuming I'm correct and
didn't just completely butcher this
section I can see why Big Boss resembles
him big boss is ruthless and is seen as
both a villain and hero just like Che
depending on who you are and what your
political views are you might agree with
Jay's views and see him as a hero but
you may also see him as a brutal killer
and the same is true for Big Boss
majority of this section represents
chapter 3 and both this and the upcoming
chapter 4 were easily the highlights of
the game the first two weren't bad but
not a whole lot was going on on the plot
but now that people have started showing
their hands things are really starting
to kick off it's a standard Metal Gear
Solid plot a strong start a decent two
subpar middle which then leads to a
climax and is full of backstabs double
crosses and angle reveals and the climax
keeps on going as once the sandinistas
come by to assist Big Boss they capture
Coleman and zidornov before Coleman
inputs the vague data and points it at
America Coleman is trying to test his
theory by seeing if the US government
would not retaliate if they knew that
nukes would come this ends up backfiring
as the government actually does want to
retaliate which is a problem as the data
is false so they would end up nuking the
Soviets for no reason and since he can't
convince them to stop the big boss has
no choice but to put down peacewalker
himself like I said the climax really
kicks things into high gear and honestly
got me excited which is not something
that happened much in this story this is
the closest the game actually comes to a
full-scale nuclear war in the whole
series and it's honestly impressive the
other games were close too but it was
prevented once we defeated the person
controlling the metal gear or the metal
gear itself in those instances nuclear
war would have started soon after our
deaths if we failed but in this case we
would die alongside the nuclear war if
we were too late it's one of the few
times in this series where I felt
exactly how the characters did in the
other games it was most of the
characters who were worried about the
impending doom but in peacewalker I felt
the intensity of this moment and it
hooked me in a way that the game hadn't
done before as stated earlier
peacewalker is really not trying to
reshape the mold here it's got the same
structure as the other Metal Gear games
even down to the twists and double
crosses but you know how the saying goes
if it ain't broke don't fix it and while
it's clear that the formula works I'm
glad the game didn't just outright copy
its own methods and actually attempted
to be something different
Big Boss then defeats peacewalker but
the data is still live so peacewalker
has no choice but to attack in
self-defense but by some miracle the
boss AI is able to gain some amount of
control again and used its last few
minutes to drown itself in the ocean
permanently putting an end to
peacewalker for good I still don't
really get the science behind how that's
possible but thematically it's one of
the strongest scenes in the series as
the boss Ai and AI that thinks like the
boss decided to sacrifice itself for
peace again which mirrors her mission in
mgs3 and also proves her innocence in a
way by showing us and the world that
peace can only be achieved not by
fighting but by putting down our guns
and accepting each other this officially
stops peacewalker and removes the false
data proving that it was all fake and
once again the boss has sacrificed
herself to prevent nuclear war due to
those aforementioned technical glitches
I had with mgs4 ended up playing this
game first as it was an X1 in release
order and I think that ended up being
the better decision because playing
these two back-to-back leads to this
moment and it's one of the best in the
series The Boss sacrificed everything
for peace even after being betrayed and
used by her own government numerous
times they could win the Cold War she
still cared about her country in the
world because she still hoped that peace
would eventually come this is why the
boss died she died for peace she died to
stop nuclear war during Snake Eater and
her AI version of being using only
rational thought also determined that
Dying For Peace was the most logical
outcome peacewalker might have one of
the best endings out of all the games
and I was very surprised how fast the
quality of the script had changed by the
end it would be such a shame though if
this wasn't the actual ending it was
just a ruse that guys to play one more
chapter which may have some of the worst
content I've ever played in my entire
life
oh
chapter 5 sucks the missions are
terrible and removes all the Thematic
weight that chapter 4 had it's a prime
example of doing too much there was no
need to go above and beyond too many
cooks spoil the broth and too many
chapters were in an otherwise great
story initially I thought chapter 5 was
one of those typical chapters in RPGs
where it's designed to be a post-game
chapter so you can finish up the extra
content you missed but that changed
after I did a few extra missions as
Miller calls big boss and tells him that
zidornoff has escaped he at the time was
put in a jail cell in mother base but he
somehow managed to get out without
anyone noticing so now we have to go
find him and toss him back in his cell
while not a terrible Mission it was
quite strange that it would say for the
final chapter and is considered part of
the main story and then it happened
again
and again
zidornov escapes six times during this
chapter and each one plays out the same
way you do a few extra Ops then he
escapes you get him back you do a few
more missions he escapes again this
repeats six times and I can't for the
life of me figure out how anyone thought
this was a good idea now this is all
leading somewhere surprisingly not even
that is remotely interesting after
spending at least two to three hours
doing this it runoff will escape for a
seventh and final time as we learned
that Paws was the one sneaking him out
pause whose real name is Pacifica is
actually an agent working for the
Patriots while we are distracted she
takes the opportunity to steal our Metal
Gear I probably should have mentioned
this earlier but when we recruited Huey
he gave us the ability to create our own
Metal Gear I find its inclusion
hilarious since both Miller and big boss
agree to only use it as a deterrent
similar to peacewalker but you can
literally send this thing on Extra Ops
and clean the floor with enemy mercs
regardless the metal gear was taken by
pause and now we have to defeat her
before she uses it to launch a nuke at
the United States I also really like
that the game keeps your color scheme as
it's funny to imagine that someone would
random other base just to find a giant
Pink Mech guarding its borders but in
all seriousness to explain this betrayal
after the two split up zero would
eventually come back and try to gain big
boss's support which is what led to
where we are now aziro wants to use
Metal Gear Zeke for his own and also
have msf act as a deterrent for the
Patriots in case they're attacked Big
Boss disagrees as he wants something to
do with the Patriots so pause is no
choice but to kill him Miller also knew
about Paws in zidorno's real identities
in fact he was the one that brought them
to Big Boss he didn't agree with their
methods but he used a doorknoffs that he
could grow msf as Miller is a true
businessman at heart it's an interesting
plot point but why is it even happening
why is there have to be a Twist that's
thrown at the last minute chapter 4 is
the end of Peace Walker whereas chapter
5 is the moment that Bridges both Peace
Walker and mgs5 since that game takes
place only a few months after this one
so it was a link the chapter does its
job well I just have to ask though why
is this the connection why does adornoff
always Escape why is Paws taking the
metal gear the connection that Bridges
the games why can't she just be a little
girl whose home was ravaged by War why
does she have to be a triple agent still
even if they really really love this
idea why is it in this game instead of
putting it at the end of peacewalker why
not put it at the beginning of mgs5
isn't that the entire purpose behind
Ground Zero is to be a prologue to mgs5
why not put this chapter here why ruin
the final moments of what was otherwise
a great ending just for this moment
chapter 5 genuinely almost ruined the
game for me I was really happy with how
peacewalker ended only to be forced to
play hide and seek six times followed by
a Twist that shouldn't have been put in
this game to begin with peacewalker
didn't exactly hook me immediately but
it not only kept me interested through
its gameplay but even surprised me at
times of how much care of input into the
script the intensity of the last mission
and the final send-off of the boss AI is
one of the greatest moments in this
series and coming from a PSP title that
many probably have written off by now
that's extremely impressive well it's
definitely not my favorite game in the
series it's definitely not as bad as I
originally thought it was going to be
but that final chapter killed all the
weight and momentum this game had just
so we could connect itself to the next
project which makes this even worse as
we wouldn't see that project for another
five years so peacewalker had this
really weird ending for years and no one
knew where it was going after some time
though it did release but not before
another Studio was given the IP which
would result in it going in a very very
different direction
Metal Gear Rising is the first game in
this video not made by Kojima it's not
the first in the series as there was
other titles that came before it like
metal gear acid and mobile but it's the
first one we've discussed originally
Rising was supposed to be set between
two and four to provide more context as
how riding got his cybernetic body but
after realizing the game wouldn't work
out Kojima approached Platinum Games who
accepted but asked to change the setting
in order to have less restrictions they
also removed the stealth approach that
game is going to have and is set opted
for full-on action and I think out of
all the decisions they could have made
that was the best one Platinum Games is
most well known for the creation of the
Bayonetta series as well as near
automata but I've always been a fan of
their sleeper head to Vanquish Metal
Gear Rising really wears its influences
on its sleeve as it plays like all those
games put together just from looking at
it though we have to ask is Metal Gear
Rising a good metal gear game no not
even close its gameplay is the complete
opposite of what metal gear is all about
but asking Platinum Games to make a game
that doesn't encourage killing is kind
of like asking Arcane to not make an
immersive Sim and well we know how that
turned out despite that though I'll be
honest with you this game is fantastic
its combat is fluid addicting and very
rewarding but the story tends to Fall by
the wayside a bit it's not that it's bad
there's just not a whole lot here to
discuss and that's for two reasons just
like Peace Walker rising's first
objective was the gameplay it's a thing
you'll be doing for 90 of the experience
so they really made sure to nail that
feeling of cutting through various
pieces of Flesh on top of this the game
is really short I beat the game at about
6 hours and that's even with the dozens
of times I reset thanks to this game
really beating my ass constantly so
already we're fighting an uphill battle
despite they sounded like a problem
though I don't consider it one I'm just
stating it's designs you can understand
why this section might be so short
Rising doesn't delve into hours of
exposition and philosophical Concepts or
reveal a crazy twist at the last minute
now that's not to say none of it exists
as it still has some of that metal gear
charm but don't go into Rising expecting
something like the previous games you'll
be disappointed its gameplay offered a
relaxing change of pace and should also
provide the same relaxing feeling to you
the viewer seeing as we're at least
three hours into this now and you could
probably probably use something a bit
more simple to digest before we go back
to the core of the series it first
starts with our boy Ryden in 2018 four
years after mgs4 he's currently a part
of a security group called Maverick
who's being hired to guard the prime
minister of Africa now while the
canonicity of this game is questionable
since it's outside of kojima's main Saga
I was still worried how Rising was going
to handle this new story since it's
after mgs4 that game ended things rather
nicely plot twists and Exposition
notwithstanding it felt like the end
regardless of how it got there but
Rising is saying actually no this is the
end of the series now this has the
chance to completely remove everything
mgs4 had done but Platinum game is able
to make it work with one unique change
rising's only connection to the original
series is the occasional reference to
sop and the Patriots and two characters
Ryden and sunny everything else is not
mentioned Solid Snake Big Boss not even
liquids Insurrection in mgs4 was
mentioned it's completely divorced from
the original story while also sticking
to its current timeline the game also
Stars Ryden which is the change that
brings us all together his role in mgs4
was quite minor and while he did have
some important moments in the script it
was mainly about Solid Snake in his last
mission if mgs4 was the ending of Solid
Snake Rising is the ending of Ryden
which is a fantastic decision as it
allows both snake and Ryden to get their
proper endings without interfering with
each others and that alone is worthy of
praise well guarding the Convoy of
armored trucks they come across the
cyborg named jet stream Sam who
immediately puts down the Gunner with
ease one thing you'll notice about this
game is how gory it is if someone has a
sword in a cutscene there's an 80 chance
someone's going to lose a head leg or
their whole body everything adds to the
charm of the game I do wish there was an
option to turn off the gore though since
trying to get to this game without
getting age restricted is going to be a
challenge in and of itself alongside
Jetstream Sam is sundowner the leader of
our new faction The Winds of Destruction
accompanying Sam and Sundowner is the
other members Mistral and Monsoon we'll
discuss them as we meet them but I liked
all the bosses in this game not just for
the mechanical challenge but because
they all felt like mirrors in a ryden's
mind some of them are just straight up
Killers but others felt that killing
should come with a cause the comment
Droid most of them share though is that
each one teaches Ryan something they
don't literally tell him not a thing but
his interactions with them cause him to
question something about himself and
whether or not he's holding back what he
truly feels like while Rising may not
include subtlety or deep complex
questions within its Story the way it
evolves and changes Ryden is its
strongest aspect returning to the
current Day events Rider will come in
contact with sundower who takes the
Prime Minister he ends up chasing him
throughout the streets before running
into Metal Gear Ray if you needed more
convincing that stealth is out the
window not only are we 1V wanting a
metal gear but Ryder makes it his
absolute goal to kill it in the most
stylish way possible
foreign
[Music]
eventually he'll catch up to Sundowner
who's also joined by Sam he's too late
though as the prime minister is killed
son daughter leaves shortly after and
lets Sam get some one-on-one time with
Ryden Sam is one of those traditional
video game bosses you're supposed to
lose to though he completely wipes the
floor with Ryan and not only cuts his
eye but also removes one of his arms
during this fight Sam will come in a
ride in sword fighting abilities and say
that while he's not bad for being
self-taught he's still going to lose
because he's denying his blade his true
purpose Ryden believes that he's only
killing those that deserve it and that
his sword is being used for justice
believe it say something like this in
the beginning which was quote sometimes
by taking a life others can be preserved
Ryden sees his killing as necessary as
these people made their choice they
chose to be mercs and guards they know
what they signed up for it's a very
naive and simple-minded look at the
situation which will return later
somehow despite losing lots of blood
Ryden is able to be rescued by Boris the
leader of Maverick the game will then
skip ahead a bit as Ryan has another job
with a new body to boot apparently Ryden
is here in abkazia to kill the
terrorists here as they've taken over
the area and killed the president and
his cabinet the group is led by an Andre
zayaf who's also working with Desperado
I didn't mention this earlier but
Desperado is the name of the company The
Winds of Destruction belonged to they
various military force including some
small cyborg infantries but the only
named members of the ones we discussed
earlier Sam is also a part of Desperado
but not the Winds of Destruction this is
due to his backstory which is a bit
complicated at least for now on the
topic of these cyborg soldiers our new
support crew which includes Boris Kevin
Courtney explained that these soldiers
are just like the SOP soldiers but with
a different name we don't see it
ourselves but there's a good chance that
there's a system like sop in place to
monitor these soldiers vitals thanks to
the fall of the Patriots the world while
somewhat safe still had to replace what
it lost the pmc's brought of a job for
the most part so they had to increase
their Edge by creating cybernetics it's
a pretty nice detail and also gives us a
bit more insight into the world post
mgs4
on the way to the group's headquarters
Robin will run into a cybernetic dog
called blade wolf this cyborg is an AI
as such it has some amount of sentience
to it besides Ryden Rising will also
come with two short campaigns that
feature Sam and blade wolf from its
short run time we can see that Mistral
was training it to be combat ready but
the AI seem to have questions about
freedom and choice being an AI under the
control of Desperado he didn't have much
choice in his well choices he was forced
to do as he was told and this could be
heard in his dialogue as bladewolf says
that he has to Kill Rotten or will be
shot down due to going against orders at
some point blade wolf was given orders
to defend Mistral but she allotted to go
where it wanted it was the first time it
was given Freedom so it took the
opportunity while it could blood wolf
would almost end up escaping if not for
missed or getting the device back which
forces him to return shortly after he
was brought back was when Ryden arrived
to fight him from our time with him we
can tell that the AI values freedom and
the ability to think for oneself
thankfully it will get its wish though
as we learn in the next mission that
Maverick fixed it up said it could help
Ryden I like blade Wolf's inclusion in
the story as it's another mirroring of
Ryden as both attempt to find the value
in being being able to fight for
themselves after a few more combat
encounters Ryden will finally meet
Mistral she starts the conversation by
calling him Jack the Ripper a reference
to his nickname he was given when he was
a Child Soldier this is of course a
further reference to show how similar
both he and Mistral are at least when it
comes to their background Mistral was
born in Algeria during the time of Civil
War at one point during said war her
parents were killed but instead of lying
down and crying about it she found and
butchered her parents Killers this made
her realize that this was her true
purpose in life but over time she became
bored with killing because she didn't
have a reason for it there was nothing
driving her to kill people that was
until someone came along and gave her a
reason someone named Senator Armstrong
at the moment he's not been named yet
but as the game goes on he starts to
become more involved with the script so
we'll Circle back to him later before
they fight Mr will ask him what his
ideals are and what he fights for he
says that he fights to protect the weak
once again reinforcing his earlier
comment about using his sword as a tool
of Justice with that discussion though
we've come to our first boss fight and I
must say it's pretty great technically
Metal Gear Ray and blade wolfer boss
fights but Mr felt like the first proper
one to me honestly I don't have a single
issue with any of these fights some are
more annoying than others but each one
felt fair and forced me to meet the game
on its own terms I do have a soft spot
for Mr although since you can use each
boss's weapon when they die and hers is
my personal favorite this thing is
really handy for when you're in a pinch
overall though she wasn't too difficult
but looking back at the footage I
realized how much I sucked at this point
in the game I didn't realize you could
lock onto bosses until Sam's fight so
all of them were pretty much done
through free cam which wasn't exactly
helpful and it took me longer than I
want to admit to realize what this blue
screen was for it's supposed to be for
the manual blade mode feature so you can
cut down enemies as you see fit but I
didn't know that at the time so it kind
of just looked like this for a good
portion of the game there's also the
fact that I couldn't land Perrys which
would be a bit problematic for Monsoon
but I have some positives to say about
that issue later one interesting detail
about these bosses though is the music
not only are the theme songs great to
listen to but the lyrics are related to
the bosses in some way one of the lyrics
in mistral's theme is I finally found
what I was looking for a place where I
can be without remorse this connects to
her earlier discussion about trying to
find a reason to fight fight it's a nice
touch as it's not often that I have to
look into the lyrics of a song to
analyze a character I wouldn't have even
known this though if the song wasn't so
damn good A lot of the music is great
it's action-packed and very intense just
like the fights
this is now
[Music]
to top off the fight each boss is also
killed using that blade mode from
earlier allowing you to absolutely
eviscerate them any way you see fit
which is rather therapeutic defeating
Mistral sees riding getting a call from
her which is weird given she's in a
million pieces at this point but okay on
the call is dolzaif who seems to have
fallen in love with her even though it
seems one-sided to end the mission
dolzaive decides to blow himself up with
the hope of taking down the plant with
him it seems seeing as his mission
wasn't really about that Ryden just
leaves the area and goes back to base
the next missions he's riding going to
Mexico to investigate a few rumors
regarding Desperado and human
trafficking Ryden needs to disguise the
blend in which is hilarious for two
reasons as it's not only a full-on
poncho in sombrero but he also wears it
in the car and then tosses it once he
enters the sewer so he only needed it
for like two minutes it's just one of
the many examples of rising continuing
to uphold the personality and charm of
the Metal Gear series ride and blade
wolf will then investigate the sewers
before coming across a kid named George
he was apparently taken and experimented
at home which Alba confirms the rumors
about human trafficking to make matters
worse not only did Ryden stumble upon a
room filled with cyborg brain casings
but he also found a video of Senator
Armstrong and sundower talking to the
chief scientist of the lab the details
of their talk are quite disturbing
basically Desperado wanted more soldiers
so they hired local gangs and mafias to
traffic kids and send them to the
facility they would then undergo brain
surgery with the brain being kept in
these cases while the rest of their
organs and limbs are being sold on the
black market while inside the cases they
would go through VR Missions similar to
the ones we could play throughout the
series and if they succeeded or
impressed the higher ups they'd be given
a body as a reward Sundowner Likens the
idea to what solidus did to the kids in
Liberia years ago which we know involved
Ryden except without the VR element
writer now has a personal stake in this
Mission given that these kids are being
subjected to what he went through as a
kid and refused to have another kid go
through the same thing he ends up
getting the chance to prevent some of
this but ends up doing something
surprising Brighton finds a Cell full of
kids which gets flooded with gas the
chief scientist also comes in with
George being held hostage and forces him
to choose the few were the many George
says that it's okay and his life is
impression anymore and is willing to
give it up if he can take the scientist
with him I originally thought that this
meant Ryden would choose the other kids
seeing as he just met George 30 minutes
ago so it's not like he has a personal
attachment to him but not only does he
walk towards George while the other kids
die he technically kills him along with
the scientist writing channels his inner
josuke and just cuts right through and
to get to the guy behind him thankfully
George lives is apparently they were
able to repair his body using Nano
machines and cybernetics but that's not
at all what I expected him to do for
someone who's trying to save the kids
from their current fate he's really
doing a bad job at it this continues
over to the next mission as Ryan ends up
traveling to Denver alone to take down
World Marshall according to Boris
Senator Armstrong is allied with a
company called World Martial and seeing
his Armstrong was just at the facility
he assumes that Desperado and martial
have ties to one another so ride in
without warning just heads to their
company headquarters to deal with them
he's going insane at this point and he
doesn't seem to be worried about the
fact that he's killing cops now at least
until Sam arrives
my sword is a means to an end to protect
those you would prey on really
let me ask you
all those cyborgs you've killed up to
now maybe they weren't kids but they
were people you ever think about them
when you're chopping them into hamburger
they're adults they made their choice
right on the dotted line of The BMC
contract usually they're not strangers
to war in fact many times they already
lost a limo tool
many times they were out of work and
starving on the street
so yes they sign up for surgery to fight
God must wear how else would you provide
for your family when your country is
embroiled in Civil War pain receptors
shut down pumped full of fear inhibiting
Nano machines and sent right into the
blender your blender
but they made their choice right
Sandlin follows up by telling Ryden to
listen to the voices that are suppressed
by the Nano machines they're able to
suppress the emotions of the individual
but Sam wants rotten to hear what the
cops really think
we'll let me die let's do this
[Music]
is all I have left
this is one of the many turning points
in the story that forces Ryan to look at
himself and see what he's become thanks
to Sam he's realized that his cause may
not be as black and white as he thought
and that he only looked at it that way
soon enough to question what he was
doing this causes him to go a bit insane
and reveal his Jack the Ripper Persona
even though it looks like a Devil
Trigger transformation it's more
metaphorical as Ryden is a cyborg ninja
who holds back whereas Jack the Ripper
doesn't he tried to live an honest life
after mgs4 but couldn't as he's always
been a part of War on top of enjoying
the thrill that comes from killing this
change in Ryden is different and could
even be considered inconsistent with how
he acted in mgs4 but I like the change
as it's accurate but subtle Ryden is and
always has been a soldier this changes
in him just killing for the sake of it
because if it was he would have just
left after defeating Monsoon and started
fighting anyone who looked at him wrong
he still has a cause that he wants to
fight for he's just accepting that Jack
the Ripper is a part of him whereas
before just like with mgs2 he tried to
suppress his old life and try to be
normal the difference is in the wording
it's not controlling him it's just a
part of him and he's able to utilize
that to fight for what he leaves in as
for Monsoon he's kind of like
psychomantis in regards to his ideals as
he has a very nihilistic view of the
world and believes that humans are made
to fight he also has a very survival of
the fittest view on life as well which
is the idea that the strong will Prey
Upon the weak whereas Mistral Force
riding to think about his ideals Monsoon
forced Ryden to embrace the real him
Monsoon Embraces his memes as he calls
it and sees people as a representation
of their memes for example as he puts it
expose someone to anger long enough and
they'll learn to hate this is an
absolutely insane thing to mention this
far in but the word meme is not what you
think it is I never mentioned this but
meme is the sort of one-worded theme of
mgs2 I just didn't use that word
specifically so as to not confuse you
basically everything we talked about in
mgs2 could be applied here all that talk
about passing down your culture ideas
memories and beliefs is short and due
passing down your memes he also sees
Free Will as a joke since your ideas or
Your Meme shape you into who you are and
seeing as something else is shaping how
you look at things he doesn't consider
that Free Will as such he Embraces what
he is or what his memes have shaped him
into being a killer once he's defeated
cab checks on Ryden to make sure he's
all right and this conversation confirms
that Ryden is still fighting for a good
cause he's come to terms with his
personality and realizes that while not
much can be done for him he can still
save the kids and prevent them from
being just like him he will then Ascend
the skyscraper and at the top awaits
Sundowner unlike the other two he
doesn't Force rodden to look at himself
he just wants to fight which makes sense
regarding sundowner's backstory as
shocking as this sounds given how much
effort we went through to stop it some
people are actually upset the war
economy is gone and Sundowner is one of
them he loves fighting and he loves
killing he's as simple-minded as they
come which is why the fight is less
about ideals and Concepts and more about
hitting each other as hard as possible
this was the first fight that I felt
well and truly stuck on it took me
probably 30 minutes to finally kill him
and even when I did defeat image Reign
my ration Supply completely this was
mostly due in part to his annoying ass
Shield that explodes if you don't hit
the targets properly I tried to brute
force it but since the fight doesn't
give you rations and I only had two I
need to actually Focus up for once but
even then I barely got by by the skin of
my teeth this ended up being a blessing
in disguise because of what happens next
as right after his defeat sundana talks
about something happening in three hours
riding in the team deduced that the
president of the United States is
currently in Pakistan right now is about
to be killed the problem is that not
even the fastest jet in the world could
get to Pakistan in that time what they
need is an rlv or reusable launch
vehicle and one just so happens to be
located at a facility called Solas it's
mostly used for space flight but
assuming everything goes well they could
keep it in the atmosphere and make it
with just enough time to spare to get
there though Ryden has to leave Denver
which is still overrun by police trying
to attack him once he leaves he comes
across the bike that he takes to the
facility before being stopped by Sam
blade wolf is also here who apparently
used to work with Sam during his time
with Desperado he wanted to see why Sam
was here but he couldn't figure out why
Sam is reluctant to tell us but his
campaign fills in some of the details
before Desperado Sam used to fight for
Revenge this resulted in a few drug
cartels losing all their members in
business Sam enjoyed the feeling of
justice so he kept data for a while
until recently when he invaded roll
Marshall's headquarters with the goal of
killing Senator Armstrong while he did
damage him quite a bit the senator
proved to be too strong for The
Swordsman who decided to join him
realizing that Justice could not be
undone by doing things his way after
being recruited he slowly started losing
his old sense of justice until Ryden
came along his mindset and ideal started
to conflict with his own which is what
led to this battle he had gone back and
forth between what was the right
decision to make here and decided that
this duel would be the answer if he wins
he'll continue to help Armstrong and
live his life as he is now if he dies
though and Ryden wins then bloodwolf
will take his sword give it to Ryden and
then it's up to him to decide what to do
with it it's sort of a nod to what
Mistral said earlier which is whether or
not Ryden is willing to fight and die
for his ideals this then leads to our
fight with Sam and by God is he tough I
was only able to find one ration so I
only had two shots at this fight before
I was dead this is what that blessing is
though because it forced me to play
properly and I finally learned how to
Parry consistently it still took a few
tries even after I got everything down
but it was still a great fight
nonetheless one thing I love about this
fight was how even it felt usually these
counter fights have you getting smoked
in the beginning only to smoke them
right back when once you meet him at the
end game this was different at least for
me though as Sam kept his power level
while I grew it felt like I had actually
triumphed over a difficult enemy rather
than the game artificially lowering
Sam's strengths was to give me the
illusion that I was Stronger it was a
fantastic fight from top to bottom and
it's probably my favorite fight in the
game from a mechanical perspective as
there wasn't many gimmicks involved like
cutting buildings and tanks in half or
having to deal with extra enemies
alongside the boss it was a proper 1v1
in the best way possible killing Sam
means riding gets his blade while also
discovering that Sam didn't have any
cybernetic implants this just shows how
strong he was he's not a cyborg with
enhanced Powers he's just a Brazilian
with a sword who somehow managed to
wound Armstrong speaking of Armstrong
he's next on our list but we need to get
to Pakistan first so Ryden heads off to
Solas and we can see that one of their
lead scientists is sunny sadly there
isn't much time to chat given the attack
is about to start soon but it's nice to
see that Sunny is doing well and has
gotten more of an extroverted
personality thanks to leaving The Nomad
and you know actually interacting with
people that aren't snake and oticon once
he arrives in Pakistan he finds Senator
Armstrong in his new robot Metal Gear
excelsius funny enough this isn't even a
metal gear but was called that to help
Market it better which might be a meta
joke from the team at Platinum Games
given that it's not a metal gear game
without a metal gear regardless Senator
Armstrong is a stereotypical American
he's extremely patriotic and loves
freedom in American Sports his goal is
to create a new America Naomi and mgs4
said that America would be born Anew
thanks to the Patriots no longer having
control over it Armstrong wants to take
advantage of this by getting elected
with the hope of steering the country
back into war Armstrong agrees with the
Patriots and knows that war is good for
the economy in this current War that's
about to happen will be the spark that
ignites it when he arrived Ryan
discovered that the news had leaked
about the attack early it states that
terrorists had attacked the base where
the president was located the president
lived with a dozen American soldiers had
died in the process trying to save him
many comments on social media called for
war and for Pakistan to be destroyed
this is the spark he wants as it'll
eventually lead to war which means
America's economy is going to boom and
finally be out of a recession to further
add to this Armstrong essentially wants
to restart America using War as a way to
end War he Harbors the same survival of
the fittest mindset that Monsoon does he
wants the strong to rule the weak and
for the law to be changed around the
individual not the individual to be
changed around the law Armstrong also
wants people like Ryden and his Nation
people who come from nothing but
struggle to be something Ryden was a
Child Soldier but because of his strong
mind and will he was able to escape that
life and be what he wants to be
Armstrong wants people like this as he
believes it will quote make America
great again Ryden is not going to let
that happen though so he has no choice
but to defeat excelsius once it's
defeated it seems like that's it but
Armstrong is a lot stronger than he lets
on he's also another example of the game
leaning into that metal gear style of
Comedy
let's go the hell are you thinking
played college ball you know
you know that's a cushy Ivy League
school
[Music]
try University of Texas
I'm not one of those Beltway pansies I
could break the present in two
with my bare hands
don't [__] with me
[Applause]
Armstrong is well strong minus the green
summoning thing which I still don't
understand we could see that his body
turns black momentarily when hitting
Ryden according to Armstrong the Nano
machines in his body hardened when
exposed to physical trauma he basically
has a shield that protects him from
incoming and outgoing damage I find this
detail rather interesting though as it
never mentions anything about enhanced
strength as it just seems to be used as
a defensive ability so like Sam the
senator doesn't have any cybernetics
that boost his strength he's just that
strong so strong in fact that riding can
barely land a hit on him or at least one
that does actual damage his sword does
nothing punching won't work either and
even goes full star platinum on his ass
and he takes it like a champ thankfully
blade wolf is here to give him Sam's
sword though but this leads to Ryden
starting to question what he truly
believed in and whether or not his sword
was actually a tool for justice or that
he just like killing until he doubles
back on it and goes nah who cares it's
not like this is my sword anyway and
then proceeds to fight Armstrong with
all the remaining strength he has left
like all the others though Senator
Armstrong is wounded just long enough to
deliver one last speech before Ryden
rips out his heart but it seems as
though Armstrong got his wish as a news
report tells us that the U.S and
Pakistan have agreed to a joint
operation which involves sending more
troops to Pakistan thus creating another
war on terror Armstrong's philosophy is
a difficult one to discuss as his ideas
do have some truth to them having
soldiers fight in Wars they don't
believe in makes no sense and Armstrong
wanted to get rid of that he wanted
people to fight for what they believed
in not with some higher up bureaucrats
wanted so why the Winds of Destruction
and Sam joined him since Armstrong gave
them a reason to fight his goals are
good but his method of achieving them by
instilling another War are not it is a
complex case but ultimately getting rid
of him was the right idea even if the
current world of metal gear solid has
its own problems already
the final scene shows riding in a back
alley killing a few thugs it seems like
he's taken what he's learned here to
heart and has decided to fight for what
he believes in as I said before he knows
that while he suffered there's not much
that can be done for him but there's
still a chance that he can still save
the kids from becoming like him which is
why he continued his mission we don't
know what his current mission is but
it's likely about something close to him
that he wants to stop either way it's a
great closure to ride in story from a
naive Soldier wanting to be like the
legendary Solid Snake who then ends up
being tricked and told his whole life is
a lie to being someone who could fight
for themselves and be a beacon of light
for those that need it oddly enough he's
become the kind of person his child self
would have wanted to save him from
solidus
it's unclear how much of the story was
already written and how much platinum
games had it put together but regardless
the end result was nothing short of
perfect they managed to take a character
from an already established franchise
and close his story in a way that fits
with his backstory Platinum Games could
have easily taken this in a different
direction but they still could ryden's
background and were able to conclude the
story of our cyborg ninja remarkably
well Metal Gear Rising was easily the
one game I was the most interested in
playing for this video I heard so much
about this game over the years and was
excited to see what it was all about and
I was not disappointed it doesn't have
the same careful and subtle writing as
the rest of the series but subtlety
doesn't fit in a game like this and I'm
glad that Platinum games were able to
make a game that balances Metal Gear
Solid strengths alongside their own that
being said though we are officially done
with our break and now must return to
our regularly scheduled double-crossing
and excessive plot twist programming and
this one is going to be real interesting
Metal Gear Solid 5 to many marks the end
of metal gear solid as a series as this
would be the last game Kojima would work
on for Konami the two had a very famous
few that ended with Kojima having to
leave the company I'm still not fully
sure on the facts myself as a lot of it
is shrouded in mystery but from my
understanding Kojima was becoming
increasingly harder to work with as he
went over budget and over time with
Metal Gear Solid 5 is the game cost of
close to 80 million dollars but Konami
wasn't making it any easier to finish
the game as they'd apparently demoted
most of the staff to contract level
positions and try to remove kojima's
name from the game which was something
that had appeared in every Metal Gear
Game thus far the beef these two had is
quite messy and some of it spill onto
the game itself as Metal Gear solvent 5
isn't even a full game it's two separate
games with two different names ground
zeros and the phantom pain to be fair
it's not like it's one of those older
PS1 era games where they come with
multiple discs as ground zero is at most
like three hours whereas the phantom
pain is close to 50 but still the long
development time was the cause for this
split and it makes me wonder how much
each side contributed to this result
regardless ground zeros would end up
being released as a demo slash teaser to
the events of the main game while also
including a few extra missions for fun
the best way to describe these missions
is to say that they are a mixed bag of
ideas some are standard missions like
assassinating two Targets and taking
down AA guns but then there's this
Mission involving us rescuing an
extremely high priority soldier that got
captured he's apparently so critical to
the team that mother base wouldn't be
the same without him only to find out
it's Kojima himself then there's also a
mission where you have to recreate
scenes from mgs1 and another where you
have to play is Metal Gear rising's
version of Ryden and our test with
killing a few select targets it's all
over the place but overall they were
pretty fun and would have easily sued me
over while I waited for the release of
the final product these missions are
also what I meant when I said that the
dispute the shoe had spilled over into
these games as within these last two
missions are logos of all the metal gear
games as well as flashlights that erase
them the thing is only the Kojima made
Metal Gear games can be erased mgs4 can
be erased but not Metal Gear arcade
since it wasn't made by Kojima mgs3 can
be erased But Rising can't be the fox
symbol is also missing from Kojima
production's logo and Miller will get on
the comms to say that while you may be
able to erase the markings the memories
will never disappear if you would allow
me to Don my tin foil hat for a bit it
could be that Kojima was saying goodbye
to the players given that he'd be done
with metal gear after this entry it's
also to say that he's glad he was able
to share the memories we had with him
along the way but it could also be a
message to Konami regarding mgs5 saying
that he even if they remove his name
from the series everyone will know its
true creator even if they remove his
name or the games we won't forget the
times we had playing these games and
what they meant to us maybe it's a
stretch and maybe I'm looking too far
into it but it's definitely a strange
Mission and the stuff going on behind
the scenes helped further the idea
besides these missions though we have
the you know actual Mission we're
supposed to be playing called ground
zeros it's highly advised that you read
The Briefing vows before embarking as
they'll provide some much needed context
mgs5 takes place miramonts after
peacewalker which means we're playing
his big boss once again
yeah
kept you waiting huh according to him
the U.N is going to perform a nuclear
inspection on mother base which is a
problem for msf as they want to hide the
nuke they have as their Ace in the Hole
furthermore it seems that not only did
Paws survive her battle with big boss
back in peace Walker but Chico was
captured while trying to find her
alongside the mission reports are tons
of diary entries and logs from pots and
upon reading them you get the sense that
she was feeling conflicted about
betraying mother bass initially she was
playing along and not pleased with the
crew but over time she started to loosen
up and enjoy her time there she had a
pet cat named nuke she went fishing and
played soccer with the crew and was even
going to perform a song with Miller but
that'd be cut short thanks to the
Patriots finding out about Zeke once
they got word that big boss Built Metal
Gear Zeke she was instructed to take
care of it immediately or suffer the
consequences this is where her feelings
started to turn she was sad that she
wasn't able to sing for the crew and
wish that she just had a few more days
to relax on the base as we know though
she ultimately decided to do as they
commanded as according to her betraying
the Patriots is worse than death to add
to the problems this inspection is right
around the time big boss was going to
find Chico so he'll have to be absent
for for it which would actually end up
being a blessing in disguise as the
first few minutes of the game shows us a
cutscene of a man giving a child a
cassette tape this man's name is skull
face and the child is Chico from the
dialogue we can gather that Chico was
tortured enough to give up the location
of mother base which is why skull face
and his team head out shortly after they
seem to be affiliated with a group
called xof which is something I'll touch
upon later but they end up erasing their
marking so it's then upload their cover
they then fly to mother base posed as UN
members while Big Boss rescues Chico and
pause to clarify it's shown later that
the UN had no idea this was happening so
the inspection was a ruse from the
beginning originally Miller and big boss
were against the inspection but Huey
ended up accepting on their behalf
anyway he thought that if they could
hide the nuke and do the inspection it
would keep people off their backs and
show that while they did exist is a
powerful group they don't have any nukes
and thus aren't a major threat Huey's
idea is sound but it's obviously going
to backfire while we're on the topic of
this both games that make up mgs5 have a
specific song that they reference
constantly I'll get to the Phantom Pains
of what it means but ground Heroes
constantly references a song called
Here's To You by a Neo Mora cone the
song is about two Italian anarchists
called Nicola and bartolomeo they were
being accused of killing two men during
an armed robbery the pair was eventually
found guilty a few years later and
sentenced to death via electric chair
the reason the case is so Infamous is
that it's widely believed that not only
were they innocent thanks to the
defense's flimsy evidence and
conflicting statements but the
government wanted to make an example of
them anyway thanks to their Anarchist
beliefs the song was created in response
to the trial as a way to show the world
that they weren't forgetting the
wrongful deaths of these two men now
whether or not any of this is true is
unclear and unimportant as we still have
to tie this back to ground zeros yet I
don't see a single connection there is
absolutely nothing in ground zeros that
relates to this song other than the fact
that it's somberton sets the scene quite
well but then I started to realize that
this may have been intentional this song
also plays albeit in a different tune at
the end of mgs4 and that's where the
connection is located mgs4 was
originally going to have a wildly
different ending that had oticon and
snake tried and executed for their
crimes to the broader World they would
have been criminals but to us the fans
we knew that they were innocent which
mirrors Nicola and Bart's situation
perfectly obviously though this ending
didn't happen in fact kojima's own
writing team were the one that convinced
him to not create the ending but still I
don't know what the song is doing here
in ground zeros it's nonetheless an
interesting callback to that original
idea though returning to the mission big
boss will then find Chico who can't walk
due to getting a screw Lodge in his
Achilles heel so he will have to be
carried to the transport Chopper pause
also will have to be carried thanks to
her torture at the hands of skull face
he also put a bomb in her stomach which
had to be taken out by the onboard medic
while Big Boss holds her down this is
around the time the team will make it to
mother base and we can see that the
attack has already started Miller and
the rest of the crew are battling skull
face and his forces but they're no match
for them as they're able to take out all
the platforms along at most of our crew
while this hurts already on its own it
hits especially hard after playing
peacewalker as this is our base and
these are our guys I don't know who this
no-name Soldier is that just died in big
boss's arms when he was someone who went
through the trouble of getting he could
have even been one of those s-ring
soldiers you likely spend hours trying
to get it's also assumed that Zeke sank
alongside inside the base so now our
Metal Gear is gone too all the hard work
in the tens of hundreds of hours spent
on peacewalker trying to make the best
space possible and it's gone in the
blink of an eye and we weren't even
there to defend it it really sets the
tone for the game and makes you
extremely pissed at skull face which
will be a key part of the Phantom Pains
theme
good they played us like a damn fiddle
big boss is able to extract Miller Chico
Paws in some of the crew but everyone
else including Huey's whereabouts are
unknown as the resume to be dead to make
matters worse Paz also tells everyone
that she has another bomb inside of her
lower region which prompts her to jump
out of the helicopter before it explodes
but she's too late as everyone is caught
in the blast the phantom pain will pick
up right where this leaves off but it's
an incredibly strong start to the game
and an even better teaser as I find it
hard to believe that people didn't pick
up this game after playing this to be
fair ground zeros did have a bit more
help given the fact that this wasn't
supposed to be a teaser in the first
place so naturally the first mission of
what was supposed to be the actual game
is going to be strong imagine if The
Virtuous Mission from mgs3 was a
separate product a quick and short
mission that sees the main villain
shooting a nuke naked snake almost dying
and the boss betraying her country that
would be just as impactful as this but
in hindsight it's probably a blessing
that the game released this way as it's
one of the best playable teasers I've
ever played and likely garnered a lot of
new fans attention because of how it was
structured the only question that
remains though is did the phantom pain
carry it the rest of the way
it first starts in a hospital big boss
and Miller are currently being operated
on in order to save their lives big will
also be fading in and out of
Consciousness over the course of a few
weeks but through these brief moments we
learned the following it's been nine
years since the attack on mother base
and big boss has been in a coma since
then he managed to survive but it won't
be without some consequences as not only
is there shrapnel on and near his heart
and skull but he also lost his left arm
now this would naturally call into
question how big boss went from this to
his appearance in mgs4 but we'll have to
talk about that at the end around the
time we're asked to enter in our
birthday as well as create a new
character this was strange but at the
time I didn't question its ancest
training also had to do the former US at
a special birthday cutscene could play
and for the latter I figured this was
for Metal Gear online as there is a way
to play it in the menu oh how wrong I
was
well the doctor is talking to Big Boss
and assassin has come to kill him this
woman is someone will be meeting again
later but her name is quiet and she
works for XLF the same group that skull
face runs and the ones who attacked
mother base before she can kill big boss
though another patient comes by to save
him his name appears to be Ishmael we
don't know much about him but he seems
to be very proficient in combat as he's
able to overpower quiet by burning her
with some flammable liquid Ishmael will
then guide big boss around the hospital
so that they can escape with their lives
as the hospital seems to have been
attacked by the XLF along with skull
Face's men his two Supernatural
individuals a man who is on fire dubbed
The Man on Fire and a child wearing a
gas mask that can levitate seeing as
there's not many of those people lying
around these days it's clear that this
child is psychomantis furthermore while
the other is a lot harder to notice if
the bright red suit and red bottom boots
didn't give it away then let me
introduce you to the corpse of Colonel
volgen from mgs3 According to some late
game audio logs psycho mantis is being
looked at by the Soviet Union next to
his affinity for telekinesis and
telepathy he is being brought to the
Soviet Union via plane until he found
the the presence of big boss
psychomantis is attracted to people's
emotions more specifically ones of pain
and revenge and after feeling big boss's
thirst for revenge against skull face he
was able to awaken his powers it's best
to think of big boss as the big bang
that awoke the powers with a mantis he's
always had these powers and feelings as
the first person's mind he was able to
read was his father's but big boss was
the explosion he needed to jump start
them right around this time was also
when volgan started waking up thanks to
mantis and he's basically puppeting his
corpse this is really hard to explain
and it's quite complicated but mantis is
sort of a catalyst for people the
specific person though is based on what
his appearance is as his hands start
burning on its vulgan a horn will grow
out of his head when it's big boss his
mask will change shape on his skull face
and this red cloth piece is for when
it's a kid named Eli will see later it
seems like these Powers happen without
their knowledge though as I highly doubt
big boss was using mantis's powers on
purpose in his case a chopper was
approaching him before being swallowed
by a whale so my theory is that mantis
use big boss's feelings of wanting to
destroy that Chopper seeing as it was
going to kill him which caused mantis to
summon a will to destroy it as for
volgan thanks to him dying before
achieving his plans with the shagahad he
Harbors this immense feeling of Revenge
towards Big Boss Manta somehow sense
this through the grave and was able to
be volgan's catalyst so in a way his
revenge against big boss is with keeping
him alive like I said it's really
complicated and we'll be returning to
this talk a bit later with skull face
but that's at least what I think is
going on here while this information is
great both of their roles in the story
are questionable neither of them speak
throughout the entirety of the game so
they never talk to Big Boss and volgan
only shows up occasionally when mantis
needs him seeing as he's the one
controlling him vulgar and solidus
somehow have something in common which
is that they were brought back from the
dead to fit this story only for their
time in the story to be pointless taking
volgan out of the game would have
changed nothing in regards to the plot
as he only appears a handful of times
and it uses a momentary puzzle since you
can't kill him and it's a real shame as
this is another villain in the series
whose Legacy has been tarnished thanks
to their final moments being men at long
cameos in a future title rather than
their original resting place as their
respective games antagonists
psychomantis on the other hand is
handled a bit better in this game and
I'd argue is the true antagonist the
Metal Gear Solid 5 which does negatively
impact skullface as we'll see later from
the looks of things though it seems like
everyone is coming out of the woodwork
to find big boss which is true but they
aren't the only ones zero not only came
by to visit big boss in the hospital
during his coma but this entire plan was
his idea even though he and big boss
don't see eye to eye we know that he
cares about him and given what happened
at the end of peacewalker he won a big
boss to join him he only resorted to
killing him since he had exhausted all
of his options big boss and zero may be
enemies but he doesn't want him to die
especially because part of the attack on
mother base was his own doing XLF the
unit run by skull face was created by
zero during operation Snake Eater xof
which is just fox backwards we're tasked
with helping Fox unit operatives during
their mission skull face in particular
was the Asian who held Big Boss during
mgs3 he was the fox's tale of where to
use a metaphor as he'd be the Scout to
the cleanup crew or decoy whatever the
situation call for skull face was there
to help this sort of diminishes the
entire point of mg S3 though as it was
supposed to be a one-man solo operation
that it failed would spark World War III
but sure why not either way after this
operation skull face would continue to
run xof but would over time grow
increasingly irritated with big boss and
zero that attack on mother base was
thanks to zero being lacks in his
surveillance allowing skull face to be
under the radar for a while defeating
zero and big boss is one of skull Face's
main objectives is he believes he
understands the boss's will better than
anyone that's why he tortured Paws and
Chico as they would reveal the locations
of zero and big boss respectively
actually while we're here I want to
clarify some of the language used in
this game and peacewalker as the word
Cipher is used quite a lot throughout
its dialogue Cipher is what the Patriots
used to go by before going by the
Patriots to summarize in the simplest
way possible cipherus would zero called
the organization but once the AIS took
over it was called the Patriots after
peacewalker zero managed to hire Dr
Strangelove and test her with creating
some AIS for the group these of course
being the same AIS from mgs2 and 4 like
gwal and JD this was because zero was
attacked by skull face via a gift he
gave him and realized he wouldn't be
able to see his vision come to life so
with the help of second and Strangelove
they were able to make AIS that would
carry on his will but as we know they
went against his ideals in mgs4 as they
deemed the war economy to be more
beneficial when the transfer power went
from zero to the AIS the group was then
renamed to the Patriots just like with
peacewalker I'll be referring to them as
the Patriots instead since the series is
already confusing enough as is but just
know that around the time of peacewalker
in mgs5 the group used to be called
Cipher that was quite a lot of
information though but given how the
series operates you may have expected
that to all come out during the hospital
scene but that can be further from the
truth all of this information is related
to the player via cassette tapes I
didn't think it was possible but somehow
the team managed to find an even lazier
way to relay information to the player
our lowest of lows used to be 10 minute
PowerPoint presentations but now we've
cut out the visual element altogether
mgs5 doubles as a game and a really good
audiobook as there's hours of tapes you
can collect throughout its run time the
contents of the tapes are also really
important as well so it's expected that
you at least listen to the yellow color
other ones is they provide the most
important info but I'll have more to say
on them later it's unclear when any of
this stuff actually happens though is
there are conversations that occur
between big boss and some of the cast
yet we only hear it in the tape despite
the fact that we're playing as big boss
the whole time for example later in the
game Big Balls will have to rescue some
children that escape mother base
completing the mission rewards you with
a cassette tape that plays a
conversation between Miller and big boss
discussing who's letting the kids escape
this is given to the player after
rescuing the second child but it seems
to have taken place before Big Boss
rescued him so why not just have a
cutscene of the two talking instead of a
tape this is admittedly one of the
easier examples is trying to establish a
timeline for any of these other tapes is
almost impossible these also take away
from the story of points it's not only
are you stopping what you're doing to
listen to audio tapes but some of the
story continues on in these tapes
further reinforcing how lazy this method
of Storytelling is the one positive in
this though and probably the sole reason
for why it was made is that they're
optional so instead of listening to
characters talk for 20 minutes you're
not given the option to listen to them
if you want to I think for those that
don't want to be bogged down by
pointless dialogue it works well as it
gets you back into the action as soon as
possible but for those that do care
enough to listen to them be prepared to
sit in the helicopter for a while as
there's a lot of tapes to go through
returning to where we left off Ishmael
and big boss have to run from mantis
Vulcan in the xof so they can escape the
hospital one thing that mgs5 brings to
the table is its mature themes and set
pieces multiple staff members and
patients are gone down while they're
pleading and begging the men to spare
them it sets a pretty horrific tone
which is quite the change given how most
of the series is operated on pure Camp a
lot of the comedy that the older games
are known for won't appear in this game
as it's trying to take itself more
seriously which is definitely something
I P to my interest I like the older
game's way of blending the stupid with
the series together but hearing that the
team would commit to its more serious
side had intrigued me as I wanted to see
how they would pull it off after
multiple encounters with volgan and the
xof the two end up escaping the hospital
before crashing the van they were
driving in his big boss wakes up we see
that Ishmael has disappeared and the
death straining has come by to swallow
one of the helicopters behind the whale
is also volgan who is riding a flaming
Pegasus it seems like all hope is lost
but coming to his rescue is none other
than ocelot the last time we saw him was
in mgs3 after defeating the boss ocelot
managed to get on board the plane even
big boss took out of the country and the
two had a bit of a duel it didn't really
go anywhere as ocelot would soon leave
never to be seen again until now it
seems like big boss had been in contact
with ocelot during his time at mother
base though and some tapes tell us that
zero had called ocelot and told him
where big boss was hospitalized that he
could keep an eye on him ocelot will
then take big boss to Afghanistan to go
see Miller during the nine-year coma
Miller was out helping some of the
Afghan soldiers as the Soviets were
moving in on their land and attempting
to take it over he ended up getting
captured though so we have to go get him
back which leads us into chapter one
mgs5 has two chapters total revenge and
race it also has 50 main missions with
the first 31 encapsulating chapter 1 and
the other 19 in chapter 2. think of each
one of these chapters as a season of a
TV show with the missions being episodes
which fit seeing as they're called
episodes chapter 1 is all about Revenge
Revenge on skull face for what he did to
us and mother base but to even begin our
revenge have to go find Miller once we
do we see that he's been beaten quite
bad he's also lost an arm and a leg
which we can assume is from the crash
nine years ago this creates a bit of a
problem for us as we have to carry him
out ourselves once we leave The Outpost
though we run into this unit of
Supernatural looking creatures these are
skull faces unit called the skulls these
guys are going to be the game's main
faction unit the group has three types
the Mist armor and camouflage units the
missed unit creates a cloud of mist that
not only obscures Vision but also
possesses enemy soldiers making them
become zombies the army unit functions
the same except the fact that the unit
itself has a thick layer of armor that
needs to be removed in order to damage
them in the camouflage unit are a group
of female snipers that are able to pick
out targets from over hundreds of meters
away and can also turn invisible and run
extremely fast like a lot of things in
this game though the quantity is what's
lacking here similar to peacewalker some
of the main missions are just rehashes
of previous missions but with a higher
difficulty so if we're to ignore those
and only talk about the unique main
missions that brings our total to 38.
out of these 38 unique missions I think
the whole hold unit appears maybe five
or six times I might be a bit off but
they definitely don't appear that much
despite being skull Face's Elite unit
they're also not a specific person like
the previous units it's just a group of
soldiers with different abilities so
they have no significance to the story
now the thing that gave them these
abilities does tie back into the story
but the skull unit itself doesn't this
coupled with the fact that they barely
show up though makes them one of the
most forgettable units in the series
after Miller is rescued the two Teka
helicopter to our new mother base and we
also have a new name for the group
called Diamond Dogs he wants to take
down skull face and make sure he pays
for what he did to msf but to do that
we're going to need an army this then
leads into missions three through five
which still have any major story
significance but are just missions to
get the player more comfortable with the
gameplay
companies governments and other private
forces are hiring us to do things for
them like Gathering Intel killing Rogue
agents rescuing prisoners and much more
so we're going to be doing a few of
these in order to raise our status again
this is truly where the game opens up
and the best way to describe mgs5's
gameplay is to say that it's a modern
reimagining of peacewalker's gameplay
capturing soldiers building up other
base collecting GMP buying weapons
putting soldiers in specific places like
the r d unit all of it is exactly like
Peace Walker it's also my favorite in
the entire series well I think mgs3 has
the best version of the more linear
stealth focused games I do like the idea
of making mother base your own and mgs5
does a really great job at expanding
upon what made peacewalker so fun to
play thanks to that though not much else
really needs to be explained as we
pretty much covered it all during
peacewalker but the biggest change 5
makes to the game is the ability to roam
the open world allowing you to do
multiple side Ops at once I never really
liked walking around the map though
since most of it is just Barren desert
or Forest outside of the occasional
Outpost or base compared to other open
world games it's definitely pretty bland
but the places you can visit have been
greatly expanded Upon A lot of the
missions in peacewalker felt very linear
but thanks to mgs5 opening up the map a
bit we were able to come at any location
any way you choose we're playing the
same Mission will likely have a
different result as there are so many
options and paths you can take which
adds the replayability of the game it's
pretty much a large virtual sandbox and
it's what initially hooked me as I had
quite a lot of fun replaying old
missions in different ways as I continue
to get more equipment and be more
creative with set equipment mgs5 is a
lot of fun to play and it's a game I
would easily recommend for the gameplay
alone as I can definitely see myself
replaying these missions again in the
coming weeks the next part of the story
starts around Mission 6 and it's here
where I started to notice a few things
among the many things mgs5 inherited
from peacewalker one of them was its
questionable Mission structure
peacewalker had the issue of splitting
one objective across four missions mgs5
thankfully doesn't repeat this but has
its own fair share of issues the first
one is the credits each mission is meant
to play out like an episode which is why
I made that analogy two seasons earlier
at the beginning of each Mission though
is an opening and ending credit sequence
the latter isn't bad it just occurs
every Mission so I skipped it every time
it appeared I assume this was made to
give more credit to specific designers
that made the mission but had the Opera
effect for me is it didn't feel like
sitting through the credits 50 different
times ultimately though it's not too bad
as the former has the more damning
consequences the beginning of each
Mission has a list of characters who
will appear in the mission like ocelot
Miller and venom snake which is Big
boss's new name like how Solid Snake was
called old snake and mgs4 but we're not
gonna call him that the issue is that
there's also a guest starring list with
all the important people involved
including primary targets and even
important characters Mission 6 says
starring skull face trendage rebanok
which is just psychomantis's real name
and the skulls unit and sure enough they
show up it also has a list of featured
mechs in the mission the main one being
the sahilanthropist so the mission is
already spoiling the cast before we even
leave the chopper now do we know what
skull face and mantis are going to do in
the mission no but its inclusion creates
a double-edged sword as any Mission
they're listed in already spoils what's
about to happen in any missions they
don't show up in cause the player to
care less about it since no important
characters arrive very rarely does a
mission manage to surprise you even with
the cast list as the story events are
listed in the credits obviously so we
still have that going for us Kojima is a
creative so he can do what he wants with
his games but it is puzzling how no one
on the team seemed to bring up the fact
that these credits might be spoiling the
events of the mission before it even
begins to add to the absurdity the
placement of these missions is bizarre
it's not where they are in the mission
list although some of them are also
oddly placed I mean what type of mission
it is mgs5 has three types of missions
main Ops side Ops and important side Ops
firstly you're already contradicting
yourself with the whole important side
Ops thing as that's just another name
for main side quests but regardless I
firmly believe some of these missions
are placed in the wrong spots mission 7
is given to us by some of the Afghan
soldiers who ask us to murder some
Soviet commanders Mission 9 also has
this be a distraction for the Guerrilla
forces in Afghanistan so they can attack
the Soviets while we distract most of
their men these aren't bad emissions and
I can sort of see how they're important
but then they're the important side Ops
a couple of which include rescuing Huey
Emrick you know the guy who we thought
was dead on mother base on top of not
only getting back the boss a iPod that
he we managed to bring out of the ocean
the one from peacewalker but also
finding the remains of Colonel volgen as
remember he's still just a corpse being
controlled by psychomantis how are these
important side Ops if anything these
missions should be switched to make
matters worse the Huey Mission changes
priority Mid Mission the important side
op numbered 82 has us fly to a nearby
base to find Huey once we arrive we
discovered that we were too late
escofface took him away to another base
as they leave though the title episode
12 appears so not only are the Ops out
of place but some of these side Ops can
become main Ops whenever the script
wants it to the same line of thinking
can also be applied to the cassette
tapes as well just like before the
yellow ones are supposed to be the
important ones and while I do think the
current yellow tapes make sense I feel
like more should have been included in
the list there is an entire section
dedicated to discussing what happened to
your old mother bass members but the
game colors it white meaning it's not
critical information yet in these logs
we learned that Chico died to be fair I
am probably many people thought that he
died too but seeing his Miller and big
boss live there's a chance he could have
made it out as well but the game
confirms it and a random audio log
placed in the middle of the pack there's
no memorial service for the Lost crew or
really any acknowledgment outside of
this one audio log seeing as I listen to
every log even the one that included
Miller creating a burger joint all of
them were a priority to me but not
everyone wants to listen to an audiobook
in between missions and some of them
probably could have been labeled
differently that being said the audio
tapes aren't too bad though as it's the
missions that bother me more as it
really creates this jumble mess of
content that can at times be incredibly
confusing so going back to the store
we're going back to that sixth Mission
we just talked about before this though
you end up finding a wolf pop near a
landing Zone if you fault in it back to
base it will grow older and be given the
name Dede or Diamond dog thus making it
the John Diamond dog DD also becomes a
buddy which is a part of the new buddy
system this system basically allows you
to take someone on a mission with you
but it's only the horse DD a walker and
someone else will meet later there isn't
much else to say on it other than it's a
pretty cool system as each buddy is
special in their own way this 6 though
starts with Miller filling Us in and our
objective we're looking for a powerful
missile called the honeybee which was
recently taken by the Soviets once he
finds it however skull face and mantis
appear along with these sahilanthropists
it's a giant bipedal Mech that has some
impressive Firepower it's a big matters
worse the missed unit is here so we
gotta leave once we do though that's the
end of the mission quite abrupt but
that's it this is how a lot of the game
tends to operate things just happen
without any comment or if they do it's
either a yeah we got the info you
extracted but we couldn't piece it
together so we'll just let you know
later which is then when a cassette tape
appears that explains it all as I said
it's just a really lazy way of doing
things a little bit later big boss will
get more info on Huey's whereabouts
which leads to that important side up I
talked about before but as he gets
closer to his location he runs into a
female sniper it's discovered that this
is quiet the same one from the hospital
and her outfit is peculiar Clyde ended
up getting quite a bit of flack before
release as many people saw it as another
example of games over sexualizing women
and it's not hard to see where they're
coming from Kojima did State though that
quiet's appearance was important to the
story by saying quote I know there's
people concerned about quiet but don't
worry I created her as an antithesis to
the female characters that appeared in
the recent fighter games who are
excessively exposed quiet who doesn't
have a word will be teased in the story
as well but once you recognize the
secret reason for her exposure you'll
feel ashamed for your words and deeds I
find this genuinely baffling because
that doesn't make sense at all the
reason for quiet's appearance is due to
a vocal cord of parasite this is
something that we'll get more attention
later but basically it was able to
repair her body after being lit on fire
in the hospital this parasite changed
her body though and now allows her to
gain nutrients through photosynthesis
meaning showering is akin to drinking
water as such wearing too much clothing
would be like suffocating her since she
can only breathe through her skin so she
has to wear as little as possible look
it's an answer which is at least
something but it is just as bad as when
Capcom changed Jill's hair color to
blonde and Resident Evil 5 and then made
a lore document to cover it up well it's
better than nothing it's very clear that
Capcom did it to market the game and the
same is true he here this specific
parasite as well is only in quiet and
the camouflage unit who also wear the
same clothing even if we're to ignore
the outfit though the game once again
keeps the same framing as the B and B
unit and make sure it's to focus on her
chest as much as possible while also
having her post seductively in the
chopper when you select New Missions
clearly this isn't the antithesis
because if it was none of this would
exist if anything it's continuing to
further the idea ultimately I think the
BNB unit is worse in this department but
I also don't like being lied to which is
exactly what Kojima is doing defeating
quiet though does give us the option of
killing or sparing her if we spare her
she'll become our last buddy and she's
extremely helpful I didn't do this
myself but I also like that you can even
kill her and continue the game with this
decision instead of instantly failing
it's a nice touch and gives you the
power to choose even if this is the only
choice you can make in the game
continuing on big boss will end up
finding skull face and Huey and it seems
like he was sending messages to Big Boss
with the hopes that he could be rescued
we can also see that Huey is able to
stand now thanks to these exo-powered
legs that he created kind of reminds me
of the ones Bridges has maybe they can
make them a porter after all this is
said and done damn three death stranding
jokes in one video I'm on a roll after
Big Boss finds his new location we
discover that Huey got the AI boss pod
from peacewalker out of the ocean for
some odd reason the two never talk about
this and it said just leave the base too
bad they're stopped by skull face who
managed to get sahilantropist working
we'll learn a bit later that this Mech
was created by Huey but he has some
trouble with the design though since it
was hard to get the thing to stand
without sacrificing Firepower or armor
so we thought an AI would be a better
pilot he already created an AI Mech
before which we saw on peace Walkers so
this shouldn't be any different the AI
installation wasn't complete though
which is why Huey is surprised that it's
even active as it's not supposed to be
the thing is is that it's not really
active at least not in the traditional
sense anyway the conduit for its power
is mantis but he's not necessarily
controlling it though more like being
the controls itself
just as he's able to manipulate volgan's
dying feeling of Revenge mantis is able
to use this along with himself as a
catalyst in order to control the mech to
use our current situation as an example
skull face is immense feeling of revenge
against big boss and zero is being used
by mantis who then transfers that power
to the mech along with skull face to
control it using psychomantis as the
controls it's definitely one of those
Just Go With It moments as it's
extremely complicated and very
Supernatural but it does sort of connect
to the theme of this chapter which is
Revenge skullface mentions how Revenge
can turn men into demons and also keep
the dead living it's meant to be
metaphorical as a way to say that
Revenge can drive someone to keep living
until it's finished but now it's literal
thanks to mantis's abilities on the
topic of mantis he's not really allied
with skull face more like assisting him
he craves negative and hostile emotions
and by following these people he'll be
able to feel more of them mantis just
follows those with the wicked sense of
negative feelings which surprisingly
fits with his original appearance in
mgs1 as he stated that he didn't care
for liquid's plans he just wanted to
kill as many people as possible and by
following a liquid that would have
happened it's honestly a really nice
time coming from a series that likes to
rewrite things as it goes at this point
though I figured we would get a cut
scene or skull face would leave with
sahilanthropist but no the thing
literally chases us and we have to
extract out before it kills us honestly
I didn't think we were gonna do this but
it definitely has the mission as it
really shows how powerful this machine
is it's not only extremely strong but
its massive size makes it incredibly
hard to hide from as it could just peek
over any cover we use I actually had to
leave Huey behind for a bit since
carrying it would have slowed me down
assuming you can escape without getting
killed though big boss will take Huey
back to mother base and ocelot and
Miller have already taken to
interrogating him both of them are under
the suspicion that Huey was the reason
that skull face discovered mother Basin
blew it up Huey being a potential Trader
is something that's going to come up
constantly throughout the game and even
reach a breaking point where the whole
base puts him on trial so we'll Circle
back to this periodically the one thing
Huey does tell us though is that skull
face pulled funding from his operation
in Afghanistan and moved into his new
base in Africa no one knows what he's
doing there but apparently the thing
he's researching will be the missing
link that skull face needs as a
philanthropist alone will be able to
achieve his plans which then leads us to
the next part of the chapter so far the
game leaves a lot to be desired it's
mostly just setting the scenes having
get back to where we were with mother
base the story itself hasn't really gone
anywhere but it did leave us with a lot
of questions regarding skull Face's true
motives a philanthropist and mantis
while the start isn't too interesting I
can personally say though this Africa
section takes the game in a much better
and more terrifying Direction
our first objective in Africa is to
investigate a crude oily coming from a
nearby facility it's polluting and
flooding in the nearby Villages so we
need to get rid of the tanks that are
causing the leak along the way we'll run
into a few child soldiers and even
though they won't hesitate to shoot us
we can't shoot back we are allowed to
tranquilize them but killing them
results in an instant fail it's a nice
change of pace for the purposes of
gameplay but it also shows the dangers
of War a large reason why I like this
section was because of how realistic it
was child soldiers in third world
countries being torn apart and destroyed
due to governments or companies taking
the land for their own needs is a very
common problem that is still happening
today I sometimes forgot I was playing a
metal gear solid game as playing a game
with this kind of tone right after six
other games that change tone constantly
can become a bit of a shock that's not
to say one or the other is bad I think
each game nailed what it wanted to do
the early games wanted some serious
tension mixed in with some comedy to
ease that tension But Metal Gear Solid 5
wants to ramp up its mature intensity by
showing the true and gruesome reality of
war and it's about to get worse as once
that oil facility is destroyed the level
of the oil starts to the lower which
reveals the dozens of bodies hidden
underneath all of whom have these large
cysts on their chest many of the teams
seem to think that skull face is behind
all this and this is all but confirmed
in a future Mission when we try to stop
a shipment only to find the skull unit
protecting it what they were protecting
was a shipment of yellow cake we're not
going to get into the science behind it
but basically yellow cake is a powdered
form of uranium which is used in making
nuclear weapons but apparently there
isn't enough to make a proper Warhead so
the team is still puzzled as if Diamond
Dogs needed more trouble on their hands
one of their contracts is from the
general of a rebel Army who wants us to
kill some of his men who were taken
prisoner to prevent them from Talking
the problem is that the soldiers are all
kids initially I thought big boss was
going to kill them and take the money
and him emptying an entire clip into the
cell wasn't exactly disproving my point
once olds revealed that he only did it
so they could get audio proof which they
would then send to the general allowing
them to get paid without killing the
kids big boss is definitely showing a
softer side here than before although to
be fair in his defense he's never
actually killed kids only recruited one
and he keeps in line with his way of
thinking is he wants to recruit them
into Diamond Dogs once he rescues them
somehow Miller is the voice of reason in
all this and actually disagrees a big
boss's decision he's still torn up over
Chico's death and also wants to test
something regarding the kid's upbringing
Miller didn't exactly have a great
childhood and he figures that if the
kids have better parents and Role Models
then they could live better lives so he
wants to do right by the kids and give
them a chance at a real life it's a nice
change it makes Diamond Dogs Out to be
this Beacon of light in an otherwise
dark world but sadly we're going to have
to delve back into that Dark World once
more as the kids want us to find their
leader Shabani he's located in a
building called The Devil's house and it
really lives up to its name the entire
place is covered in beds with people
hooked up to machines they all seem to
have their throats cut open with an
earbud being placed inside them while
the radio it's attached to seems to be
playing various new stations and
networks from across the world its grim
and is perfectly in line with the tone
of this game as we've just walked into a
pseudo torture room and you can't help
but feel uncomfortable while walking
through its Halls we do manage to find
Shabani but thankfully he seems to be
all right while Big Boss attempts to
break him out though skull face arrives
of mantis and volgan who torched the
place killing shibani along with all the
evidence we could have used to put a
stop to them to escape we have to
temporarily stop vulgan by dousing him
with water which admittedly was a fun
puzzle to figure out this is right
around the time I came to the
realization that mgs5 was sticking to
what it set out to do and not taking
things lightly and I was all for it it
hooked me in a completely different way
than the other games in the series I
wanted to see what these Horrors were
and what skullface was doing here and
this Mission not only continued to keep
me interested in the story was probably
one of my favorite missions in the game
due to how it sets things up it's a
wonderful Mission overall and is largely
one of the reasons why I like the Africa
section of the game as things have
started to take a drastic turn for the
worst which is totally different from
our time in Afghanistan the sad part is
that we're not going to get any answers
about what's going on here for a while
as we have a lot of miscellaneous
missions to do first which of course
severely impacts the pacing of this
otherwise great story but one of them
does at least have a pretty Infamous
character involved in it Diamond Dogs
got word of a group of child soldiers
that are taking over nearby Villages
Miller thinks that if we can take the
commander then the kids will surrender
that that's going to be easier said than
done given we have to sneak into a can
filled with armed kids but their leader
also happens to be a fair-skinned boy
named Eli or as we know him liquid snake
this ends up making the meeting a bit
awkward as liquid is his son and he
doesn't even know it since he left the
Patriots before the cloning project
began but a rather odd detail though is
that liquid's DNA doesn't match big
bosses Miller wanted to scan the kid
since he kept calling Big Boss Father
but the DNA results came up a negative
for some reason this will make a lot of
sense later but it's a nice bit of
foreshadowing Big Boss ends up defeating
liquid though and takes him back to
mother base we don't really know how he
got here but we do know that solid and
liquid snake are meant to be free range
in the sense that they weren't under the
control of the Patriots that's why solid
state in the US Will Liquid went to the
UK before going to Africa it seems
liquid being liquid though is going to
cost him Havoc for the crew at mother
base as he's already trying to start
fights with people before he's even got
a chance to look around I'll admits I'm
quite torn on liquid's appearance in
this game as he really doesn't do much I
was initially excited to see him along
with psychomantis in this game and it
does provide context as to how the two
met but outside of that liquid's role in
the story is rather unimportant there
are a few key things that happen that
involve him but most of those scenes are
extremely confusing or left unexplained
as such I'm going to put him alongside
vulgan as another character that was
thrown into the plot for no reason
despite the strong start the story has
started to take a dip in quality
thankfully it's about to go back up as
our next mission might be one of the two
best moments in the entire game after
coming back from a mission Miller tells
big boss that some of the crew have
fallen ill even worse they started
showing signs of those cysts we saw in
the people earlier meaning whatever
happened to them is happening to us in
order to stop the spread they've set up
a quarantine platform away from other
base but we're tasked with putting the
crew there ourselves we have to look
through the current list of infected to
see a Common Thread they all share race
language gender it all has to be
considered here if you can't find the
connection then more of the crew will
die and get infected and to clarify
these aren't random people these are
members of our crew so you could
literally lose all the men you spend
hours getting if you don't figure this
out even if you do manage to figure it
out we still will need to find the Cure
which is what the next three missions
will be about but segregating the crew
you think is infected is the best way to
prevent more people from dying while you
find the Cure the game also runs on an
in-game timer so it's highly advised
that you pause the game instead of
sitting in the chopper as time passes
while inside and that you select the
ASAP deployment time instead of the
other options as it also passes time
it's a really great string of missions
as I felt pressured to get going as fast
as possible which caused some problems
as some of the missions were done during
the daytime which is not ideal for
sneaking around while the intensity of
the missions are great it was the idea
that really intrigued me I was glad to
see that our crew was a part of the
story as big boss's Mission and mother
bass have been largely separate for the
most part it also makes you care about
the crew a bit more than before as you
know they aren't Invincible beings
anymore the decision to make the
infected actual crew members was genius
as it has the potential to completely
erase all the work we've gone through to
build up Diamond Dogs which gives the
player enough motivation to actually
take this seriously after a few missions
though we discovered that a man named
code talker would be able to help us
find a cure but he's located in a
mansion deep in the forest that's also
guarded by the camouflage unit this is
the first and only time we meet the
camouflage unit and is also around the
time of the player will realize they act
exactly like quiet we know that quiet
was working for skull face but quiet is
a lot different than these ghoulified
women plus we don't even know how they
got these abilities in the first place
well code talker will explain what's
going on apparently this is the result
of a vocal cord parasite during the 60s
code talker was able to examine the
end's body and discover how he was able
to photosynthesize with the environment
this organism was given the name the one
that covers it's also the same organism
used in quiet and the skulls which
explains their supernatural abilities
code talker was particularly interested
in these vocal cord parasites though as
they seemed to be an untouched part of
the world that no one's discovered yet
scofeys would eventually hear of code
talker's work and ask him to weaponize
the parasites in order to remove
language it was discovered very early on
in the research process that these
parasites can infect through language so
not speaking a specific language will
prevent it from spreading but also
prevent people from using that language
essentially making it go extinct to use
an example if there was a Spanish strain
of the vocal cord parasite it would
would activate and spread when people
use Spanish the solution would require
people to not use the language as it
would spread but that means Spanish
would become extinct as people can speak
that language or the disease spreads
this is exactly what's happening back in
mother base but with the kikongo strain
all the crew that speak to Congo are at
risk of spreading and dying to the
disease it's the only way to truly kill
off a language and that's what skull
face is hoping to achieve skull face was
born in Hungary around the time conflict
was happening this resulted in the
Invaders winning and forcing people to
conform to their standards including
Customs cultures and languages skull
face was forced to speak another
language in order to survive and it felt
like he had a part of his life Stripped
Away From Him language is a core part of
people's identities and cultures and
having that missing could have an
immense fact on the individual what
skullface was doing in the devil's house
was exactly that the parasite hooks onto
the inside of the throat of the victim
so he was placing an earbud in their
throats set the parasite could for a
lack of a better word learn the language
he wants to create strains of all kinds
of languages the most important one
being English his main goal is to rid
the world of the English language as
it's the lingua Franca of the world
oddly enough this directly opposes zero
in the Patriot's way of thinking they
want to control the world and put it
under one border and as we've seen from
the previous games they're willing to
censor information as they see fit so
it's not hard to assume that zero would
also want people to be under one
language as well which would naturally
be English skullface would be removing
English from the world which would
severely hinder if not completely
destroy Zero's goals while also causing
chaos in the process now this all sounds
genuinely insane but there is a
surprising amount of Truth in his words
as stuff like this has already happened
such as Brazil I remember a few years
ago when I had my mind blown by the fact
that people in Brazil don't speak
Brazilian but rather Portuguese I figure
Japan Japanese China Chinese Brazil
Brazilian right apparently I was wrong
and then I realized why in the 16th
century Brazil had a small portion of
Portuguese immigrants within their
country they naturally spoke Portuguese
but at the time it was only those
individuals that did eventually a treaty
called the Treaty of tortesilos would be
signed that would put the new newly
discovered land outside of Europe
between Spain and Portugal Brazil fell
within the Portuguese Alliance of the
country took the opportunity to settle
on their land and also connect with the
other ethnic communities over time
though the population of these
Portuguese immigrants rise due to their
recent colonizations which leads to
today where now Portuguese is a national
language of Brazil which is the only
country in the entire Americas including
Northern Central and Southern America to
have it as their national language so
basically if you're from Brazil you've
technically had part of your culture and
life taken away from you before you were
born thanks to your ancestors being
forced to conform to the Portuguese way
of living this same thing has happened
all over the world for years it could be
as large as one country conquering
another or a village taking over another
within the same country but this kind of
thing happens everywhere all the time
another notable example would be America
it originally started out as the 13
colonies but thanks to western expansion
and various purchases the country is now
10 times the size it used to be it's
widely known that Native Americans used
to populate these lands till the early
colonists drove them out hundreds of
languages were lost in the process of
this and while that doesn't seem bad you
have to consider that each language is
unique and how it presents ideas and
Concepts as well as how it ties back to
that group's culture so each lost
language is like losing a piece of the
world no matter how small it is thanks
to all this happening all over the world
all the time English managed to be on
top as the lingua Franca lingua Franca
roughly translates to language Bridge
English is considered this because it's
the most popular language in the world
even though only five percent of people
in the world speak it natively one in
five have it as a language a large
contributor to this was the British
Empire as it took over a large chunk of
the world during its Reign all those
people under the British rule had to
conform to their way of life either by
force or just naturally over time as now
British people were taking up residence
in their land naturally the original
settlers would want to learn the
language they could easily communicate
with them you don't learn Italians you
can live in America you learn English as
almost everyone in the country knows it
this then spreads across the future
Generations as more and more people have
kids and teach them English until that
old language has basically become
obsolete at this point English has
become the world's best language for
communication as it's the most
well-known language but it only got to
that status because only rows above the
other languages but also stuffed out
others over time thanks to this skull
Face's English as a parasite on the
world one that should be eliminated but
it can't just infect an entire language
at the start he has to test it which is
what those bodies in the oil were he'd
use the Lesser known languages specific
to small groups of people as test
subjects in order to test its
Effectiveness so that he could perfect
the English strain of the vocal cord
parasite honestly out of all the
world-ending plots this Series has a
parasite that removes language is
definitely towards the top it's not only
incredibly unique and ties back into the
overarching plot of Metal Gear Solid
seeing as this is opposing zero and the
Patriots but the parasite is rooted in
history it's not some metaphorical thing
that the team came up with as a recent
talk about dying languages supports this
the crazy part about all this is that
it's not even his full plan is there
still another piece to the puzzle we
haven't discovered yet and we're about
to see that part in just a moment as big
boss takes code talker back to mother
base to get rid of the virus until the
chopper is taken down by some Mist this
thing that is rusting our aircraft is
called archaea kotaker once again trying
to get as much time in the script as
possible also found a microbe called
archaea that was supposedly eating
uranium he was hoping to use this as a
way to remove the element from Navajo
land in an attempt to stop the pollution
skull face said nah you're actually
going to help me make nukes with it to
which code talker agreed but only
because skull face had held the Navajo
hostage through his extensive research
he was able to make a metallic version
of the archaea which was used to make
the armor of the sahilanthropist as well
as Huey's EXO legs one version of the
archaea is the corrosion we just saw now
but the other is a uranium version which
is why we saw that yellow cake earlier
the reason there was only a small amount
being transported was because the
archaea needs to be inside it in order
to survive but you don't need a whole
lot to store it this is the final step
in skull Face's goal the real objective
in all of this is peace which is ironic
given what I just spent the past five
minutes talking about but assuming his
plan works it could technically create
peace see skull face believes that he
understood the boss's will the best and
that big boss and zero are the ones that
are wrong clearly all of them are wrong
a solid snake was the only one who
understood it but regardless his plan
involves the archaea the parasite and
sahilanthropist the parasite would wipe
English off the map removing zero and
the Patriots out of the picture while
also giving people back their mother
tongues as he calls it thanks to English
being the lingua Franca of the world
removing it would mean people would have
to use other languages allowing them to
reclaim their mother tongues the other
non-english strains he has would likely
just be used as a Fail-Safe as though
their countries would come after him
after all this so he wants to make sure
he isn't defeated so halantropist is
going to be used to jumpstart the Cold
War again as announcing to the world
that you have an Evangelion seismic is
not going to sit well with people then
he plans to sell his metallic archaea on
the market as a sort of get nuke's quick
scheme along giving the smallest
countries to have nukes at their
disposal this all leads to his theory
which is the same as Coleman's from
peacewalker and that if everyone has
nukes no one's going to shoot them as
they would risk that country shooting
back at them with their own nukes thus
everyone would be in a constant state of
deterrence meaning peace would Prevail
as no one would risk starting nuclear
Armageddon it's a sound theory on paper
but it also requires a lot of trust
which is not going going to happen and
requires people to conform to other
languages skull face seems to see
English as a colonizing language that
takes from people but it's also a
language meaning it's also got its own
set of Concepts ideas and cultures so
wiping it off the map would be no
different than if another language
disappeared he's contradicting himself
but it ties back into the theme of
Revenge he wants revenge for what
happened to him as a child and he wants
to take it out on the world zero and big
boss for as much as I find skull face is
a person to be Bland thanks to his
absence in the story his master plan is
very interesting and definitely one of
the more unique ideas to come from this
series
now that my own form of an exposition
dump is done we should probably return
to the story after the chopper is
attacked by the cross of archaea the
skulls appear to take them out once Big
Boss defeats them he's able to make it
back to mother base with co-talker in
tow and with his help other base has
been officially rid of the Congo strain
of the virus but not without some
consequences to get rid of it co-talker
had to use something called wolbachia
this is a very common bacteria that when
attached to the vocal cord parasite will
turn male into female and since every
one of the parasites would be female
they can't reproduce and thus can spread
the problem is that it also has the side
effect of rendering all those infected
in Fertile so all the crew that were in
quarantine can never have kids to be
fair the alternative is dying so I think
the pros outweighs the cons here still
though the one thing the team is
confused about is where it came from
while their base sanitizes everything
thanks to war being a feeding ground for
disease but they did forget some guests
the kids they were from an African
village that was luckily used as an
experiment for skull face which is how
they were infected with the parasite the
good news that the parasites don't
affect kids only adults but Miller is
still ashamed of the fact that they left
this slip through as it could have saved
some of the crew and also I don't mean
to bring this up again but all that
information I just mentioned was from a
white cassette tape which further
reinforces my point about this game not
only using tapes as a lazy way to relay
the story but also how most of them are
mislabeled as I feel like a tape being
about the cause of the infection that
could have killed our entire operation
would be important
but now that we have cured mother base
rebuilt Diamond Dogs and no skull face
is planned we can now take the fight to
him and get our revenge Big Boss goes
alone and manages to sneak into his
Fortress before being caught by mantis
so skull face takes him hostage and has
big boss travel with him to where
sahilanthropist is located said he could
see his plan fail right in front of him
he also wanted to talk to Big Boss and
discuss his past which is where we
learned his goal as well as his past his
big boss's assistant during Snake Eater
it is quite the long car ride though and
it's probably the only time the game
falls back into its old habits with long
talks during the mission this talk is
strange though and I'm honestly
convinced a voice acting strain of the
parasite infected Kojima Productions as
no one ever talks in this game outside
of the tapes where people seem to talk
up a storm really anyone says anything
this is the second last mission and we
finally meet skull face after not seeing
him for over a dozen missions
psychomantis and vulgans a zero dialogue
throughout the game quiet sticks to her
namesake and doesn't say anything either
although that reason is backed up by the
story liquid actually scared the [__]
out of me because he doesn't talk either
except one time and I completely forgot
that he was British
goodbye father I don't need you anymore
and even big boss himself rarely speaks
which is probably the most disappointing
part this entire cutscene is just skull
face talking for 10 whole minutes
without any back and forth a common
complaint some games receive is the
silent protagonist basically the
criticism is that the protagonist
doesn't speak during times in which they
should which has the potential to
negatively impact certain scenes as
while the character is pouring their
heart out the protagonist is just
staring at them with a deadpan look
somehow metal gear solid has fallen into
this pit which is ironic since a common
complaint was that the characters talk
too much and now they don't talk enough
Miller and ocelot are the only ones that
talk the most and here he has quite a
few lines when he's a part of the script
I don't have specific stats but I might
even go as far as to say that Huey has
more lines than big boss which should
not be happening
once skull face finishes his talk and he
shows big boss sahilanthropist right on
cue things go wrong as psychomantis
takes control of the mechan attacks
skull face as we know mantis is
attracted to those with immense feelings
of hatred and while skullface was the
one who had the highest feeling liquid
managed to sneak onto the helicopter
that's watching over big boss mantis
felt his hatred and allowed liquid to
usurp control so technically liquid is
the one controlling the sahilantropus
everyone thinks it's a mantis and they
won't know the real truth until much
later as they still don't understand the
length of mantis's abilities but now big
boss has to defeat the mech before that
happens look what takes the opportunity
to kill skull face who is now trapped
underneath tons of rubble he doesn't
seem to mind though as once again his
plan was to use the mech to start a war
so once information gets out that a
weapon like this exists then the Cold
War would restart but thanks to Big Boss
none of that happened as the mech is
destroyed after a very long boss fight
the only one who actually seems injured
in this fight is sahilanthropist as
mantis relinquishes liquid's control
over the mech and mantis himself seems
unharmed but still a win is a win before
they head out though Miller and big boss
pays skull face visit he carried with
him a device that had three vials of the
English strain one is missing one was
destroyed and one was taken by mantis
before it could be burned skull face
then begs to be killed which results in
the two shooting him repeatedly in order
to make him suffer they shoot him in the
stomach they even take off one of his
arms and legs to get paid back for
Miller and somehow he's not dead Huey's
the one that gets the last laugh though
foreign
[Music]
yeah Revenge anyway here's a
non-sequitur for you Metal Gear Solid 5
is a weird fascination with Moby Dick
the story of Moby Dick is centered
around a Captain Ahab who lost his arm
to the giant whale Moby Dick and vows to
strike it down along the way he picks up
a crew of like-minded individuals and
chases the thing to the ends of the
Earth all to fail as it's assumed that
the crew died while the whale survived
it's supposed to be a story of Revenge
and how it's unsatisfying and how Ahab
dedicated his life to that Revenge this
mirror's big boss in Miller perfectly as
they stopped at nothing to defeat skull
face but it goes even deeper than that
Ishmael from the hospital is the name of
a character from the story and is also
written from his point of view so Moby
Dick is really his story about watching
the crew take on the whale which sort of
fits given who Ishmael actually is ishma
also calls Big Boss Ahab both of whom
are the leaders of their respective
groups and lost and aren't the thing
they swore revenge against and our
helicopter is named Pequot which is the
ship they used to sail the high seas
with now the story doesn't exactly give
us any clues as to what will happen next
but it is cool how this chapter was
pretty much committed to mimicking the
events of that story regardless my
thoughts on skull face are mixed because
I don't like how he was presented in
this story but that also ended up making
this moment better despite being the
main villain he only shows up in a
couple of missions for a total of maybe
20 or 30 minutes most of which come from
the last two missions he's largely
absent from the entire story which makes
him a really boring villain but that
makes this scene even better as I feel
like it's supposed to portray how
revenge is petty and usually not
satisfying which might be why the final
bullet doesn't fire it's anticlimactic
and I think the whole scene is meant to
feel that way and having skull face be a
complete non-factor throughout the
course of this chapter makes it feel
even more so that being said it does
suck that his presence is lacking as I
feel like there was a way to make both
options work which would be having skull
face be more present while making the
Revenge unsatisfying without sacrificing
one for the other he had the potential
to be a very good villain as his
motivations were interesting and the
things he does in the tapes are horrific
like pretending to torture some of the
Navajo to get code talker to work with
him he's a terrible person in the tapes
but his on-screen performances really
where it counts and it doesn't succeed
which is a shame as ironic as this
sounds though the ending does give off
this sense of closure the crew goes back
to mother base and even boughts a
philanthropist with them as a trophy of
their Victory even though they can't use
it and pretty much everyone celebrates
and relaxes now their rival is dead as a
whole chapter 1 like this whole game is
a mixed bag it's neither good nor bad
and even the same parts of the story are
not good or bad as I just mentioned I
didn't like skull face nor his role as
main villain but his role at least when
it comes to what he means to Miller and
big boss worked well a lot of this
chapter and even this game is give and
take as I find it extremely difficult to
look at one thing and go that's perfect
or that's terrible it's a constant
Whiplash of back and forth and it can be
seen throughout the missions one minute
you're rescuing random Intel members
then extra going through a torture
chamber even the entire cast is mixed we
haven't really talked about Miller and
ocelot outside of a couple missions
because they don't usually provide much
to the story but in regards to their
roles as ocelot being the sort of
know-it-all leader and Miller leading
mother base they're great but the story
is also conveyed lazily through these
cassette tapes which takes away from the
story right in front of us as if the
team can't figure out how to construct
the scene they can always fall back on
these tapes as a last resort but some of
the moments throughout the story are
incredible like the aforementioned
torture chamber and even the attack on
mother base back in ground zeros it
really is a mixed bag and a lot of this
is going to continue into chapter 2 as
it arguably gets worse and better at the
same time
if chapter 1 was the rise of Diamond
Dogs chapter 2 would be the fall as over
the course of the chapter Diamond dog's
going to go through some rough patches
that will change the group forever right
away though we gotta talk about the
missions as I said at the top mgs5 has
50 missions Which chapter 2 containing
19 of them Mission 32-50 are a part of
this section but more than half are just
repeats of previous missions with
different difficulty modifiers Mission
34 titled subsidence c2w is just Mission
4 c2w with an mgs1 twist as we start
with no gear mission 50 extreme cell
entropist is just a repeat of mission 31
but on a higher difficulty these make up
12 of the 19 missions in this chapter
and none of them have anything to do
with the story now I don't mind their
inclusion as their fun missions for the
sake of gameplay but why are they in
this chapter most of the unique story
missions in this chapter involve
cleaning up Loose Ends like going back
to code talker's residence to extract
some materials before the xof get their
hands on it those are fine and I don't
mind them but it's the repeat missions
that make no sense to me oddly enough
peacewalker actually has had the right
idea when it came to structuring these
missions after each the doornov Escape
you get a handful of new content to do
with the assumption that you would do
them and then zodornov would escape
again which would of course give you
more missions mgs5 sort of does this but
it's mainly these repeat missions since
they make up the majority of this
chapter I think it would have been
perfect to swap some of the important
side Ops and put them in here I have no
issue with these missions from a
gameplay perspective in fact I'm glad
they added the modifiers to them but the
important side Ops in these missions
should have been switched to make the
story flow a bit better on top of this
the missions themselves aren't too
interesting it's mostly what happens
after upon doing a dozen or so missions
and returning to base intermittently
between them we discovered that Huey has
created a new battle gear for us to use
we can also create nukes to use at
mother base and liquid is piss because
of one of the kids we took aboard died
in an accident on the base I cannot
stress this enough when I say that it's
not the missions themselves that trigger
this but the trip back home that does at
this point in the recording I destroyed
some Walker gears and did a couple of
the repeat missions nothing of no had
occurred in these missions it was only
after furthermore this chapter is also
where I got 80 of the info I've
discussed with you till now the stuff
about the Man on Fire being volgan the
goals of skull face which involves the
halantropist the archaea and the
parasite how skull face was going to
make the get nukes quick scheme how the
code talker managed to find the
parasites in the end's body why code
talker wanted to get the uranium out of
the Navajo land why there was yellow
cake in that cargo truck a few dozen
missions ago all of it was in tapes and
given to you around this time I hope
that illustrates my utter disdain for
the system after some more time doing
side Ops and such we're told to find
Colonel vulgan's remains as well as the
boss a iPod and bring them back to
mother base just like usual though all
we do is extracted and then it's not
until a few missions later where we get
the actual info we need from it but in
the form of a cassette tape according to
the tape Huey was being interrogated by
the team again but his story doesn't
seem to be adding up it's heavily
implied that Huey not only used oticon
as a test subject for salantropist but
he also killed Dr Strangelove which he
disagreed with his plan to harm their
child multiple timelines across the game
show us that Otakon was born in 1980 so
this happened in between that nine-year
coma what that does call into question
what Huey was doing seeing his mother
base just got attacked so how did a man
in a wheelchair manage to escape that's
where a lot of these suspicions starts
with him and working with skull face was
not helping his case he claims that it
was either doing this or die which I
could believe but here he also seems to
jump ship whenever he can as for Strange
Love she wasn't present during the
attack as they moved all civilians off
the base beforehand that the U.N
wouldn't ask questions she somehow
managed to get roped back into all of
this though and had to work with zero to
create the AIS afterwards she met with
Huey who was under the command of skull
face and the two had aracan the
relationship was starting to go
somewhere in peacewalker as she seemed
to flirt with Huey a bit but Strangelove
also seems to be bi as she was deeply in
love with the boss and there's even a
tape from Paws that talks about strangel
and flirting with her either way Huey
was trying to test out sahilanthropists
but since the cockpit was too big for an
adult he decided oticon to be a perfect
fit for the job as if that can't go
wrong Strangelove disagreed then when
apparently sent him to America which is
a bit mind-boggling as the kid is like
three at best but Huey didn't like this
though and ended up [__] her in the
boss a iPod which suffocated her to
death Miller and ocelot are still going
back and forth on what to do with him
though as Huey has said that everything
we have accused him of are lies so
they're going to set up a trial soon and
put him in front of all of mother base
as for volgan well not much happens
actually we attempt to Fulton this
corpse back to base which wakes him up
but he stops her before killing big boss
I think this is another attempt at
foreshadowing which is admittedly pretty
cool but once again I feel like volgan's
character was completely wasted as this
is the last time he'll appear in the
game he's never talked once throughout
the entire game which I could forgive
seeing as he's just a corpse with him
transforming at the end could have went
somewhere why not have him talk about
the events of Snake Eater to really
drive home how much he hates him or even
have him poke fun at his eye since he
lost it on that mission without this the
whole interaction is just really awkward
to watch
foreign
[Music]
it's crazy how much dialogue can carry a
scene even if it's a few lines from what
I've heard Koji wanted to lessen the
dialogue a bit to convey the actions
speak louder than words which is
impressive given his previous games do
the exact opposite but it's always felt
like the team goes to the most extreme
conclusions whenever they come up with
ideas like okay we need dialogue let's
have 20 minutes of exposition we need
cutscenes let's make one that's 70
minutes long well that was too much they
want less dialogue alright let's just
make everyone mute like there is a
genuine Middle Ground here and I don't
know why I can never be reached in his
defense some of these moments do work
and it ironically has to do with the
character who literally can't speak
despite my initial criticisms of her I
actually enjoy quiet and found her to be
a great member of the team and a lot of
her scenes do fit with what Kojima
wanted to convey if you have a high
enough bond with quiet you can play in
the rain with her and you can tell that
her and big boss are happy and enjoying
their time together no words are spoken
here but there doesn't need to be as the
scene does a good enough job on its own
to explain how they feel this of course
is rare though as most of the time it's
like our meeting with vulgan the only
Silver Lining is that we got to see
colonel vulgan in the new Fox engine so
there's that after a few more missions
Miller will call big boss and tell him
that someone else is infected on the
base more specifically quiet the team
once again resorts to torture but she
won't say anything that is until they
leave to which she speaks to code talker
and Navajo this is a rather huge moment
as it's recruiting her she hasn't spoken
a single word even in another language
that's because she was given the English
strain that third vial that was missing
was injected into quiet scofeys have put
it in her in case an assassination
attempt failed so she could infect
people by speaking to them his plan
failed again though as quiet decided not
to speak to anyone since coming here she
seems to be torn on what to do as she
probably won a revenge for a big boss
did her at the hospital but she also
seemed to like big boss so she didn't
want him to die like most of the stuff
in this chapter though won't be talked
about for a while but quiet will end up
leaving the base at one point supposed
to not spread the virus Big Boss goes
after her and somehow she was captured
by a group of no-name soldiers only to
escape after getting drenched in water a
bunch of soldiers seem to have come out
of the woodwork to take her down so we
have to take out some of the tanks in
apcs along with her this Mission though
actually almost broke me as for some odd
reason you cannot abandon the mission
like all the others before so you're
forced to complete it the moment you
start this is also where I learned about
one of the chicken hats I had one when I
talked to code talker since the
camouflage unit completely destroyed me
but that allows you to be spotted a few
times out actually being spotted it does
impact your ranking in the mission but
it's helpful for when you're stuck well
apparently there was an even higher tier
than that which I got during this
Mission I was very underprepared for
this as once again the mission priority
changed so I had no clue we would go
from finding quiet to fighting the
entire Soviet Army to be fair you don't
have to use these items but I was
struggling enough as is so it did help
to a degree regardless once the tanks
have been destroyed quite has to be
carried by Big Boss thanks to a
sandstorm coming by and drawing her up
the two end up hiding from some Soviet
forces but big boss is bitten by a
venomous snake which is fitting and has
to be evacuated so he can get medical
attention the problem is that pequoda
can't see us and big boss can't speak
since he's fading in and out of
Consciousness right now so it's up to
quiet to do it but she won't speak
because the English strain until she
does as I said only a few lines of
dialogue are needed to really set the
scene here and quiet was willing to
speak English just to get big boss out
of here it really shows how much she
cares about him and she's willing to put
herself a risk just to save him this of
course calls into question though what
will happen next now the strain is loose
but it seems to be a bit more
complicated than that according to code
talker the parasites multiply an effect
the more a person speaks plus it also
happens after an unknown amount of time
so quiet doing this and then leaving
right away would in theory prevent the
English strain from spreading which is
exactly what she does as she leaves
after big boss is rescued the vocal cord
of parasites are definitely a bit hard
to wrap your head around sometimes but
overall I liked the mission and is one
of the reasons why I like quiet as a
character Plus for the purposes of
gameplay she's also gone for my buddy
list I have heard that you can get her
back by redoing the introduction Mission
seven times but I haven't done that
myself either way she's now gone from
our team and it's a pretty big hole that
she left that she was easily my favorite
buddy in the game sometimes DeDe and D
horse were better but if I didn't know
who to choose I usually do if alter the
quiet as you really can't go wrong with
her so it sucked to see her go as she
was a valuable asset to the team and her
insistence on making sure mother bass
wasn't destroyed by not talking was very
brave of her and shows how much Diamond
dogs and big boss had really affected
her sadly quiet isn't the only one to
have left the base as the kids We
rescued from that mine earlier also
escaped the team must have absolutely
loved the zidornov missions as they're
basically an exact copy of those at
least they show up right away this time
and don't take up the whole chapter
though but as they say one in one out as
we actually have a new member joining us
at mother base who is Paws sort of if
you go to the medical platform on mother
base you'll find Paws in one of the
rooms and she seems delighted to see us
apparently she had Amnesia and forgot
everything regarding the Patriots and
ground zeros funny enough she's exactly
what I wish pause was in peacewalker a
normal girl whose home was ravaged by
War the problem is that she's not real
it's just big boss's mind tricking him
into thinking she's alive in fact not
even the room exists as the door just
leads to a platform outside the building
Miller and ocelot do appear in the
cutscene as well but I also think it's
big boss's Mind Playing Tricks on him
again this is further confirmed by the
constant flashbacks big boss will have
when he first meets her as he travels
back in time to when the chopper blew up
from her
[Music]
no no no no it's okay yeah
there's another in my
[Music]
course
the guided tour will be wrapped up by
the time you get home make me proud
by the time they leave I'll have the
iaea praising us as the poster boys for
world peace out
the events of the cutscene are also
slightly different as a rocket blows up
the chopper instead of the bomb it seems
like big boss is trying to come to terms
of what's going on by changing the
memory in his mind it's another good
string of missions as you're likely to
be confused as to what's going on with
Paws if she clearly died but she's also
alive right in front of you even if you
assume that she's just a phantom pain
from big boss's mind you'll likely want
to know where this goes as clearly Paws
showing up out of nowhere isn't just
going to be thrown into the game and
never talked about again while she
doesn't have her own set of missions she
has ones that are related to her which
require you to give her pictures taken
from mother Bay string msf she basically
repeats what her audio logs talked about
in ground zeros before Big Boss realizes
that she isn't real it was a nice set of
missions though and even though she
wasn't actually here it was also great
to hear paz's voice again as well as
reminisce about msf
remember Professor Galvez on his
instrument during peace day
such a funny sound for a musical
instrument
he said the Soviets invented it
everyone sure seemed impressed
music has no borders the professor
taught me that
Professor Galvez anyway now that one kid
has been taken care of we should
probably get those other kids we were
supposed to get earlier as I said before
they pull out exactly like these adornov
missions which are pretty stupid
especially since the question of who's
letting them out is brought up again
except this time it's pretty obvious
liquid was the one telling them to
escape as he believes that they should
do what they want and be who they want
and if that means soldiers then so be it
liquid also says that bringing them back
is going to come with serious
consequences and surprisingly he isn't
lying as with the help of mantis they
managed to take sahilanthropist with
them and leave now this wouldn't be an
issue seeing as it's really just a pile
of metal at this point but apparently
Huey was making repairs to it and now
it's fully operational again while all
of that is crazy what's even crazier is
that the mission just ends and is never
talked about again the most common
criticism levied at Metal Gear Solid 5
is that it's unfinished under Reddit
threads Forum post hell even my own
Community post people were telling me
that the game was unfinished this is
backed up by a couple of things one is
the actual ending itself which we'll get
to and the other is this Eli
psychomantis since the philanthropist
never show up again for the rest of the
game this is the last time we see or
interact with them that's obviously very
confusing as they just stole a Mech from
us and psychomantis gave liquid the
English strain earlier so they also have
that with them the game never brings
this up but it seemed like it was going
to there was a cut Mission 51 called
Kingdom of the Flies and involved Big
Boss going to Africa to take them down
apparently the kids liquid and mantis
use the vocal cord parasite to infect
the area and kill the adults since the
strain only affects adults and then they
would have announced the mech to the
world and demanded the body of big boss
or else they would launch a nuke
eventually liquid would start to feel
symptoms of its infection until Mendes
took it out of him using his telekinesis
from there it seemed like there was
going to be another big battle between
sahilanthropist and big boss which would
result in him winning and Diamond Dogs
napalm in the area in order to stop the
infection from spreading I'll leave a
link to a video by a newsie that shows
what was created in Full so you get a
better look at things but overall it
sounded like a pretty cool Mission All
Things Considered while this is
definitely a good argument when it comes
to the claim that mgs5 is unfinished we
also have to ask why it was cut it's
possible that it didn't fit with the
story but it could also be that the
Konami Kojima Feud has once again
spilled onto the game the one thing I
will say though is that this ending is
arguably more rough than the one we got
as liquid and mantis leave the place
before being blown up and then he says
it's not over and then the game ends but
once again it's unfinished so it's hard
to judge the product as it is that being
said even with the Cod content I have to
judge the final product and obviously
it's pretty bad speaking of cut content
although not exactly I found out about
this Midway through editing this part of
the video but apparently there was a
whole nother ending planned regarding
the nukes thanks to chapter 2 nukes can
now be bought and placed on mother base
there was an ending that would trigger
though if zero nukes were present on the
base but that meant Zero nukes in the
whole game meaning every nuke from all
players had to be disassembled in order
to get the nuclear disarmament ending
apparently this is impossible as the
only way this worked was for someone to
hack everyone's nukes out of the game as
there were supposedly nukes that
couldn't be destroyed no matter what
people tried but the ending was going to
have some kind of monologue about nukes
and how so many of them still exist
today and just like with Mission 51 it
seemed like it would have been a pretty
cool cutscene to watch if you managed to
get it it's also linked in that video I
mentioned earlier if you want to see it
for yourself it's kind of interesting
though how good some of the game's cut
content is as it all ties back into the
series in some way with the disarming of
nukes being literally at the core of
this entire series and liquid wanting
big boss's body with something he also
wanted in mgs1 so all of it could have
tied up some of the loose threads left
by other games but we sadly won't be
able to see these come to fruition
anytime soon
minor tangent aside we still have a few
more things to discuss regarding chapter
two one of which being another outbreak
this is different from the stuff with
quiet as that was just an MRI scandum by
code talker this is another full-on
outbreak like the one we had earlier and
while I did like the devil's house
Mission 43 is easily the best one in the
game the outbreak started on the
quarantine platform which is a lucky
break for Diamond Dogs is that place is
already sectioned out for the rest of
the base from the footage inside we said
the infection has spread fast and most
of these surviving crew has been
attacked big boss is then given the job
of going in and assessing the situation
and the inside of something out of a
horror movie the place is covered in
blood in the bodies of our men once we
reach the top we find the guy who sent
the transmission to us earlier who gives
us goggles allowing us to see the
infection through the victim's throats
the problem is that it's showing up on
everyone and the infection is also
forcing them to go outside as their
bodies would be eaten by the birds and
carried elsewhere so either kill them or
let the world succumb to the virus so we
have to put down our own men and once
again these aren't random people with
actual members of the crew I checked
myself and even found one of the crew in
the list right next to me this hissing
hippo was someone I recruited and now I
have to kill him it was different before
as the virus was killing us but now we
have to deliver the killing blow
ourselves it's the most unnerving
Mission I've played in the whole series
and it makes it even worse when the crew
looks you in the eyes while you do it
like they know what you have to do and
are willing to die if it's by your hands
[Music]
foreign
I'm sorry boss I never felt more
connected to a character in these games
before as big boss feels terrible for
having to do this and you're right there
with him it's the perfect example of
actions speak louder than words and
while the game didn't really capitalize
on this in the other missions they
absolutely nailed it here after everyone
is killed Big Boss walks the halls of
dead corpses and sits there in silence
while the blood and bodies surround him
the surviving crew then has a memorial
for the Lost crew and big boss hops to
have them made into diamonds that they
could be worn by the crew allowing
everyone to carry on their fellow man's
wills and take them into battle with us
it's a very ceremonious Mission and
there isn't a single bad thing about
this Mission it's perfect from start to
finish and is the physical embodiment of
the best parts of mgs5 a mature and
serious game about loss and pain the
only thing that remains though is the
answer as to where the infection came
from well according to code talker the
results from the wobakia mutating the
wobakia was supposed to stop the
infection due to it mutated in the vocal
cord parasite but now the wolbachia
itself has mutated thanks to some Beta
Ray that were used in their scans but
beta Rays aren't needed for their kinds
of scans so someone added it to the
scans and triggered a mutation and the
only one who had access to that was Huey
which of course leads us to his trial
when I say trial Loosely since it feels
rather one-sided as Miller and the crew
kind of just want Huey dead but big boss
opted to have him cast out of the base
on a life raft kiwi being a traitor is
quite a difficult topic to discuss since
there's no actual evidence outside of
killing Strangelove that he did what he
claimed he's done the thing is though is
that Huey is a habitual liar originally
he said skullface killed Strange Love
and then after being pressured by Miller
he said that she accidentally locked
herself inside the Pod and died okay
so which one was it that's two totally
different outcomes so clearly his story
isn't adding up which leads me to
believe that he's lying about everything
I'm partially willing to believe that
the attack on mother base was not his
doing but everything after definitely
was helping the kids would
sahilanthropist the outbreak of mother
base and everything else have a decent
amount of evidence behind it so it's
probably for the best city leave our
establishment Huey is to put it bluntly
a Monster who will lie and kill to get
his way he's a terrible father that was
willing to use his own kid as a test
subject and then killed the mother of
their child simply for doing what any
parent would do the one positive to Huey
though is that he and Strangelove
conceived a child that would live on and
deny the family history by actively
going against what his fathers did all
those years ago
oticon is one of my favorite characters
in this series for many reasons and part
of it was because of Huey aracan
couldn't be further from his father
personality wise if he tried he hates
seeing his dangerous Tech used to kill
people will openly admit when one of his
Creations were stolen by someone and is
actually a decent human being despite
how much I hate Huey he's a good look at
what Otakon could have become had his
life taken a different path which is why
Solid Snake is another member of the
cast that I adore as he showed aracan a
different way of life and the two of
them together were able to save the
entire world despite the odds all in all
the way the team created Huey as this
unlikable guy with practically zero
redeeming qualities was great and it
really just shows how terrible Huey is
while also showing how great oticon was
with that we have now come to the final
mission after doing all the main
missions all the important side Ops and
I believe reading all the yellow tapes
we're given one final mission labeled
Truth The Man Who Sold the World the
mission starts in the hospital I didn't
believe it at first but the game
actually makes you play the entire first
mission again I understand why they
would do this as this mission is tied to
the twist that will happen soon but
doing the whole thing again is certainly
a choice that's for sure the real change
comes at the end where big boss and
Ishmael crashed the van and that's that
big boss was never Big Boss Ishmael was
the real big boss we were a decoy along
with Miller Another injured crew member
who survived was the medic who operated
on pause or more specifically the person
we created in the beginning of the game
this is the real identity of the medic
and the person we've been playing as the
whole time since the world is gunning
for big boss he needed to lay low
outside the eyes of the world where he
continues his plans we as the new Big
Boss were made to be his stand-in
attract all the attention and continue
to uphold the legacy of big boss while
not actually being him the whole time
meanwhile big boss would take our
identity which honestly caused my heart
to stop a bit when I saw my name appear
on the postcard and the passport big
boss was taking my identity while we
were forced to use his everything after
this explosion was from the perspective
of venom snake our created character and
I do mean everything that's why the DNA
for liquid didn't match as it wasn't big
bosses in liquid's DNA it was Liquid in
the Medics and obviously they aren't
related it's also why the boss say iPod
didn't recognize him when they meet and
probably why vulgin died after getting
close to venom snake is he realized that
he wasn't the real big boss that's also
why the real big boss was named Ishmael
as in Moby Dick this story is from his
perspective as he watches the crew fight
the whale while big boss is watching
Venom and the diamond dogs fight the
World the game also teases this a couple
times during the intro listen to these
lines again and remember that Ishmael is
actually big boss and that they're
talking to the body double and not the
real one
short way down
you're talking to yourself
the name's Austin
big boss you know who I am the certain
man gave me a job to do two actually
first was to get you out of that
hospital
second is to rescue the man himself
it's time once we're there
don't take too long getting used to your
new self mgs5 has taken the series back
to its roots with plot twists that are
subtle enough to hide under the radar
but end up becoming more apparent on a
second playthrough from what I've heard
though some people have said that the
ending was too obvious and I can see
that the problem for me was that the
game was gaslighting me the whole time
it's all like the liquid snake reveal
where it's only through a Kodak call
you're literally playing as who you
assume is big boss and then are told
that you are him throughout the game
it's a great twist but is still not even
over yet as we see the medic venom snake
listening to a cassette table The Men
Who Sold the World the name is in
reference to a song of the same name it
was originally sung by David Bowie but
you may have also heard the other
version of it by Nirvana the song
basically spills out the Twist from the
beginning as the song is about Bowie and
how he struggle to recognize himself
over the years but it goes even deeper
as well as the version used in game is
it covered by someone called mid-year so
the person singing is in Bowie just like
how Venom is in big boss it's a perfect
song to use for this kind of twist it's
not only catchy but it also mirrors our
current situation on the back of the
cassette tape though is another track
labeled operation intrude n313 aka the
outer have an uprising or more commonly
known as the events of metal gear 1.
this is why I've largely avoided talking
about the events of metal gear as this
game would inevitably change things
around the original release Solid Snake
was tasked with going to a base called
outer heaven and taking down their
leader his commanding officer at the
time was Big Boss but it was discovered
that the leader of the group was also a
big boss he was hoping salts think would
fail in his mission which is likely why
a lot of his dialogue says things like
oh yeah I kind of forgot to mention
you'll need a gas mask or to enter this
area he would eventually overcome and
kill him which leads to the events of
Metal Gear 2 where Solid Snake now has
to take down another place called
Zanzibar only to discover that big boss
is here again this is where he
officially defeats him though and where
he would stay dead until I'm GS4 but the
change that big boss was never Out of
Heaven as it was venom snake the series
has now come full circle as in release
order the protagonist of the last game
is the villain of the first game this is
further confirmed by the background as
the logos change from Diamond Dogs to
Outer Heaven not only proving that venom
snake is Big Boss for Metal Gear 1 but
that he's become a demon of sorts now as
his attitude changes drastically when
the diamond dog's logo appears he seems
to be okay with the body double act and
is one to carry on his legacy as he's
extremely loyal to Big Boss but when the
outer Heaven logo appears he has either
gone completely mad or resents big boss
or realizes that he only did this to
benefit himself personally it's a bit
hard to tell and Metal Gear 1 doesn't
exactly give us any clues either since
the games are made 30 years apart but it
does seem like something changed in bed
in between Diamond Dogs and outer Heaven
the purpose of the ending though is to
not only show how much of a villain big
boss is by literally stealing the
appearance of one of his men to suit his
needs but also how big boss could be
anyone big boss is just a title it's
like what ocelot said regarding Ryden
and the big shell given the right
situation the right story anyone can be
shaped into snake
even rookies can fight like men of
experience anybody could be big boss of
the circumstances allowed it and mgs5
shows that it's possible the most
logical thing to ask now though is who
knew well ocelot big boss and zero
continuing the theme of over
complication and slowly ruining
everything we just built up the body
double switch was all the planet zero
which is annoying as once again
everything has to be the will of the
Patriots now it also ruins the original
idea that big boss did this said he
could go under the radar now big boss
seems like someone going along with the
plan rather than it being his plan as
for ocelot he didn't know and did know
at the same time he apparently
hypnotized himself before we got to
mother base that he would believe that
venom snake was big boss which is odd as
he could have just I don't know not said
anything but I guess he didn't trust
himself plus he somehow needed a way to
snap himself out of the hypnosis which
he achieved but it's never explained
what it was because of course it's not
the one part of this I did like is
Miller as he has no idea about any of
this and his pissed as he thought big
boss would clue him in on the plan and
now he feels betrayed because of it he
then decided to join Venom instead and
continue to run Diamond Dogs but after
what I assume was Diamond Dogs merging
with outer Heaven he left to train
people with him Fox on which is where he
met Solid Snake I don't understand why
some of those last few details were
necessary as once again they ruined the
twist a bit but overall The Twist is
fantastic and definitely one of my
favorites in the series but the problem
is that it ends here this is the final
mission and Venom punching the mirror is
the last thing we see it's very abrupt
but I almost like it that way mgs5 is in
the middle of the timeline so it's hard
to make a clear-cut ending when there is
more to go plus you could argue the mgs5
story ended when we killed skullface
like how Peace Walker technically ended
when the boss killed itself still I saw
this ending as a message from Big Boss
to keep doing what we're doing we as
venom snake now know our true origin but
that's not going to stop our mission we
still have to continue to play the role
of big boss so by continuing to play the
game we'd be doing exactly that that's
at least how I saw the ending anyway but
if you're someone who dislikes the
ending and finds it too sudden I think
that's a totally valid opinion to have
this Mission though is the final piece
of content for chapter 2 and mgs5 and as
I said before this chapter was at times
going to be worse and better than
chapter one the second outbreak in the
various plot developments like the trial
of Huey and liquid taking the subtle
entropists were great but then it fell
back on itself Again by not answering
what happened to sahilanthropists over
complicating some of the ending for no
reason and most importantly of all
making more than half the chapter
different versions of old missions it's
a very odd way to structure a chapter in
a very odd way to end a game I've
already explained my thoughts within the
chapters but my thoughts in the game as
a whole are the same as the individual
chapters it's a lot of give and take
it's a lot like mgs4 in that respect
where it Nails specific Parts really
well but tends to fail at others ground
zeros is a perfect product and a great
introductory mission for the game and
the devil's house and the various
outbreaks that occurred on mother base
were some of the highlights of the story
the main motivation behind skull Face's
actions and the idea of using language
as a weapon intrigued me enough to see
where it could go but then there were
those tedious repetitive missions with
no real weight behind them mission that
were oddly structured and should have
been placed in different sections
characters that were thrown into the
plot for no reason very little back and
forth dialogue and a few plot points
that were just not answered despite that
though just like mgs4 my overall
experience was positive I enjoyed my
time with the game I truly did the
gameplay was Top Notch and the best in
the series and the decision to go for a
more serious tone this time was
unexpected but welcome and I think given
what the team had to work with they did
all right it's luck to see that Kojima
had to leave a series behind after this
but I think it left on a good note
Metal Gear Solid is a great series and
an important one at that and I finally
understand why people love these games
I've given Kojima and his team a lot of
[__] throughout this video but I did
enjoy each of these games I like some
more than others but I never truly hated
any of these games some have some great
gameplay incredible messages beautiful
portrayals of the harmful effects of war
or just all around good stories
they also have very questionable pacing
retcons or changes in the script to fit
the narrative and a few characters with
some wasted potential that being said
each game is so unique that there's
something here for everyone usually
games have to change their genres
completely to attract new fans But Metal
Gear Solid did that by just doing what
it does best all over the Internet are
people defending at least one of these
games in the series because each one
resonates with someone differently they
might love the generic action of one the
message of two the wackiness of three
the fan service of four or the gameplay
of five and dozens of other things I
haven't mentioned for those games and
even the ones I didn't mention it's
honestly impressive how a series that
stuck to the same formula for years has
managed to Captivate new people with
each entry for completely different
reasons
ultimately as a sort of final note which
I can now say after playing them flaws
and all there really isn't a bad Metal
Gear Solid game
well
maybe one
Metal Gear survive was a game I added in
at the last minute which is ironic as
the whole game feels like it was cobbled
together at the last minute at the time
I'd worked on this video every day for a
month and a half straight it was ready
to call it quits after finishing mgs5
plus the review scores of the game were
less than stellar and I kind of wanted
to end the video on a good note but I
decided to play it just to say that I
did which is when I discovered how
important this was to the series Metal
Gear survived as konami's first crack in
Metal Gear Solid post Kojima due to the
dispute a lot of people had sided with
the little guy and saw Konami as the
ones who were wrong as such this put a
lot of pressure on the company as even
though the main creative is gone they
still had the IP and many were wondering
what this series would look like after
this and well they got their answer
Metal Gear survive is not a terrible
game but it's certainly not great it's
got some interesting ideas and because
of how it's structured it's really going
to resonate with those that enjoy it in
fact there were even times I was having
fun with the game the issue is that all
of that pertains to the gameplay the
story man where to start we're probably
at the beginning Survivor starts around
the time of ground zeros where mother is
attacked by the XLF we could see some of
these surviving msf members going back
to the base to bury their comrades
joining them is a man named good luck
who has taken interest in a specific
person that of course would be us which
is where we begin our customization
survive's protagonist is called the
captain and you can create them however
you like I didn't realize until later
though that I made an exact copy of
venom snake but with a mustache so for
the sake of headcanon we'll say this is
Venom snake's twin the captain oddly
enough this fit says just like venom
snake the captain loses their left arm
too as right after the attack happened a
wormhole appeared over mother base and
sucked up everything nearby the captain
managed to barely escape the portal but
got Bioshock infinited in the process
and now their arm is gone according to
good luck though our arm mysteriously
grew back unlike Elizabeth though we
won't get any interesting powers like
opening tears into other dimensions in
fact all we get is a death date is now
we're infected and slowly dying in order
to find a cure we have to complete good
Luck's Mission so we have no choice but
to go inside once we enter we see this
world known as dite is very run down and
dying inside here is an xof Soldier
known as Reeve initially our
conversation with him is less than
inviting but he'll eventually come
around and help us that we can get out
of here before that happens we run into
the main enemies of the game The
Wanderers which are these zombie-like
enemies with crystals protruding out of
their head apparently these wanders used
to be humans before being infected by
some virus which turns them into these
things once we make it to a safe place
we find an AI pod named Virgil who'll
repeat what good luck said about the
mission and location our first objective
being to Rendezvous with the Karen core
a group of people that came in before us
but they don't seem to be present so we
have to find these memory boards in
hopes of not only repairing some of
Virgil's memory but finding out where
this core went to say metal year
survives an allegory for hell is an
understatement as this game's interest
in The Divine Comedy is pretty on the
nose our AI is called Virgil in
reference to Dante's brother Virgil dite
is supposed to reference the city of dis
which encompasses the lower circles of
hell Karen cores derived from Caron the
ferryman who sells a boat across the
rivers of Hell upon getting to a new map
in the game good luck will congratulate
us for reaching the next Circle as in
the next circle of hell and even calls
the objective Beatrice who is Dante's
wife like I said it's pretty
heavy-handed but it makes sense given
how hellish this place feels plus it
meant that all my knowledge of Dante's
Inferno didn't go to waste so far though
the start is lukewarm at best I wasn't
exactly enthralled to be in another
dimension though as it feels a bit too
much for the likes of metal gear say
what you will about Rising Clue's
connection to the series this game could
have honestly done without the metal
gear name as the only threads that
connected are the attack on mother base
and the occasional reference to Nano
machines outside of that it's its own
Standalone game which isn't a problem
but not only should you not expect a
metal gear experience when first jumping
into this but I also think removing
Metal Gear from the name could have
given it better publicity sadly our
first objective didn't exactly increase
my interest in the game either as these
memory board missions are boring all we
receive upon retrieving them is a few
tapes from a couple members of the Caron
core but it's exactly as you would
expect the beginning tapes are happy and
lighthearted would eventually descend
into fear and panic as the crew is taken
over and then killed over the course of
the tapes now admittedly these are
spread out throughout the game so you
won't get all the tapes right away but
they could have been used to show what's
going on behind the scenes but the team
didn't capitalize on that none of the
information is important outside of one
part where one of the teams says that
someone named Seth had joined their
ranks so that's quite important later so
I'm glad his arrival was mentioned but
out of the 30 minutes I spent listening
to those tapes that was the only notable
piece of info eventually Reeve and the
captain will see a helicopter arrive via
Wormhole and crash into the ground the
captain decides to go alone and check
for survivors while Reeve stays back as
he hurt his leg on the way to the base
the best way to explain Reed's role in
the story is that he's the voice of the
captain since our character is silent
the game needs someone to have a back
and forth with and Reeve is our guy for
that all of these conversations also
happen through text slides and I don't
think I need to explain how I feel about
them what bothers me most though is that
the game has cutscenes but refuses to
use them there's one that really stuck
out towards the end of the game where
Virgil meets with the crew and discusses
their plan to take down the big bad guy
but it starts in a cutscene and that
goes into those Tech slides again
another is a bit earlier when someone
kidnaps someone else but it's all played
out via the text again it really takes
you out of the experience it makes you
feel like the game didn't have any
thought or love put into it once the
captain makes it to the crash though he
finds a nurse named Miranda who managed
to survive the helicopter managed to
crash inside the Dallas as well so they
have to get her out before she dies this
dust is a toxic substance that can only
be traversed safely with the help of an
oxygen mask and since Miranda doesn't
have one we need to get her out
immediately after she's rescued Virgil
will task us to make a wormhole device
that when power will be able to generate
a wormhole for us allowing us to leave
dite it's discovered though that the
team doesn't have enough power and thus
needs more energy to power it which is
when a person in Gruen comes on the
comms and says everything good luck told
us was a lie good luck wanted us to help
him for his own selfish power-hungry
reasons and Gruen here was able to put a
stop to it as good luck apparently
committed suicide but if the
illuminati-esque picture next to his
name didn't give it away it's clear that
Gruen is lying out of his ass but we
don't know what he wants just yet after
a few more retrieval missions we
discovered that someone else has been
found in the wilderness Miranda though
decided to go alone and save the person
herself yeah the nurse in heels who has
no combat experiences decided to venture
into the dust to find the person usually
I would say that this shows How brave
she is if she's willing to put herself
in danger in order to save this person
but this is just stupid thankfully Reeve
who hasn't done anything in seven hours
decides to finally get up and go save
her while we find the person who came
through the Wormhole it's learned that
this person is a kid named Chris to
finally round out our crew at least for
a bit later we also have to find another
person who's a cop named Nick each
person within our group are pretty one
note in regards to their personality but
they play it well Reeve is the hard ass
soldier who wants to go home Miranda
acts like a very dedicated nurse and
wants to see the good in people while
also trying to find ways to cure the
wanders Chris is a kid and does kid
things and Nick is the comedic relief I
think my only wish is that they were
more involved with the game outside of
these talks they can help around the
base and do talk on occasion but they
are pretty much irrelevant outside of
that which is a bit disappointing as
there is a few Sparks of Personality
here that could have been more developed
while doing these missions the player
will inevitably encounter the Lord of
dust this absolute monstrosity of a
creature that walks around the dust and
stoms anything in its path the Lord of
dust is the antagonist of the game and
is something the team will eventually
have to fight but just like the
characters it's pretty irrelevant
throughout most of the story and even
when you meet it its existence can
pretty much be ignored the Lord of dust
and never attempts to attack you so all
I had to do was make sure its legs
didn't stop me but even then it moves so
slow that you could just walk under it
with minimal issue with the basic crew
at the base though let's talk about the
gameplay it's probably the one thing
you'll have the most questions about
survive is the biggest departure from
the Metal Gear series in terms of
gameplay Rising was pretty out there but
this is on a whole nother level as the
name suggests survive is a survival game
you need to manage your food and water
intake as well as scavenge materials to
craft weapons and gear it takes a lot of
inspiration from Fallout 4 as you'll be
picking up anything that isn't tied down
to the geometry and throwing it in your
backpack wood planks Nails jugs buckets
all of it can be picked up and turned
into materials this not only helps with
the crafting of those aforementioned
weapons and armor but it also helps
create structures at base camp like mgs5
we have our own mother base called base
camp just like mother base our current
crew can also help around the base by
putting them in select teams like base
development and medical creating a
proper base with defense is going to
help but I never found the defense stuff
to be worth the hassle as you only get
attacked I think three times throughout
the main story so it's better to focus
on the important things like workbenches
and campfires first and then focus on
the defensives later talking about
defenses leads us into the main gameplay
mechanic of the game and that's wave
defense and by God does this game love
wave defense almost everything you do in
this game will require you to defend a
position for a set amount of time it's
not a bad gameplay system but it's
extremely overdone placing Wormhole
devices together energy requires you to
defend it activating a teleporter so you
can fast travel also requires you to
defend it the only time you aren't doing
a wave defense is when you're walking
around the open world or collecting
memory boards these defenses though are
on the complete opposite sides of the
Spectrum in regards to Quality some like
this one in the main story have you
defend a position for a whole 15 minutes
it was intense and definitely a
highlight of my playthrough but the
other regular fast travel defenses are
extremely subpar for some odd reason you
can completely negate all the difficulty
here just by killing The Wanderers first
when the device activates it attracts
all the enemies nearby but the game
doesn't seem to spawn any new enemies it
only seems to attract current ones so
like a normal person if you decide to
kill them first build your defenses and
then defend the Wormhole you'll have
stuff like this where the most
threatening enemy I had was one Wanderer
who was crawling on the floor this isn't
even a cherry-picked example as this was
the area before I killed them there is
at least 60 enemies surrounding this
space so activating the teleporter would
have been more exciting but I didn't do
that because I would just be setting up
my defenses only to have them destroyed
plus it's not like I can make more as
the game doesn't let you now I'll be the
first to admit I don't play many
Survival Games valheim Conan Exile sons
of the forest this genre isn't my usual
Forte so let me know if this is just a
standard for these games but you can't
craft anything or change gear on the fly
all the crafting has to be done at the
base you don't even have a small
crafting book that allows you to make
super basic items so whatever you take
with you is what you keep you also can't
swap equipment unless you're at the base
either so if you decide to test out a
new weapon and realize it's too slow for
your liking you have to go all the way
back to the base just to switch it
that's also why the game only drops
materials and blueprints and not actual
gear as if it did it wouldn't matter as
you couldn't switch it out anyway
furthermore placing things down is
permanent if you accidentally place a
fence or barricade down but realize it's
in the wrong spot or was the wrong
defensive item too bad as it's stuck
there you can remove it by dismantling
the item but it permanently deletes it
and doesn't give you materials or the
item itself back you also can't repair
existing structures at least that I'm
aware of as I wasn't able to throughout
the whole game survive also removes
these structures for some reason which
is something I still don't understand I
had this bright idea to surround the
Wormhole device with these sandbags is a
sort of last line of defense but once
the first wave was over the device
exploded which apparently removed them
completely I'm assuming it's because
they were too close to it but the game
does it during the teleporters too which
is strange as there's no reason to
remove these items this wouldn't have
been an issue either but due to the
aforementioned problems it's not like oh
damn the game removed my sandbags that's
alright I'll just make more it's more so
oh so I just lost a third of my defenses
and I can't make any more wonderful
besides the defenses you'll also be
exploring the open world and it's pretty
boring on the map are circles yellow is
the main quest green are distress calls
and blew our points of interest like
resources and teleporters but outside of
that there is nothing else your crew can
give you side quests which they claim
are favors you need to do for them but
it's more of just the previous examples
put on your map there are no actual side
quests in this game it's just more of
the same the blue circles did help
though as you're able to get Kuba in the
game's currency and supplies and you'll
need this to craft the best weapon in
the game offense fences not only serve
as barricades but they also allow you to
use thrusting weapons through them so
you can kill wonders from behind the
wall these are your absolute bread and
butter when it comes to defense or just
general combat you can get heavy
one-handed and two-handed weapons with
thrusting weapons with fences never let
me down Plus getting close to these
wanders is almost a death sentence as
you can't really stagger them is they'll
just swing through your attacks and
likely still unlock you thankfully there
is a Dodge button which was extremely
helpful so there is at least some way to
combat this the thing is though is that
the Dodge is a part of a perk in your
skill tree I don't mind the skill tree
but I do find it odd how there's only
one skill tree throughout the whole game
until after you beat the game game where
you can then Branch out and experiment
with different skill trees I think it
would have been nice to have the skill
trees introduced earlier but also make
the cost to level up cheaper so you're
not spreading yourself thin in the early
and middle game the one positive to this
though is that there is a real lack of
microtransactions which surprise me
seeing is the first thing Konami did
with the metal gear IP after Kojima left
was making mgs3 Pachinko machine I
figured this would be filled with
schemes and methods to get you to pay
money to be fair it's not like it's
non-existent but there's definitely less
than I thought there is a weekly item
shop which didn't bother me since it's
all cosmetic and even the Pay to Win
things are boosters which I didn't
really consider necessary but it does
get a little bit egregious though when
you realize you have to pay money for
multiple Recon teams which are similar
to those dispatch missions in mgs5 to be
fair you also needed to do that for that
game as well as I believe the number of
squads was tied to the number of fobs
you had which was bought with real money
but you get a decent amount of teams to
start with unlike survive which has one
but still while it was pretty annoying
it's not as bad as I thought it was
going to be as you can get through the
whole game without it and they
thankfully didn't tie the material cases
to the coins which are found throughout
the world and are rewards for weekly and
daily quests that give you random
materials so we can all breathe the
Cyber leaf that they didn't monetize
these loot boxes too
I've talked about survive's gameplay
more than any in this video thus far and
that's for a few reasons one is likely
because the vast majority of people
including Metal Gear fans haven't
touched this game so you should probably
understand what's going on here the
other reason I talked about the gameplay
so much was because there wasn't a whole
lot else to talk about there are 22 main
missions in survive and getting Nick our
last main crew member was mission 12.
we're more than halfway through the game
and that's all that's happened the thing
is that I'm not even skipping over
details again sometimes I skip over
certain events in the game as they
aren't necessary to talk about I've done
it in all my videos and even in this one
in between sniperwolf and Raven was a
boss fight against liquid snake and a
Hindi Chopper I didn't talk about this
because story wise nothing happens
liquid taunt Solid Snake we blow up the
chopper and then we move on there was no
need to bring attention to it since
nothing said was important and the
flight itself wasn't necessary to
mention since liquid is going to survive
anyway I didn't want to take up more of
your time than I already am so I just
decided to skip it the thing is is I
have not done that for survive I have
covered every morsel of information we
received and this is all I have to show
for it this normal really wouldn't be a
problem but since the game plays at the
Forefront for over 90 percent of the
game it's the only thing that players
can look forward to a game can have a
mediocre story but good gameplay and so
be considered great the same is true for
the opposite but it's only for games
that have a healthy balance of both it's
why some people still play mgs5 despite
not liking the story because the
gameplay was that good or why some
people may enjoy the earlier games
despite the clunky mechanics as their
stories they tell are wonderful since
survive story is absent for 90 of the
experience though the only thing you can
look forward to is the gameplay and that
on its own leaves a lot to be desired
fast forwarding to where the story
continues eventually we find enough
energy to generate a proper Wormhole
allowing us to get out of here to
actually spawn when we need to defend
the Wormhole device what generates power
which leads to one of the few times the
base itself is attacked defending the
base is admittedly quite fun especially
since you can use more defenses than
what you can carry I do sort of wish
that the crew actually helped though
unlike mgs5 all of your crew are
invincible allies that claim that
they're helping you while you do all the
work I can understand why people like
Miranda and Chris don't help but I think
it would have been cool for the people
you put on the Recon team to help you
defend the base you could also claim
that it would be weird for Reeve to help
out in case he died but you can also
find no-name soldiers like the ones on
mother base and they don't help either
while the wave defense stuff is really
tedious at times they already leaned
into this thing so why not go further
with it having your crew be another line
of defense would have been interesting
and having more base camp defense
missions would have helped Elevate the
gameplay experience after we
successfully defend the base Gruen tells
us we need to use more power claiming
that we can't go home if we don't Gruen
is lying as he actually wants the Lord
of dust to just arrive to go through the
portal in his he wants to bring it into
our world and then harness its power we
won't let that happen but we also can
stay here so we take Chris and go while
the others go on ahead the captain seems
to really love suspenseful action
instead of running away he looks at the
giant creature for minutes at a time
which of course causes him to fall trip
and almost drop Chris multiple times the
crew then makes it through the portal
before the Lord of dust can enter but
they realize it's not home but rather
another circle of hell as good luck puts
it before he killed himself he recorded
a few tapes for us to listen to which is
when he explains that his main objective
and the reason he sent us into dite was
so that we could destroy the Lord of
dust we also learned that dite is not an
alternate Dimension so to speak but a
version of our current world in the
future apparently in the 22nd century
the world was overtaken by a virus that
started from Nano machines these Nano
machines eventually evolved into what's
called dread dust which is that gray
particle substance we have to cross
constantly eventually this dread dust
evolved and took on a form of sentience
which eventually gave rise to the
wanders in The Lord of dust this Lord of
dust is attracted to large amounts of
energy so its plan is to use a wormhole
to go into our world and kill everyone
this world that we're in now is a world
of metal gear in which that happened the
Lord of dust is creating a constant time
Loop that resets when it destroys the
world so we have to break this cycle
this new circle of hell that we're in
though is actually just the Africa map
from mgs5 and you can tell because our
new bases were the devil's house used to
be it's even got the same tunnel and
it's also why I think the dust was
created so that players couldn't tell
that they were on the same map with
reused Assets Now that we've made it to
the next step of the plan good luck
tells us through his post-mortem
messages that we're here to find a
weapon that will destroy the Lord of
dust but first we gotta go find more
memory boards at this point in the story
I was honestly getting excited but doing
these memory boards kills all the
enjoyment I had as they're not only the
same exact Mission but the tapes as
we've already discussed aren't that
interesting to listen to I want to
clarify that while I was excited it was
incredibly minor if my enjoyment at this
point was as low as a concrete Street my
enjoyment now was about as high as a
speed bump it's higher than it was but
even some of the series worst moments
were better than this after finding the
memory board we also come across two
guys named Seth and Dan Seth was in a
picture good luck out of us so the
captain seems to know him well but
seeing as he can't talk we don't really
know according to Seth though the weapon
they were working on that could destroy
the Lord of dust was none other than
sohilanthropists I guess we know what
happened after mission 51 as it was left
here in the African Wilderness Dan ends
up leaving as we try to kill Seth but
ends up coming back to Ambush us while
we look at sahilanthropists this is once
again another example of the game just
refusing to use cutscenes as it cuts
right to the text while Dan holds us up
with a shotgun Dan claims that Seth is
the bad guy but Seth claims that Dan is
the bad guy so clearly one of them is
lying but before we can talk more we're
ambushed by a whole three Wanderers so
Dan has to run away now that we know the
location of Saw philanthropist though we
can use it against the Lord of dust but
we need to extract it from its current
position which leads to another wave
defense Mission but it's actually one I
liked as it's that 15 minute one I
talked about earlier after we extract
its head we discovered that Seth was
actually the bad guy all along and
decided to kidnap Chris sooner or later
someone was going to betray us it just
sucks at its Seth since the time in
between his arrival and his betrayal was
literally two hours I barely spoke to
the guy outside of that one time we
found him and all of a sudden He's the
bad guy according to Seth he is also a
Wanderer but a more advanced version of
the wanders which is what we learned
about the dread dust and Nano machines
and how they evolved into these
creatures Reeve once again decides to
come back into the script and put some
effort in by coming up with a plan to
take down Seth the plan is to have the
captain distract him while Reeve puts a
bullet in him this ended up actually
surprising me although I think it just
shows how low my expectations were at
this point as Not only was there an
actual cutscene I was honestly expecting
Seth to just die right then and there
instead he ends up transforming into one
of those mortar enemies but is then put
down by the captain a few minutes later
so he still ends up dying anyway after
this is where Seth is replaced with
dance that we can at least have a new
member on the team but seeing as the
game is about to end in a few hours and
the cast doesn't talk outside these
cutscenes Dan is pretty much irrelevant
to the story thanks to Seth though
Virgil was able to repair some of its
memories and tell us that the captain
has about 12 days to live before the
infection overcomes their body the only
way to stop the infection is to defeat
the Lord of dust so we have to prepare
for its arrival the plan is to construct
these archaea blades that will hold the
beast in place while we charge them
railgun to shoot its weak spot all that
is going to take time to charge so it's
time for the final wave defense this was
probably the most fun I had with the
game as it really shows the depth it has
as Chris gives you a lot of defenses to
use there are dozens of barriers machine
guns electric fences and it was honestly
pretty fun using the machine guns on
hundreds of wanders while they swarm
almost like the beaches of Normandy was
great but it just shows how limited the
current gameplay system is since we
can't carry this many items with us so
this kind of excitement can only be
achieved in this mission
joining us although only through
cutscenes are the rest of the crew is
they decide to stay behind and defeat
this thing while Chris Goes Through the
Wormhole and escapes originally the plan
was for all of us to go through it while
Virgil stays behind but the team decided
it's all or nothing as they want to make
sure the Lord of dust is actually dead
so Chris is being sent out with all the
info we've gathered on dite and the
dread dust in the hope that in the
future Chris can come back and get us
out I knew this was coming as there was
clearly a post game and survive can't
exactly exist without dite I just find
it funny how the whole objective was to
escape only for us to stay behind anyway
regardless we fight the beast's Army and
then deliver a railgun shot from
satellantrabis through its weak spot
however it didn't seem to work but
Virgil has a plan apparently since the
Lord of dust originated from Nano
machines it's not organic thus it
doesn't understand organic Concepts like
death as such Virgil is going to go
inside the Beast and teach it what it
means to die so it can experience death
as unnecessarily complicated as it
sounds it is at least Very Metal Gear to
do this though survive takes from Peace
Walker and has another AI pod sacrifice
itself in order to save the world it's
supposed to be this emotional where we
say goodbye to our friend while also
showing us that our actions affected
Virgil as it was able to understand
human Concepts thanks to our talks with
it and for what it's worth it does at
least work in conveying that sort of
emotion however Virgil is integral to
the gameplay so obviously it's not going
to die as the Rogan really wounded its
casing while completely destroyed the
Lord of dust Virgil also plays us one
last audio log from good luck in its own
that Chris was good luck from the past
since the Lord of dust was creating a
Time Loop the events of the world are
also in a Time Loop good luck as a kid
would be sent into detail only to be
thrown out during this fight but instead
of going back to his original time he
was sent back to 1943 so he was able to
create a Time Loop by repeating the same
events over and over again he would work
his way through the company find the
captain and instruct him to defeat the
Lord of dust during that is when the
captain would meet Chris who would then
join the group only to be forced through
the portal later going to arrive back in
1943 and repeat this cycle as we talked
about before though defeating the Lord
of dust would stop this psycho which is
exactly what happens now that it's dead
the Lord of dust will no longer come
into our world and kill everyone only to
go back into the past and do it again
plus since it's dead the infection that
plagued the captain disappears so now
they won't die long story short the crew
of the base camp saved the world from
constant destruction the series has also
come full circle as the Lord of dust was
born of dread dust which started as Nano
machines so now we've gone from using it
as a plot device to explain unexplained
things to actually killing a nano
machine incredible
all in all survive isn't great I won't
harp on the gameplay too much as I've
already done that quite a bit but the
story is pretty disappointing it's
absent for most of the experience and
only picks up in the final hours of the
game thanks to most of our objectives
being repetitive memory board and
defense missions our crew has some shred
of a personality but seeing as they too
are largely absent for most of the story
they're never given the time to shine
they also have to disappear in order for
the captain to do all the work which is
why Reeve doesn't do anything for the
first seven hours of gameplay and the
same goes for the rest of them the only
time the crew actually worked together
was right here at the end when they
activate the blades that trap the Lord
of dust outside of that scene though
they all run away so the captain can
defend the base by himself or the script
forces them to separate like when the
wanders were about to attack Dan earlier
when a game is this obvious and what
it's trying to do you get taken out of
the experience and there was rarely a
time when the game managed to bring me
back in survive story is the worst in
the series and probably would have done
better critically if it didn't include
the metal gear name in its title Rising
wasn't that connected to metal gear and
is even considered not Canon by many but
still manage to not only conclude the
story of a beloved care character but
also kept things connected by
referencing past events like the
Patriots and sop survive is only a metal
gear game and name alone which severely
heard a lot of its impact on the gaming
industry but even as a standalone
non-metal gear title I can't imagine it
would have stuck around for long anyway
as I said at the top of this section I
wasn't going to cover survive and I
still wish I didn't waste four days
getting this part of the video finished
but it was necessary to talk about in
detail so you could see what the series
is today even if many want to say that
the series ended 7 years ago with the
phantom pain realistically it was five
things to survive this is where one of
the most beloved series of all time now
sits at least that's what I would have
said had this video released a month ago
the reason PlayStation showcase showed
us that not only is there a mgs3 remake
in the works but also a master
collection that has the first three
games together on one disc it's
apparently called the volume 1 which
makes me hopeful for a volume too as you
already know the first game I want in
that second collection whether or not
the Remake will be any good remains to
be seen plus konami's track record for
Metal Gear games hasn't exactly been
great so a lot of people are worried
that their remake of arguably the best
game in the series would ruin its
reputation even without that
announcement though this stain on the
series could now possibly topple what
Kojima has built it would have to take a
Monumental amount of mistakes to truly
tarnish this series which is a good
thing as Metal Gear is one of the
greatest series of all time and now I
truly understand why a few months ago
all I knew is that there was this guy
named snake along with a few other guys
named snake but now it feels like I've
opened my third eye Metal Gear is a
series that is Rich with lore and a
story that almost makes your brain hurt
trying to piece it all together but if
you manage to actually understand it
you'll come to realize how incredible
this series is it's filled with dozens
of themes and messages that are not only
extremely important but some are even
more relevant today than they were when
it first released it's a series of games
that not only makes you think about the
actual story but also the real world
ramifications of its ideas nuclear war
is a devastating creature and Metal Gear
shows how it can corrupt people mgs1
talked about your genes and how they
don't Define you mgs2 was about passing
down things that aren't your genes like
culture ideas and memories mgs3 showed
us that the times change our perceptions
of people all the time and how our
enemies today may not be our enemies
tomorrow mgs4 showed the harmful effects
of 4 as well as the negative effects on
a world heavily reliant on technology
peacewalker talked about peace and if it
was truly possible and mgs5 dealt with
revenge in pain and how those things can
corrupt someone and change their outlook
on life it's a series full of enriching
stories and messages that it's no wonder
people are still talking about it all
these years later despite this series
being radio silent for over five years
people are more than ever talking about
their story and experiences with metal
gear and this video is just another one
of them talking about Metal Gear
thoroughly is a complicated task is
there's so much to discuss but I hope I
was able to get my point across even if
it took five hours to do so thanks to
the community of fans it's garnered over
the years Metal Gear hasn't been able to
disappear from the public eye and it
likely won't for a very long time as
there truly is nothing like it while the
complicated story was fun to dive into
my favorite part was connecting it back
to the themes of each game but out of
all them there was one that really
resonated with me the most it's just not
only a message to the fans from Kojima
but it's also about the series Legacy
it's about never giving up and
continuing to live our lives regardless
of what they may be it's also about
enjoying that life that we have in ever
settling for Less
or as the game puts it never be game
over
thanks for watching
thank you for watching today and I hope
you enjoyed kept your waiting huh I've
been waiting to make that joke for two
months so spare me the eye rolls the
next video will likely be on spec Ops
the Line I've been meaning to hit that
game up for a while and I also believe
it's also got a similar anti-war message
so it'll connect to Metal Gear quite
well don't worry though you won't have
to wait another two months for that to
come out as the game in its respective
video will not take nearly as long as
this so we'll be all right I know I've
said it a ton but thank you if you
manage to make it this far I did not
expect this video to be this long I
figured it'd be three hours at most but
that didn't happen it's definitely the
longest video I've ever made and will
hopefully be that way forever as this
was a tour to make at times but it was
worth it either way like the video if
you enjoy and subscribe if you're new
thank you to my returning viewers for
coming back to another video and take
care everyone
goodbye